and then stand and join with
representative Thomas as we pledge
allegiance
[Music]
to thank you good morning everyone I'm
Michael Bose and as chair of the house
science technology and energy committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2012-04 this public body is authorized
to meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to science technology
and energy committee executive session
on pending legislation may be held at
any
time please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
this meeting should call Tu 71
366 or
3600 or email
HCS ledge. state.
n. us let me repeat that phone number
since I butchered it the first time
27136 in the event the public is unable
to access access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled the staff who is assisting
us today is Jennifer for the committee
researcher let us start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to no
law that I will ask our clerk Fred PL to
call the role but before I ask him to do
that I just want to say welcome back
Fred it's great to have you here to see
you okay please call the RO yes chairman
V you're
here representative Thomas Vice chair
here representative Harry
here anybody in the room with
you yeah my wife's in the room with
me representative here in the room
representative burer here
representa here
representative I hear in the committee
room representative Bernardi here in the
committee
room representative Campbell president
in the committee room representative
pres in the committee room how I do with
a
name
aw representative white I am here and
I'm alone
representa
represent yeah he uh he's GNA here let
me turn my video on here
okay represent K here
representative here by myself I'm
Al
Representative Vincent excuse me I am
here did you call my name I I couldn't
tell represent oxenham are you here oxam
thank you yes I'm present and I'm
alone representative McGee I'm present
and alone representative MC Williams I'm
here by myself represent
CHR yes I'm here and also by myself
representative I'm here here and alone
in a room represent
Pas representative
Pas unmute
yourself Mr chairman okay thank you Mr
chairman yes represent Representative
Vincent uh I just wanted to point out
that uh I didn't have a zoom link so uh
representative McGee sent it to me and I
noticed on my screen I have
representative cat McGee at the bottom
um I just wanted to make that
clear thank you I appreciate that I
think we can fix that and we can tell
the difference too and we can probably
tell the difference between you
guys she she's much better looking oh
that's for sure that's for
sure yeah there's a rename function here
so I'm gonna type
in but
Representative Vincent is much more
explosive can he sing
explosive that's an
interesting okay I've changed your name
you're now Representative Vincent so
thank
you okay before we get started this
morning uh I have a couple of
announcements uh number one I want
to to let representative Troy mner know
that all of our thoughts and prayers are
with you and your wife in a in a
difficult time I know for the two of you
we're happy to hear she came out of
surgery last
night in in good fashion and we wish her
a speedy recovery if she be in ICU for
24 hours to go to watch her then they
feel that she'll be recovered by
hopefully tomorrow night I could bring
her home excellent excellent news well
we got lucky we are we are hoping uh
that she re recovers quickly and our
thoughts and prayers are with you thank
you she's a tough lady and she'll
probably be at at work in three days and
make sure can't see me makes it the same
thing she calls a Wonder
Woman the other announcement is uh we
have a meeting next Monday February
22nd and originally we had one bill the
final bill assigned to this committee to
discuss but because we had to suspend or
recess the public hearings on two other
bills HB 213 and HB
315 on Monday we will be
resuming
the I just realized that sounds kind of
funny since we're using Zoom
resuming anyway we will be resuming the
public hearings on 213 and 3:15 11
o'clock for 2113 and 1:00 for 3
50 as a result of that the exact session
activity that I had originally planned
for that day will be substantially
delayed so I have resumed reserved
rather a room for us on Monday March
8th and I want you all to realize that
that will be probably exclusively an
exec session day so we'll have to exec
all the bills that we haven't
exec prior to that on that day because
on March
11th the house rules say that we have to
have all of our bills finished and done
with so March 8th is going to be an
extremely important day I hope everybody
will be here and I hope we can get
through all the exact exact sessions
that we'll have to get through that
day one other uh representative Thomas
thank M do we do we have the room here
on March 8 for as long as it takes to
exec all the
bills uh we have the room from 9 to 5
will that be enough time to exec all the
bills that's kind of up to the to the
committee I certainly hope so because if
not then we'll have to make other
arrangements and I don't know what those
arrangements will be but thank you for
that
question okay one more uh quick item I
was having a conversation with a friend
of mine the other day about the rather
difficult circumstances that uh the
people in the state of Texas have gone
through in the course of the last
several days with a kind of a collapse
of their electricity
Market and my friend was pointing out
that Texas
unlike ISO New England and and other
markets around the country
has no capacity
Market a capacity Market really is kind
of like an insurance
policy you pay a little each month to
make sure that when things go wrong
backup generators can step in to fill
the
Gap well Tech Texas didn't have that uh
ability because they have no cap
capacity Market they have plenty of
generation available in Texas but
because they weren't paying people to be
on stand
by uh they weren't able to ramp up
quickly and get their their Market uh
moving again there were high price
signals that should have pred generators
to fire up but if they're not staffed it
takes time to fire up they just weren't
prepared to do so
quickly which they would have been able
to do had they had a capacity Market no
a capacity Market though really isn't
just a capacity Market it's really a
reliability
Market that's the way we should think of
the capacity Market because it is an
insurance
policy and it relies on Basel load
OnDemand dispatchable resources not
intermittent resources to get us through
an
emergency and that's a good reminder
that if you put all your eggs in one
basket you can be in
trouble it would be like uh investing
all your retirement funds in one
stock if that stock is doing well you're
doing well but if that stock goes bad
there goes all your retirement
Savings Mr chairman I must protest that
that is not the facts of what happened
in
Texas of what went offline was natural
gas that
froze that that may be true but uh hang
on a second let me finish what I was
trying to say here what I'm what I'm
getting at is an all electric energy
sector would create a massive single
point of failure for our entire
economy and I don't think that's a risk
that we want to take and Texas I think
is a good warning sign for all of us
that uh you can't allow your reliability
sector to be rotted
out little by little over
time in the pursuit of some particular
fad of the day so with that I would like
to uh get this show on the road it's now
9:14 we're already few minutes Mr
chairman I have my hand up J why okay go
ahead yeah let the chairman call on
us uh yes representative McGee did you
have a question yeah thank you um I
noted that you gave us four um bills
that you were considering for exec if we
have time in between sessions today and
I really appreciate that and it looks
like we have a full exec session
scheduled for the 8th but I was
wondering if you also had plans for
Monday if there's extra time so we could
get that on the books and be ready over
the weekend for anything that might be
exec on the
22nd yes uh we will be executing on the
22nd time
permitting representative Cali pittz all
I was gonna do all I want you to do is
ask fa if when the invest there's an
investigation right now when that
investigation is done in Texas I would
really like to have somebody come and
talk to us and tell us exactly what
happened why it happened and what
they're going to do to uh remedy the
situation once that investigation is
complete so I would ask that you keep
that in the back of your mind good idea
I appreciate that suggestion
representative samage uh yes thank you
Mr chairman uh Mr chairman I would like
to just point out two two errors in the
calendar that just came out the two
bills that are in the regular calendar
vote totals are
incorrect for for one bill the 614 there
is no vote vote tally it just be uh 11
to9 and for the second uh Bill
624 there is a vote tell that's
incorrect that should be
1110 okay I will let our committee
committee researcher and our admin know
um that those numbers were reported
incorrectly to the to the clerk okay I
don't know how that happened but it's
not our responsibility I think it's
handled by the committee researcher and
the admin but I'll talk to them about it
and see what what we can do to make sure
that that doesn't happen again
appreciate it Mr chair my question was
specifically which bills would be exact
on Monday because I know you have a at
least a plan of what is coming or what
you're going to be doing so that we
could also do that work over the weekend
and be prepared for those exact sessions
I know we may not get to the I will send
that information to representative ssuch
I don't have it at my fingertips right
at the moment thank you I appreciate
that all right so let's now open the
public
hearing on HB 106 and I would like to
First recognize the prime sponsor of the
bill represent representative Timothy
Lang of sand Borton so representative
Lang be recognized
here
okay representative Lang you are now
allowed to talk and the floor is yours
for three minutes thank you Mr chairman
thank you committee members for taking
my testimony um I am representative Tim
Lang from the towns of Tilton and samton
I serve as a chair of fishing game uh
and I am before you on House Bill
106 um this house bill if you the
testimony is going to be kind of a
repeat for you if you if you've been on
Science and Tech for more than one year
um this bill comes back as is a redo
from last year House Bill
1402 which was intrm studied and
recommended for future legislation on a
vote of 14 to1 um in in a weird twist of
fate today is exactly one year to the
day since we inum studied this bill on
the house floor um and represent McGee
there spoke against this bill and then
in another twist fate she is a
co-sponsor on this bill with me this
year um and what this bill does is it it
removes the one megabit me megawatt cap
sorry megabit I'm a technologist so I
think that way sometimes um it removes
the one megawatt cap for a limited set
of circumstances those circumstances
involve what is a new classification of
generator called um a minicipal host um
a municipal host generator is a a a a a
solar or or a clean energy um generator
that solely sells power to uh political
subdivisions and the issue may you may
be asking why I've limited this bill and
having having served my third term here
now and having sat on Science and Tech
at least a dozen times um one of the
things I I was kind of amazed when I was
doing my research is I went back to see
when the first net metering bill or net
Energy bill was submitted and that bill
was submitted in in
2002 by representative Pitts on this
committee um and and so this is a
conversation that's been going on a long
time um and like I said in my in my term
in the house I've sat on Science and
Tech several many times um and one of
the conversations that always comes
around talks about data um and the data
what's it going to do to our grid what's
it going to do to the rate payers what's
going to do um to the to the U Market um
and so what what I offer you as this
bill as a as a as a point is is two
points number one this gives us the
ability to do a pilot project a and see
what the results will be uh in a in some
limited circumstances without throwing
the doors wide open but it'll allow us
to to expand our clean energy and green
energy Market um under a li limited set
of circumstances and then take a take a
breath and look back and see what that
did to our infrastructure um a lot of
the conversation I've heard in the past
in this committee around around Net
metering bills was always about cost and
and and actions on the grid and we
always try to extrapolate what other
states have done and how it relates to
the Hampshire and here this will give us
an opportunity to actually see what's
going to happen in New Hampshire um this
would allow towns and cities to be able
to put up um arrays and group net meter
all the political subdivisions in this T
in that town and I I use as an example
um the town of bosin would be maybe a
good example um the town of bosin has
not only it Town Hall it's Town Police
Department and fire department and
library it also happens to contain um
the political subdivision for the County
nursing home and the county jail so in
and of itself the town of Osa may not be
able to get a good return on investment
for the ability to uh put up a a large
solar array to pay the electrical cost
for those town-owned buildings but what
this bill would allow them to do is
contract with the um County as as well
because they're contained within the
borders for those two larger facilities
and be able to put up um an array and
sell the any any power that they're not
using um over to the um the county and
and to offset the cost of electricity
for both the nursing home and the jail
this would apply to any uh my own town I
again we have you know we're a smaller
town of of of about 2 200 voters um and
in that in in that we've got a small
police Department small fire department
um Library uh Town Hall but um we also
have a school district that's a Regional
School District that we have one of the
elementary schools in here so again my
town if it felt it was uh they can get
the return on of investment for them and
the savings necessary they could put up
an array and um and also offload include
the load for the school system in there
and sell that power to the school system
at lesser than retail rates and uh it
would save the school district money as
well and again so so it's a second
benefit of this bill is that not only do
we expand clean energy we get a pilot
project of uh what this would do to our
infrastructure we also have potential of
doing cost savings for our
municipalities which which ultimately
will help the local uh uh taxpayers um
one thing you'll see in this bill is
that there's
um uh no cap actually on this bill I
just uncapped I
didn't five megawatt and um and the
reason for that I wanted to Future proof
this bill so we don't have to keep
coming back if FK should change their
rules um then we would have to come back
we set a 5 megawatt and FK moved it to
seven we'd have another argument moving
up to seven or if they dropped it down
to four then we'd have an argument about
moving it back down to four this bill
would future the way the Bill's written
would future proof it allow it for
um uh to deal with the Federal
Regulations as they adjust and I'll
happy to take any questions thank you
representative Lang I appreciate that I
uh initially misspoke and said I was
going to give you three minutes but
actually Bill sponsors are allowed five
minutes and so I give you the full five
minutes now it kept me short thank you
for
that uh so I I do have one question for
you um but I'm gonna call on
representative Thomas first because
quite frankly I forgot my question so
representative Thomas thank you to thank
you for my question
represent um um I'm a little concerned
on page two line six and seven and the
fact that you said that there was no cap
uh does this not open the door even if
it's unintentional to
um other entities that might take
advantage of having no cap have you
considered consequences and the fact
that
F probably would will never lower if its
rules so why not just keep the cap the
same right now and then if it needs to
be expanded come back to
later again I'm not opposed to that my
goal was try to Future proof the bill um
by by allowing the FK rules on on you
know right now it's five megawatts with
FK um and allow that be the guiding
factor for the state and and again you
know also I'm not opposed to it if the
committee wants to put a hard cap in
here have at it um again my goal is was
the future Pro it so we don't have to
continually come back I think I counted
when I did a net metering search and let
islative and net energy search somewhere
in the neighbor around 47 bills have
been submitted on those topics and my
goal was to reduce that work of
legislature and if this bill can be
elastic and adapt then I was hoping to
do that but if the committee feels
that's not appropriate then it can
adjust
accordingly okay uh I remembered my
question you have heard testimony um
representative lying to a pilot project
but I don't see any language in the bill
that talks about a pilot project can you
explain that further further please well
sure I didn't specifically call it a
pilot project in the bill because we're
meet we're we're opening this up and and
allowing municipality Municipal host
generators to do this um but in in
practicality that's exactly what we're
doing is we're creating a pilot project
because we have a limited number of
people that can um utilize this program
um we could then go back and look at
that data from those limited number of
users so um it guy like I said before
and so we I regularly do pilot projects
on New on new technologies and we
Implement in one little given area and
see how it works and go back and and do
the research um and then I'll if it if
it worked then we we can expand it if it
doesn't work we can either pull it back
or we can just leave the pilot as it
exists if the if the Departments worked
on it so or departments made the
investment so again the way I looked at
it was in practicality it is a pilot
project even though I didn't
particularly write that language into
the
bill okay thank you um next up
representative Cali pittz has a
question yes representative Lange thanks
for dusting off an old bill um I'm
concerned about line 18 can you tell me
why you put in that line a municipal
host may be owned by either a public or
private entity now I understand them the
Municipal maybe wanting to get in that
and trying it to wet its feet in that
but what about the private entity and
would the municipalities still retain
control thank you for your question
ma'am um representative pittz so again
the idea behind this was I was concerned
about lease Arrangements where a
municipality may enter into a lease
arrangement for an array that's put on
top of their landfill say um and then
they don't technically own that property
they're paying a lease on it usually
like a dollar buyout at the end and so I
wanted to be able to allow those kind of
a lease and private public relationships
it also would come into play with if
there was um a generator that um wished
to uh put up an array and and make an
arrangement with the town to completely
sell the power to the town 100% of the
um members of the of the group net
meeting would have to be political
subdivisions then I don't know why we
wouldn't want while back um and it would
be an arrangement a private public
relationship Arrangement between
municipality and the private
owner may I follow up follow
up okay my concern there sir is the cost
that once you let rates Etc go out to
private entity private entity wants to
make
money and they're not perhaps regulated
so the cost cost wouldn't be controlled
and maybe not necessarily less than what
was happening
so is that something You' thought about
so I'm not quite sure I understand your
question but um again the town's not
going to enter into an arrangement
that's not cost um or or city or or any
political subdivision that's not going
to be uh cost effective for them um and
so and the same with any business owners
not going to go into an arrangement
where that's not cost effective for them
if they can't if they can't get their
cost back and make some profit then the
bus not I don't know very many business
owners are going to do that kind of
business um and so I'm not quite sure I
understand your question um so maybe you
can restate it I'll try to answer it
what's efficacious today what says I can
make a profit today may not be true
tomorrow and if if there's no regulation
no oversight no caps no
then there could be a problem that's all
I'm
saying thank you for the question again
I I I guess I I I can't look in the
future and guess what might happen with
the rates again you you'll notice
nowhere through here do we talk about
rates um the existing current statute is
everything is still controlling when it
comes to rates and on on metering the
only thing we're basically doing here is
uh taking the cap off for a li limited
set of circumstances and allowing uh
towns to engage in what they feel is
their best opportunity um as it comes to
Green energy and costs thank you thank
you the chair recognizes representative
Harrington for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question uh actually
there's a couple um my first one is uh
the extension of this over one megawatt
what is the rate that would be paid to
the electricity that this uh project put
back onto the grid so again represent
herting thank you for the question again
nowhere in this bill do I talk about
rates the rates would be the existing
rates as as it is currently defined for
up to one
megawatt so you would then talk about
followup Mr
chairman yes go ahead okay so the
existing rate for up to one megawatt is
to pay full default service rate so
you'd be you uh what you're talking
about here is full default service rate
for up to 5 megawatts and possibly if FK
change they M 10 or 20 or 30 megawatts
is that correct uh I would say yes to
that they I'm I'm I'm taking your on
trust that that is what the law
says and just one more followup Mr
chairman yes go ahead it's you've also
Incorporated this in with you brought in
not just the municipals here but also
the lowi income what is the term uh low
income low moderate income Community
solar project so in that case
again they could go the over the one
megawatt limit be paid the default
service rate doesn't this involve more
almost like a welfare program for cost
shifting to the lowincome people rather
than simply support them through
attacks representative herting thank you
very much for that question that was
something I forgot to cover in my
testimony I I've emailed the entire
committee an amendment to this bill and
it would strike the language regarding
to the uh low to moderate income
Community solar Pro and the reason I was
considering I I would ask the committee
to strike that language with that
amendment is because what I didn't
realize is on 724 of 19 Senate Bill 165
was passed um and in that bill there's
some specific language and one of the
things it talks about is that onor
before July 1st 2022 the commission
shall report on the cost and benefits of
such addition and the development of the
market for load of moderate income
Community solar projects and provide a
recommendation and what I wouldn't want
to do is upset the data um and so right
now apparently there is a mechanism in
for those projects and for pu to be able
to uh do a a report relative to those
projects and I I I wouldn't want to
insert a new variable into this
discussion until um pu came out with
that so I'd humbly asked the committee
to I I did the footw for the leg work
for you and and and sent the uh
amendment in um so you guys could adopt
it if you chose to strike that language
but I do think that would upset the
apple cart for a previous law that we
have that's looking at this data and
they we're going to insert a new
variable into it so I'd ask you to
strike that
language okay thank you uh
representative L and representative
Harrington I'd like to point out before
I call on the next questioner that we
have eight people signed up to speak on
this bill and we have 27 minutes left in
this public hearing so representative
samon just recognized for a question
uh yes thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Lang uh I got to say
that I like your bill uh I I like the
fact that you're thinking ahead and just
saying let's not have a cap
obvious yeah so obviously um that means
that whatever is possible people can do
so what I wanted to ask you is can you
again uh reiterate what you think is the
primary benefit to municip alties and
political entities of this bill what's
the primary benefit that you see so the
primary benefit I see for the
municipalities if if they can again this
goes back to their Contracting but if
they can negotiate a good rate with
getting a a clean energy we'll use a
solar because it's the simplest
conversation point the most common one
if they can arrange an uh putting up a
solar array to offset their electricity
costs um you're going to see a a
reduction in the operating expenses for
municipalities and hopefully an
operating expense reduction results in
property tax relief so um that is my
consideration for the best benefit of
this thing followup Mr chairman follow
up uh okay so that so that's I think
that's a really good goal can you tell
me why this is not possible for them to
do that right
now I believe it's the aggregation
component and allowing and again I'm
going to use the the conversation Point
around um bosquin
um using multiple entities to be able to
do that and ability to uh virtually
group all those uh meters behind a
virtual meter and offset the entire uh
uh grid for that the entire electrical
consumption for that thank you thank you
representative partial has recognized
for the
question uh very quickly uh
representative Lang very very good Bill
thank you so much for drafting it uh the
amendment that you attached on your
email I do not seem to have uh receiv
received that Amendment perhaps I'm
alone but could you please double check
I will send it again I just sent it me
just shortly ago so uh right before the
uh public hearing started OLS had sent
it to me okay thank you so much thank
you representative McGee is recognized
for question thank you Mr chairman I
actually wanted to just add something as
a co-sponsor I'm I'm not asking a
question but I'm answering a question
from before about how municipalities and
political subdivisions would use this
because I live in a town that's already
made Investments and they are not in a
position at this point to recover uh
those investments in the way that they
were intended for anything over one
megawatt at this point so I know that
their their Investments were based on um
following a plan that would allow us to
lower those rates uh for the you know
for the town um and so we have
significantly low lowered our costs but
we are still not recovering or gaining
credit uh for the amount generated in
excess of what our needs are and so
that's the other piece um that I think a
lot of folks are waiting for because in
some cases it's not backed-up projects
but projects that have already been put
into play so I just wanted to mention
that uh as who would
benefit uh J recognizes representative
Harrington for a
question
representative Harrington did you have a
question I was muted sorry I think I'm
can you hear me now yes okay thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question representative Lang on the
second page starting on line 13 talks
about a municipal house is a customer
generator with a total Peak generating
capacity of greater than one megawatt
used to offset the electricity
requirements of a group my question is
so if it's less than one megawatt it's
not a municipal host that would be part
one and if it is a municipal house can
the output above one megawatt only be
used to offset the electrical
requirements of a group or can some of
that electricity be fed back into the uh
grid and they get payments for that so
again the intention of the bill when it
was drafted was to offset the the usage
um and again allowing this this concept
of a virtual meter um behind all town or
political subdivisions within a single
municipality to offset that electrical
usage so and again I the way I read it
in this language um was intended for the
entire consumption so if you put a 2.5
megawatt uh array up you don't have to
go to Five you could put a two megawatt
Ray up um the the consumption of that
two megawatt would be within that
Community for the political subdivisions
followup Mr
chairman follow up try to make it quick
thank you uh I'm still a little confused
let me just give you for instance so uh
one of these Municipal hosts decided to
put up a lease from a private entity a 4
and a half megawatt facility but the
maximum load for the municipal host was
75 megawatts would they be able to do
that and then sell the rest of their
output because they' never use more than
75 whatever that Surplus was would they
be able to sell that back to the Grid at
the uh at the default service
right I'm going to say in that concept
that in conceptually yes that Pro that
could happen um I I don't see imp
practicality of that happening but yes I
do I do see that as a possibility and
again I'd be open to if you feel there's
better language I could clean that up so
that doesn't happen that's not the
intention of the bill the bill the
intention of the bill is to lower
electric cost municipalities and not
create a revenue stream for
municipalities okay thank you very much
representative McGee we really need to
move on can you can you hold that
question yeah it wasn't a question I was
going to try and answer that further
but
I I appreciate it thank you so on our
next speaker who is Clifton Belo from
Lebanon New Hampshire uh representing
the city of Lebanon Mr V the floor is
yours for two minutes thank you Mr
chairman um I am as he said assistant
mayor of the city of Lebanon testifying
on behalf of the City generally
supportive of this bill I do have a
couple of concerns um I did send out a
suggested Amendment um uh although you
just received it so I haven't had a
chance to look at it it uh would uh put
the 5 megawatt um uh limit into the bill
uh to specify that to participate in the
uh uh as a group Municipal group host it
have to be less than 5 megawatts the
reason for that is because that is a
hard and fast boundary that has been in
existence at for at least 20 years I
think actually probably quite a bit
longer uh any generator that's 5
megawatts or larger um by definition
essentially you know has to register
with ISO New England as a uh FK
jurisdictional generator it's
participating in the Interstate
Wholesale markets of which FK has
exclusive jurisdiction um the state has
exclusive jurisdiction over distribution
and within State wholesale sales but
only for generators that are not
participating in the interstate market
so I think that 5 megawatt limit is
important um another way to say this
would be to say a customer generator
that participates in net metering shall
not participate in is and New England
markets as a generator or network
resource um I've also uh sent along um
uh a neor brief on this issue that um
gives a lot of background on the just
jurisdictional boundary and in my last
30 seconds um another concern that I
didn't put in my letter but it's some
significance is the fact that um you
might want to consider netting out the
RPS compliance cost because for four
megawatt solar project um it would
generate um about 5.3 million kilowatt
hours a year and uh the RPS compliance
cost for that would be about $40,000 and
if you're selling it at the same if
compensating at the same rate you're
turning around and um delivering it to
another customer there's $40,000 RPS
compliance for which there's no revenue
and that cost would have to be shifted
to other rate paays and and so I think
that's problematic for these large
systems thank
you thank you very well done two minutes
and seven seconds appreciate that any
questions for Mr
Belo seeing none we will move on to our
next speaker who is Donna gamos
representing ever Source um and Miss
gash is listed as opposing the bill so
miss
gash find you on the list here I should
have done that earlier I
apologize okay Miss gash you are allowed
to speak unmute unmute yourself and take
it away two minutes thank you very much
uh very briefly um we are test on on
behalf of eversource uh energy I'm
testifying um in opposition to House
Bill 106 but only just to raise a couple
of concerns with some of the details um
because the idea of Municipal host
generators is not something that we
oppos um with that the first issue with
the bill is that just as you just heard
from Mr Belo that we believe there
should be a cap for each facility
without a cap um very large projects um
could earn the net metering compensation
rather than getting the wholesale
market-based compensation and um it
obviously the cap would be consistent
with Federal rules I wanted to just
share with you some examples um in
speaking with Rick lebre whom some of
you know we have six large projects in
our que right now combin they total 100
megawatts you can do the math if you
only divide um 100 by six each project
uh if they were e of equal size would be
roughly 17 megawatts um so right out of
the gate the projects are larger than
five megawatts the second issue we have
is that the language uh on page one
lines 15 and 16 is unclear on whether
all group members must be political
subdivisions or just one or more and
it's the one or more language I'm
speaking about if that is the intent
then it would be very easy for a very
large generator to assemble a group of
say six Walmarts um to to um participate
as a municipal group host and then our
third issue um under section two
beginning um page two beginning on line
eight the language attempts to negate
any provisions of settlement agreements
or orders related to qualifying
facilities and independent power
producers we really don't know what the
purpose of the language is but for over
the last 40 plus years there have been
dozens of voluminous settlements and
orders and we really don't know um what
the intent of the purposes so um oh one
last thing we have um I think it's on
page one line 21 there is a reference to
a customer being an entity you know in
quotes created for a special purpose we
don't know what it means or what the
purpose is so from from our perspective
we just have a lot of questions that we
need answered the main issue we have is
just including the cap and with that
thank you for taking my
testimony thank you uh not bad two
minutes and 16 seconds uh representative
Thomas is recognized for a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for take my
question I just have a ask your question
would would this bill um in any way uh
either negate or or um
supered the current law that requires
Public Utilities from uh
purchasing uh extra renewable energy
that people
produce I think I think I think I know
where you're going with that I don't
think that's the intent but there is
some ambiguity in the legislation so I
understand why you asked that question
our lawyers don't think that that um is
the intent but again we've raised a few
ambiguities today so um I would say
generally speaking
no
thank thank you uh representative ssuch
is recognized for a
question uh thanks Mr chairman and thank
you M mamash for taking my question um
does eversource already participate in
in the similar concept that is proposed
here in other states of new New
England um we do participate in net
metering in other states and the two
other states that we participate in are
Massachusetts and Connecticut and in and
in both cases they have five megawatt
caps thank you thank you okay thank you
uh any other
questions seeing none we will call on
our next speaker who is Steve Steve
zaretti a lobbyist for Brookfield
Renewable let me find you here
Steve there you are okay Steve you're on
and you're allowed to speak for two
minutes great good morning can you hear
me we can thank you great I'll be brief
um for your reference Brookfield
Renewable owns and operates 144
megawatts of generating capacity within
the state that includes several
smallscale hydropower units um we are
supportive of HB 106 uh we think this is
a great step for expanding access to
renewable energy and for uh local
control of energy sources um and in
particular we're very supportive of
language in the bill um that tries to
address interconnection limitations uh
that impact just a few existing
smallscale Hydro facilities in the state
and that includes four small units in
Berlin and Goram that Brookfield owns
and
operates if we didn't include this
clarifying provision in section two uh
those units could be shut out from
participating in the program uh even if
the program were expanded um considering
there is some discussion here around a 5
megawatt cap being implemented uh in a
future draft so that would of course
prevent the from serving interested
public um off-takers if if there weren't
clarifying language included so again we
are very supportive of this bill uh and
thanks very much for the opportunity to
comment thank you very much any
questions for Mr zeret representative
Samson has recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Zer for testifying uh can I just
have a clarification a little bit about
what your answer was about the cap um uh
if I did are correctly are you in
opposition to capping this do you like
the fact that there is no cap and
wouldn't that be self- enforcement
anyway if if the if you went over a cap
that was not allowed by FK uh The Entity
doing it would have to adjust itself
differently wouldn't that be the case so
so the the language that I'm referencing
um what IT addresses is the fact that
there are some hydropower facilities in
New Hampshire um that under the current
rules of the program would be deemed as
aggregate units and so if there were a
cap of say five megawatts some units
that are you know two or three megawatts
might be aggregated together and then
not be able to participate in the
program because they would exceed the 5
megawatt cap so not taking a position on
the cap just saying that if a cap is
introduced to this discussion uh this
language becomes necessary for that
reason okay thank you very
much uh four speakers to go in 10
minutes I now
recognize Miss Heidi
Crow and
um I know you're here somewhere there
you are Miss Heidi Crow you are
recognized to speak for two minutes um
thank you Mr chairman um I actually if I
could have four um I'm testifying on
behalf of both the granite state Hydro
Power Association and badok paper
mills okay well compromise on three
how's that all right I will try to be
very quick um so Granite State Hydro
Power Association um supports House Bill
106 um we support the fact that it will
remove the one megawatt cap on the size
of renewable facilities that are
eligible to participate in net metering
um uh I will say that to address one of
the questions that came up um Hydro
power facilities uh the way
representative Lang has written this
bill and we do appreciate it hydr power
facilities would be able to serve um mun
political
subdivisions um whether that's schools
or
municipalities um you know anything even
if you do put in a cap um anything up to
five megawatts um regardless you know
that the hydro facilities could be
outside of a municipality and he
recognizes that um and we very much
appreciate that because obviously new no
new Hydro facilities are being built um
and uh you can't relocate them it's not
like solar where you have some
flexibility about where those are cited
um the other and we gsha also supports
section two of the bill which we feel
includes Provisions that ensure a Level
Playing Field um I will say from anad
paper mills perspective um you heard
from Mr zetti um the first section of
section two really deals with this uh
unique circumstance where multiple um
Hydro facilities it's Unique um to hydro
facilities and we're only aware of um
ours and and uh the North country that
Mr Z spoke of uh manado paper mills has
three small Hydro facilities each are
under one megawatt they are all behind
the meter and they share a single
interconnection point with the grid um
namely the Mills interconnection point
with eversource and so they have been um
those three Hydro facilities they're
independently um licensed by furk and
they uh are independently recognized by
the Pu as RPS eligible but because of
this uh kind of aggregation problem
they've been shut out from net metering
so the language in section two would
address that problem we've saw this
language last year and it had bipartisan
support and we would hope that you would
support it again this year um to address
the question that came up um the second
piece of um section two Miss gash had
some concerns or questions about it um
it's simply to make sure small Hydro
facilities have been participating in
the wholesale Market as qfs and that
language is simply me to acknowledge
that um if they start participating in
net metering instead they will be
subjected to the net metering rules and
laws um that the Pu has on the books um
so kind of making sure that they're um
playing by the same rules that any other
net metering facility would play by and
be happy to answer any questions thank
you very
much thank you very much Miss Gro any
questions for Miss Gro looks like Peter
ssuch has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh just briefly
what what is a
qf uh qualifying facility I'm sorry
thank
you any further questions for miss croll
seeing none I will now recognize the
next speaker Rob Warner who is a
lobbyist for the league of
conservation voters Mr Warner you have
the floor for two minutes thank you
chairman o and members of the committee
um I won't be long I just wanted to
point out an addition to the
environmental benefits of deploying more
renewable energy across the state
through the municipal host platform I
think you should also consider this as
an economic development tool because of
the very large Investments that are are
going to come forward if municipalities
and other governmental units are
permitted to take this step it is a
certainly a significant step uh forward
and cities and towns will also gain the
economic benefit from tax arrangement
with providers through pilots and other
uh arrangements so I think that that's
significant for communities and lastly I
wanted to uh highlight that you should
have in your possession a letter from
many of the Mayors across the state that
are uh in support of this approach and
um I think I've come well under the uh
time
frame oh you sure did just a minute way
to
go thank you Mr wner any questions Mr
burner representative Samson just
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you Mr burner for
taking my question um you alluded to the
economic development opportunities and
that that this is kind this could be a
tool can you elaborate a little bit
about what do you think municipalities
how they could benefit from those kind
of tools well in several ways I think
that um you know again the pilot
agreements uh and such Arrangements that
communities will gain from hosting these
kinds of projects um but also um there's
a job and economic development uh aspect
to these projects because obviously are
going to employ people to build them and
to the extent that we expand this in
this way at this time I think it's going
to address um some job creation needs
that we really have uh in the State of
Affairs that we're in with the covid-19
so I I think that's going to be a
benefit thank
you thank you uh seeing no more
questions for
um Mr Warner I will
now turn it over to our next
speaker who
is Robert Hayden Mr Hayden represents
himself and standard power Mr Hayden you
have the floor for two
minutes thank you representative oose
can you hear
me yes thank you so much and thank you
to everybody for their service on this
committee it's a pleasure to have the
opportunity to speak to you folks again
it's been a while I do support HB
106 um standard power currently
administers 25 small Hydro facilities
that are net metered to schools and
towns here in New Hampshire so we have a
lot of experience in the smaller version
of these projects and the great success
they've had uh through group net
metering we've returned over $3 million
since the Inception of the program in
2015 to New Hampshire entities
two-thirds of that has gone to schools
and
towns we currently serve over 50 schools
in towns in this net metering program we
have another 12 towns that would like to
join and a couple of school districts
that would like to join uh we do not
have that capacity right now even though
we've re-energized several facilities
this year and hope to re-energize a
third uh excuse me we re-energize two in
2020 and hope to re-energize a third in
2021 so even doing a program like that
employs New Hampshire
folks um which I think is critically
important a couple of uh towns we serve
that are worth mention Peterboro who's
been 100% green
for seven years uh Derry Rochester go go
and a few others um because this focuses
on Municipal entities it keeps all of
the benefits of net metering in the
state and when a thirdparty finances a
program like this the benefit is a fixed
benefit that can still go to the
community regardless of the def default
service rate that it's based
on uh my last point is that doing this
as a pilot as has been kind of discussed
would minimize the impact on the
interconnection evaluation team at
eversource in Maine they were deluged
when they opened up the floodgates for
this kind of a program here starting it
off with a trickle of projects might be
appropriate with the expectation that it
would be extremely successful and be
able to proliferate in the future
okay thank you Mr Hayden I appreciate
that uh any questions for Mr Hayden
looks like representative s has a
question go
ahead thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Hayden uh and Mr Hayden it's really nice
to hear your voice again you've always
been a participant in these these
hearings uh my question is this to you
uh right now the projects that you
you're um mentoring or you're in charge
of uh has there been any movement in in
that direction to include some kind of
energy storage as well that's a great
question and frankly the answer is a
little bit unique we've tried to um
acquire a facility in Massachusetts to
work with their clean Peaks program to
determine the value statement and how to
best introduce that into New Hampshire
with that intellectual property in
addition we're I'm standard power is
participating in the storage docket
that's currently being held by the Pu
because we fully have the intent of
understanding and implementing battery
storage to not only help uh monetize the
value of the electricity but to minimize
the peak hour load that causes us to
enjoy a disproportionate amount of
transmission costs here in New
Hampshire based on the fact that
surrounding states have um outrun Us in
the production of solar and by virtue of
that it reduces their relative
transmission cost in relationship to New
Hampshire okay thank you very much very
much no more questions for Mr Hayton I
will recognize well before I do that I'm
going
to open the public hearing on HB 294 and
recess that public hearing until we
finish this one and I will recognize our
final speaker who is meline mano
representing clean energy New Hampshire
Miss Mano you have the floor for two
minutes thank you Mr chairman um clean
energy New Hampshire supports this bill
and thanks representative Lang for
bringing it back uh We've long advocated
to allow larger energy users to
rightsize their renewable energy net
metered projects and this bill would do
that for political
subdivisions um this bill though it is
limited allows for real progress for
renewable energy in New Hampshire that
would directly benefit our towns and
cities and your
constituents we are concerned that the
town boundary requiring that the host
and all members be located within the
same municipality is overly
restrictive um we think that two small
towns should be allowed to work together
on a project for example that a school
district that spans multiple towns
should be allowed to have one project
that serves all their schools and the
electric grid is not organized according
to political subdivision to political
boundaries and so an interconnection
Point may be located in the next town
over um we are okay with um adding a cap
that matches FK and ISO regulations as
other speakers have
mentioned um it is important to allow
the host to be privately owned um
because some towns don't have The
Upfront Capital to invest in a project
and so they may want to go into a power
purchase agreement or a leasing
agreement as representative Lang
explained and also uh existing Hydro
projects are not necessarily owned by
the municipality but they may want to
serve uh the electrical usage of the
political subdivisions finally I want to
go into a little bit that this law would
use the existing group net metering um
statute and under group net metering
host generation must match group load if
the host generation is greater than the
member load then there's a true up that
goes into effect and a financial penalty
occurs so I want to be really clear that
the host could not um just export to the
grid and be compensated at default
service without serving the electrical
needs being matched with the electrical
usage of a political
subdivision they can't just export and
be compensated at default service unle
unless they're directly serving that
load 15 seconds I'm done thank you okay
great thank you any questions for M Mano
representative McGee you recognized for
a question
question oh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Miss Mano for taking my
question um could you say a little bit
more about the group net metering uh
default rates and how that works since
this bill uh is highly affected by how
that compensation comes in because I
think people might be having difficulty
understanding how that would work yes
thank you that's what I was trying to
get at the end of my testimony there but
I'm I'm happy to have a little bit more
time to explain it in a little bit more
detail um representative Harrington
asked representative Lang when he was
introducing the bill if the host could
simply export energy to the grid without
serving the
electricity use of a political
subdivision and be compensated at
default service and I wanted to clarify
that our group net metering statute and
the rules enacted by the Public
Utilities Commission prevent that from
happening when you're a group net
metering host you must demonstrate on an
annual basis in an annual report that
your
generation is matched with the
electricity usage of your group members
so in this case you would have the
municipal host they could be serving the
town hall the County nursing home the
the school the electricity usage of
those members has to match the output of
the host and so that is an assurance
that you're not just acting like a
generator exporting to the grid but
being compensated at the net metering
credit and if that does not occur there
is a trup that goes into effect and the
host actually has to pay back money to
the utility the difference between the
credit they received and the avoided
cost which is much much lower and so
they make sure that that doesn't happen
because it's actually a pretty
significant financial penalty thank you
that's very helpful thank you okay thank
you very much the chair recognizes
representative Harrington for a
question
representative Harrington don't forget
to
unmute representative Harrington are you
there can you hear me now yes okay um a
follow up on what was just discussed I'm
just trying to get this straight in my
mind you're saying that the true up you
know the true up is what based on total
kilowatt hours used during the course of
the year by the
host so the host typically does not have
significant load um what is required is
an annual report
demonstrating the generation the export
from the host and the usage of all the
members and that has to match up so for
example just to use a round number it
was 100 megawatt hours that was exported
by the host the members have to have
used at least 100 megawatt hours in that
year if if say the members only used 90
and during the year the host was
compensated at default service for 100
megawatt hours the host will have to pay
back the difference between avoided cost
and default service for those 10
megawatt hours that their members did
not use and make a payment to the
utility followup please follow up yeah
uh so it's it's then based on the total
me what hours uh the host consumes in a
year versus the amount that they export
total for the year is that correct what
the host exported compared to the total
amount used by their members in their
group okay thank you okay representative
oxam you're recognized for a
question thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you mine and M minu for taking
the question uh no no one's mentioned
the the health value of the the the
change to using more renewable energy
which this bill will make possible um in
in many of our towns particular I'm
thinking of Kean where they're subject
to inversions there's a real issue um
and not that it's not a real issue
elsewhere it's just a more obvious and U
yes so could you please speak to that
issue which hasn't been mentioned
absolutely you know switching to more
clean renewable locally generated uh
electricity definitely has a lot of
potential to offer direct public health
benefits to our communities and that has
a real avoided cost um for another bill
testimony later today I emailed you um a
report that synapse energy economics
recently um put out and we're mostly
focused on the avoided energy and
capacity costs but they also get at some
of the public health benefits of uh
local solar generation so I would
reference that okay thank you the chair
recognizes representative for
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
Miss moo for taking my question um this
is going back in relation to the um
payment for sorry uh payment for kind of
exceeding the capacity um what's the
reason
for not having a bit of a buffer on top
of that say um you know don't exceed
110% or 120% of the demand it seems like
to to me it seems like it might be
useful to not penalize people for making
a little bit extra can you speak to why
that um is written that way yeah we uh
we and our members uh many of whom are
group net metering hosts would certainly
appreciate having a little bit more
flexibility in leeway but I think the
intent of groupnet metering is for a
host to serve a specific um specific
group members energy needs and so the
requirement is that the host the the
memb usage must equal or exceed and so
the way to cover yourself a little bit
is to have a little bit more load in
your members than your generator is
likely to to produce and so it is very
strict and that's what I wanted to make
really clear that group net metering
hosts are not acting like generators and
merely exporting energy to the grid and
compensated at default service without
being associated with specific customers
that they are serving in their
group thank you okay thank you very much
uh M Mano representative Samson you've
already had a question here so I think
uh we're going to conclude this public
hearing at this point we had 201 people
signed in in support of this bill two
opposed there were too many elected
officials who signed in signed in to to
list here so with that report I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
106 and we will
immediately reopen that public hearing
on House Bill
294 and I will call
on the substitute Prime sponsor
representative Lang to introduce this
Bill representative Lang you have five
minutes thank you thank you chairman
Bose and again I won't take full five
minutes uh we're already running late
over my last bill so um this bill came
out of discussions with the governor's
office again I'm apologize I'm
representative Tim Lang uh serving
belnap County 4 um this bill came out of
discussions with the governor's offices
and a group of legislators in the summer
of
2019 um this bill was brought forward
last session along with two other bills
including the one we just heard um these
bills were designed to break down the
governmental barriers and ensure rate
payer protections from higher
electricity rates and expand access to
renewable energy um this bill is the
same as House Bill 1262 which was
introduced last year which was inum
studied uh and and recommended for
future
legislation um and if you remember right
house bill 1262 along with the previous
Bill we had uh language was incorporated
into house bill 1218 which was the
larger grander size of a renewable
energy bill um this amends The Limited
energy I'm sorry The Limited electrical
energy producers act which was first
passed in
1979 it was looked at maximizing the
opportunities for Renewal Energy and
break down those government barriers to
competition uh there's a lot of work and
amendments that went into the original
bill which were not reflected here it's
my understanding a great deal of work um
and stakeholder discussion that still
needs to occur needed to occur to move
forward but that's been done and this
bill is is adjusted for that um I
brought this bill forward again so we
can begin the additional work and uh the
challenge of uh that remains is
perfecting the bill to adequately
address stakeholder concerns I am not by
any stretch of imagination an expert in
the area of limited electrical energy
producers and I'm sure we're going to
have people coming uh behind me uh who
will have much better answer questions
so I rather not take questions but if
someone really feels the need I I'll
take it I just may not be able to
answer okay thank you representative
Lang a minute and 51 56 seconds well
done are there any questions for
representative Lang we have two other
speakers who may be in a better position
to answer those
questions seeing none well okay we see
one at the last minute here
representative McGee you recognize for a
question I was just wondering whether I
should ask this question but I guess it
is relevant um representative Lang uh
thank you for taking my question by the
way are you aware of the conversations
that myself and representative Pearl had
about 294 and 407 because they're very
similar I I have I am not aware of those
conversations I shouldn't say that
representative Pearl didn't mention that
he had a conversation with you and you
have a similar bill in I don't know
where they marry up and and where
they're the same and where they're
different so um again I apologize for
that representative Pearl called me this
morning and asked me to introduce for
him because he was busy at work I I
understand Mr chairman may I just have a
followup uh since you're going to be
introducing uh HB
407 you a
clarification pardon just a
clarification
from go ahead please is it your
understanding that that uh House Bill
294 is the same language as 1262 from
last session
that is my understanding again but I I
haven't gone back to look but my
understanding is yes this is the
original starting point of 1262 from
last year that was ultimately uh
incorporated into 1218 last year thank
you appreciate
it our next speaker actually may be able
to answer corre
again seeing no more questions for
representative Lang we thank you
representative Lang for introducing the
bill and for
standing in for representative Pearl I
hope all is well with him uh our next
speaker who uh I know is very
knowledgeable about this bill because
I've heard him speak on it many times
before is Clifton Belo of the city of
Lebanon elected official Mr Belo you
have the floor for three
minutes thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee again I'm assistant mayor
of the city of Lebanon testifying on the
city's behalf um uh
very supportive of this concept um this
is a market-based alternative uh for us
uh distributed generation under 5
megawatts in size that is not
participating with ISO New England or um
uh in net metering
um it is something that's been on the
books for a very long time uh this
section of the rsas it was actually last
amended when we actually uh did the
original net metering bill um way back
in 1997 and uh 9 UM 8 of which I was the
Prime sponsor and representative badley
was the then this chair of this
committee and and the co-sponsor and
that bill actually went through
something like a dozen work sessions
over the course of two years uh it not
only created initially net metering um
for you know with the idea for early
adopters it was very small scale at that
point but also tried to update this
statute the dates I believe back to the
70s uh that allowed a limited amount of
um direct producer to Consumer retail
sales or or a few um within State
wholesale sales um and we tried to
update the statute but we didn't do far
enough so that it was actually
functional this bill uh and the next one
you're going to hear do try to do that
there were several issues raised last
year about this bill and I I've tried to
reflect those in in helping
representative McGee with 407 um I could
run down those through real quickly um
there was concern by the Pu that wasn't
clear that the that there was a clear
prohibition on double dipping by
participating in in uh by not fully
retiring from the is New England markets
or participating in that metering uh
there was concern about paragraph um
three on lines 26 to 31 of the current
bill that prohibits reporting on
production of Generation Um uh that some
found objectionable so that that um is
issue to address um I'm probably about
out of my time here at this point um uh
I you know I'm happy to work with the
committee rep represented V last year
you know chair the subcommittee that was
working on this bill and unfortunately
didn't move forward uh uh at that time
uh but but I think it's a really
worthwhile compliment uh to what we're
trying to do by harnessing the power
comp competitive markets and create a uh
alternative uh for these gener
alternative to net metering 30 seconds
I'll stop there thank you okay thank you
uh one quick question did you um work
with the prime sponsor of HB 407 in
crafting that
Bill yes I did and I will also confess
to being the person who originated the
language in this bill it was actually
part of a Senate Bill 13 introduced two
years ago that I suggested as a market
based alternative to expanding net
metering okay excellent any additional
questions for Mr
Bel see none I will call on our next
speaker who is Donna gamar from ever
source and
U have good morning can you hear me yes
we can hear you and you have three
minutes thank you okay I will be very
brief um since I'm not an expert on
federal jurisdiction on energy
transactions that require the use of
transmission system but we understand
the purpose of the bill we understand
the desire for instate generators to
undertake a bilateral contract within
the state for the output of their power
it makes perfect sense to us this type
of contract can take place uh currently
without the involvement of FK or ISO New
England if the two parties are merely a
ected by the distribution system of
course with puc oversight if however the
two parties need the transmission system
uh to finalize the transaction according
to firk they must undertake the
processes required by those Regulators
this bill is intended to override the FK
or ISO oversight which again we
understand um but this legislature can't
overrule FK and ISO requirements so um
we do believe that there could be ways
that the parties can at opportunities to
update the RS RSA 362a as Mr Belo
mentioned it hasn't been updated in 20
years we think that there could be
opportunities that um currently to
update but also having an eye for the
future how it could be updated um I
wanted to add also that a transaction
like this can take place regardless of
whether um it's a distribution or a
transmission impact if it is a financial
Arrangement only the issue arises when
the trade is an energy product so um I
just wanted to say we recognize what you
want what the uh sponsor is trying to do
we think it makes perfect sense and uh
we'd be willing to offer our experts
within eversource to join with whatever
stakeholders you deem necessary to try
to find a way to reach the goal and make
legitimate changes to existing laws to
make it happen and that's the end of my
testimony thank you a minute 44 seconds
well
done okay are there any questions
representative has a
question thank you uh chair thank you
for taking my question um is it correct
to paraphrase what you just said Mr M
that as written this bill is not ready
for prime time uh that's how I would
word it correct thank you for
that uh representative McGee has
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Miss kamash for
taking my question you said that the
financial Arrangement uh the Financial
aspect of an arrangement was already
allowed could you elaborate on that a
little more so I could understand so the
I I wish that I could have our experts
here with you today to do a better job
but uh my understanding is if it's if
these are Renewables there's a way
through um renewable energy certificates
and other types of things like that that
you can create this financial
Arrangement but again I would love to
double check that with our experts
followup Mr chair follow up yeah and the
one aspect of your testimony was you
said that this bill would override the
iso New England could you explain that
well because um the there is a
distinction between um this type of an
arrangement if it if it's touched by the
transmission system that is if the two
parties are far enough away that it
naturally requires the use of a a
utilities transmission system to to Pro
make sure that the power goes from one
to the other once once you hit that
transmission system it automatically
uh requires the oversight that Federal
oversight is it distribution or
transmission transmission you can do it
with
distribution so there's a difference
between the two and we but but we have
seen in the past where uh there have
been entities wanting to undertake this
but it did have a transmission impact
and those entities ended up withdrawing
their petition before the Pu because of
it so that's why we're saying if you put
a few PE you know the smart people in
the room uh all the different
stakeholders maybe there's a way to come
up with an alternative so that that that
can take place going
forward thank
youcome thank you seeing uh no more
questions
for Ms gash oh representative oxenham
has a question you
recognized actually I'd like to to
address it to the prime sponsor it comes
out of Representative Thomas's uh
earlier question is the prime sponsor
still
available I believe he is I'm still here
sir
excellent yeah so back when we had this
bill last year we all decided it wasn't
ready for prime time so we sent it to
interim study at interim study we all
said Bill looks good but you know needs
work because of covid we weren't Poss it
wasn't possible for us to do the work we
sent it back to the sponsors and I
actually signed on with the notion that
there was going to be substantial work
and we were going to come forward with a
an updated and improved version so when
when it became clear that we have the
same bill again I I have to ask what
happened why why has the bill come back
in its original
form uh I'll allow the uh question
because I forgot to acknowledge before
you asked it representative oxam that as
a co-sponsor you shouldn't be asking
questions but I'll allow representative
Lang to
answer again I'm not sure I can answer
that question I can tell you that this
bill was brought forward again at the
behest of the governor's office um to
allow the introduction of this bill and
to allow work to be done on this bill
because they believe that this is an
important part of the state's energy
policy okay thank you very much see no
further
questions from any members of the
committee either in the committee room
or
online I will note that we had 115
people supporting this legislation and
two people
opposed and I will officially now close
the public hearing on
HB
294 we will take a five minute bio break
for people who are on site here at the
Legislative Office building and we will
come back at 10:30 and
initiate an executive session so get
10:30 know on what
Bill yes we have four bills I shared
them with representativ sson I don't
know exactly which one start
with
Lee yeah it's uh there are on the list
are HB
351 HB
289 HB
373 and
396 just wanted to know which one of
them would come up first because you you
we never
know this is a hard
job don't hesitate to asker you don't
have to write point is you know you
don't have to it speaks I just I just
write them in favor I don't really write
a lot of detail them all you
know
with uh as many executive sessions as we
can squeeze in between now and 11:00
and I should have remembered and I AP
apologize representative oxen I should
have remembered that the one we're going
to start with is the one that we
recessed last week which is House Bill
351 so I would like to uh
reconvene the executive session on House
Bill
351 and recognize a representative
Thomas for a
motion chair I had some thoughts to go
back to review my notes and I confirmed
what I thought originally so my
motion1 is to
OT representative grey is recognized I
second it has been moved and seconded
that we judge HB 315 351 rather to be
ought to pass is there any discussion
representative ssuch is
recognized yeah thank you Mr chairman
and um well I think this bill is not a
good bill we heard overwhelming
testimony including from the consumer
Advocate uh that this bill is um would
harm our program for Energy Efficiency
would harm a lot of programs but it
would basically uh sty me what we use
the systems benefits chars for four and
um even the utilities uh two of the
three utilities testify against this
bill uh the blue sheet was
overwhelmingly opposed to this bill so I
think this is not a good bill and I
think we should uh not agree to OTP it
thank
you thank you representative MC
recognized
for a
comment yes thank you Mr chairman I I
think it might have been my
protestations on the last Auto pass that
had you guys reconsider whether you
wanted to go through with the vote that
day my concern is in Reading rereading
the testimony in preparation for today's
potential executive session um I I think
the the purpose as given for the bill is
to support savings to rate payers and I
think this bill could do the opposite
from the testimony that we've seen so my
question is how do we find it beneficial
to ort of pull the rug out from under
the the the way this pricing which was
delicately put in place to
support uh our Energy Efficiency uh
programs and the plan that's pending
right now at the Pu how does it benefit
us to put all that time and effort into
creating a plan of a way forward that
everybody agrees to that stakeholder
process and us coming in and just
undoing it all I I don't I don't I I
feel like that's a waste of money and
time and effort so I'm trying to figure
out what the intent of the bill is in
terms of uh economic benefit it I think
there's been no evidence that it would
have economic benefit I guess that's the
easy way to say what I'm trying to say
and so I don't think it's a good bill
either
obviously the chair recognizes
representative Harrington yeah thank you
Mr chairman uh can you hear
me yes okay just wanted to make sure
first of all the the intent of this bill
is not to save rate payers money uh
necessarily uh it does nothing to reduce
the system benefit charge or the amount
of money collected on it it simply says
that the uh money should be spent on
energy low-income customers and Energy
Efficiency programs whose main purpose
is to reduce the consumption of
electricity and that's the way it was
originally done and back a few years ago
the utilities came and said boy we're
having trouble spending all the money so
we want to go into thermal projects and
I think I was a commissioner at the time
I think I made a mistake I didn't
realize the extent it was the transfer
was going to be from actual Savings of
reduction of electric use to Thermal
projects and if you look back and I'm
looking at the figures now that we uh
from the New Hampshire saves program
these are a estimate just approximate
but 60% of the money was spent on
thermal projects to save 14% of the
kilowatt hours so 60% of the money saved
14% of the kilowatt hours where 40% of
the money saved 86% of the kilowatt hour
reduction and the purpose of the system
benefit charge is to reduce the the use
of of electricity so that there is some
type of savings for everybody now every
every time you all kilowatt hours aren't
equal because if you save money at 2:00
in the morning uh you're not reducing uh
the cost of electricity to anybody but
except for the person saving it but if
you do it at 3:00 in the afternoon on a
on a hot summer day that's when the uh
cost benefit curve really jumps or the
cost load curve goes way way up but
regardless of that the purpose is to
transfer the money to where it does the
most good to benefit the system which is
like I said 86% of the savings was from
40 40% of the cost and the other part
was to restore to the legislators the
authority to raise a low of the system
benefit charge nothing prevents anyone
from doing a study like it's been done
prevents someone coming the Pu coming to
the legislature and saying for the
following reasons here's our report we
think you should raise or lower the
system benefit charge all it does is
reserve the ultimate Authority where it
belongs to the legislature so again it
doesn't reduce uh costs it simply
transfers the money to the places where
it saves the most kilowatt
hours okay thank you representative
Harrington representative oxam is recogn
yes thank you thank you very much uh
first and foremost what we have to do in
order to save money is reduce our Peak
demand all of our neighboring states are
reducing their Peak demand they have
aggressive ambitious renewable energy
and Energy Efficiency measures in Bean
they are they've already plateaued and
reduced their total electricity demand
not New Hampshire
we have not invested the money and we
have not been able to bring our Peak
demand not our total and not our Peak
and the issue here is that this this
bill if it were to pass would actually
increase costs to rate payers
because we will have to pay an increased
share of the regional transmission
charges all the other states are going
down we are going up and I I checked
with Dees and they say that um if you
just look at the next several years ISO
is projecting an additional and a half
billion dollars in increased
transmission charges okay everybody else
is paying less we will have to pay more
in our our P our usage used to be
99.5% that was our share of the regional
total we're projected to be up at
10.8% by
2029 every one tenth of
1% that our share goes up is well over a
million dollars in increased
charges if we're going
up a whole percent plus
8% no it's a whole percent plus three
1.3%
increase each tenth of a percent is
millions of dollars this is this is the
cost to New Hampshire rate payers of not
putting in the maximum amount of energy
efficiency we can ring from the system
every single expert that's come and
testified before this committee has told
us Energy Efficiency is the greatest
bang for the buck you invest a dollar
you get four times that back in savings
reducing our Peak we've been told by ISO
we've been told by Dees the OCA you name
them this is where we save
money and yet you want to eliminate it
I'm I'm
flabbergasted representative
Ox uh we may have to start imposing uh
time limits on these comments oh I must
protest this is a travesty we have no
discussions we do not work on our bills
we do not thrash things out because it's
time limit time limit of order I I I
demand the Corum and this and and
request to speak and not interrupt the
chair
agreed representative penel has
recognized to speak uh thank you Mr
chairman I I actually agree with uh
representative Harrington that we need
to transfer the money to where it does
the most good and right now where it's
going to do the most good
is in uh insulation projects uh that
sort of thing uh the utilities have
already changed enough light bulbs most
most of our gains there we've already
gotten we're looking for new places to
spend our Energy Efficiency money uh we
are rif with projects that really need
to be uh dealt with to get lowincome
peoples
General energy needs down this is
something the utilities companies the
smaller utility companies want and asked
for this is in opposition to to their
wishes as well as the wishes of the
general
public um I can't see that passing this
bill makes any sense at all thank you
okay representative uh man is recognized
for a
comment thank you thank you Mr chairman
um first of all where would we get this
this uh idea that somehow all we're
trying to do is save electricity money
um the uh homeowner or the building
owner or the building user saves if he
saves money on heating oil or saves
money on gas uh through Energy
Efficiency uh they will also save
electricity for one thing and they also
have more money to their to easily pay
the electric rate so in in effect that
you're benefiting the user by doing the
maximum Energy Efficiency you can it's
also true that we've I've done several
projects in my own town and electricity
tracks heating oil if you look at uh
utilization of electricity and heating
oil week to week they track each other
and so by reducing the um the heat the
heat loss through the building you
reduce the electricity consumption as
well as the oil I don't think there's
any law that says you're not supposed to
also accidentally uh not on purpose um
save oil expenses uh just because you're
aiming at
electric
expenses uh anyway um one of our
buildings uh we reduced
the um heating cost by 55% which is sub
stantial this is a stone building with
leaky windows we did nothing to the
windows we simply did an indication uh
insulation
work um and it's amazing what you can
get done with Energy Efficiency
so again we're not just trying to save
electricity we're trying to save money
as well representative man
representative C Pitts is recognized for
com
I just want to make a comment that my
objection to the bill is that it goes in
the hands of the
legislature know the saying the wheels
of the Gods grind slowly the legislators
grind almost
nil thank
you thank you representative
representative partial is recognized for
for a
comment yes uh I've I've been watching
as all here for the events in Texas 10
years ago advice was at that time was to
winterize their grid and they failed to
do so and I see this is a our wakeup
call do the same here uh Energy
Efficiency this makes sense and that's
really all I have to say thank
you thank you representative p and
recogniz thank you Mr chairman I just
want to talk to you a little bit about
my previous uh job I uh work worked in
the hbac industry I did systems designs
and uh I'm not sure if you're aware of
it but uh uh air
um heat pumps are are a big thing in the
industry right now um and so we've had
many people saying that they want to put
um heat pumps in their house first thing
they do is they bring bring their their
blueprints to me or whatever we look at
the heat loads in the house and lo and
behold we get to a situation where uh we
find out this house isn't insulated and
basically what we tell them in order to
go to uh to to gain the most amount of
money it's not by switching to a heat
pump but it's by insulating your house
and it is only until after they can
insulate their house that it makes sense
to go to um an air source heat pump
so indirectly insulating houses are
working us towards Energy Efficiency
using
electricity so that's a good point
representative pel thank you
representative Bernardi is
recognized yes I just want to uh
reiterate what uh representative
Arrington has said Thank you Mr Speaker
for please uh speak more loudly thank
you thank you chairman boss for uh for
acknowledging this um this bill deals or
this subject matter is systems benefit
charges systems benefit is the
electrical system not the not the uh
insulation systems or whatever for
people's homes and so the focus of of
the Monies to be utilized here should be
for dealing with saving
electricity not for other insulation
programs not that those aren't a bad
thing they may be but that should be
under a specific program designed to
focus on that subject matter we are we
are dealing with the premise of a
systems benefit charge which is for
saving
electricity
thank you uh representative McGee is
acknowledged for our comments thank you
Mr chairman um I guess that seemed what
uh what representative Bernardi just
said I guess is that the Crux of the
discussion that we're having the debate
that we're having the language that was
in uh the original Provisions here from
line seven starting with the word such
say such benefits as approved by
Regulators May
include but not necessarily be limited
to which representative Harrington's
Bill strikes programs for low income
Energy Efficiency uh customers or
low-income customers Energy Efficiency
programs and then the bolded language is
whose main purpose is to reduce
consumption of electricity and not some
other form of energy that's added
language that's not what the system
benefit charge was originally and in
statute designed to do that is what
representative Harrington's Bill does to
to the language and the statute and so
what it does is it narrow casts our
ability to actually derive the savings
that were indicated by having a system
benefits charge and to representative
oam's Point earlier what that does is it
removes our ability to save people money
over time because this is a this is a
collective way to be able to to uh
invest in lowering how much of the
transmission charge is actually
allocated to our state so really the
only way we can attack lowering rate
payers Bills or the portion that we are
required to pay is by doing what the
system benefits charge does and if those
funds are allowed to help us transition
the home heating sector uh uh to
beneficial electrification that is also
a desirable thing because that's another
place where our emissions are still high
and we're going to have a really hard
time getting handle on it so
as well so all of those things are
supported by our having money available
through the system benefit charge to
help people become more efficient there
is no downside to this to the debate to
keep repeating the same points over and
over and over you made your point right
and the point is that it's not
economical speaker uh that I will allow
and then I'm gon to call the vote that's
representative s go ahead
representative thank you Mr chairman um
well I sympathize with representative
Harrington in one way um I understand
that originally the idea was that this
should be something linked to the
electric
bill and uh however I think people also
figured out pretty quickly that that
electric bill is based on uh how much
energy you're using in your home of all
kinds whether it's electricity or or
Heating and that is why the scope of the
SBC was expanded to include all forms of
energy efficiency regardless of what
whether it was electricity or other
sources and like was mentioned before
insulation is the number one thing you
start with when anytime you're trying to
reduce any type of energy and that
subsequently reduces other energies the
funding for New Hampshire saves much as
that money is going to insulating homes
that need it desperately uh as I
mentioned I I visited her Richardson our
former chairman on this committee uh who
who lives in a trailer home and uses
electricity for air conditioning and
heating uh however it's not particularly
well insulated so he benefits greatly
from these kind of projects and
incidentally our energy use electricity
is only 30% of our energy use in total
we need to use everything every measure
we can to reduce the total energy we're
using and it benefits everybody not just
the electrical use thank you
representative s
apprciate repetition of points that have
been already made I'd like to call on
the clerk now to call the role on the
motion of OTP on HB
3es Mr Mr chairman is no uh I had my
hand raised can we not have a
discussion no we cannot because we're
running out of time number one number
two you've already made your points I
want well I've made one point second
thank okay Mr CL would you please call
yes representative Thomas
yes
number okay representative Haring
yes representative n yes representative
burner yes representative PL votes yes
representative barish yes representative
Bernardi yes representative kend yes
representative yes representative white
yes representative
S no represent KY
pits no
repres where
represent
represent you're not you're muted
John no
represent no Representative
Vincent Representative
Vincent Representative mck
no representative MC Williams
no
Representative no Representative
commel no
[Music]
representative okay
uh can we ask Representative Vincent if
he's on there still or what
happened represent chairman votes
yes
vote is 11 to9 one.
voting okay representative are you
there Representative Vincent does not
appear to be there so we'll call the
vote the representative representative V
to9 on the bottom no okay representative
V yes who's speak who's representative
Jackie representative Jackie um before I
I would like to just ask where
is representative PL because he's not
appearing on my screen and he's not
appearing with a phone raise your
hand I'm sitting with
s raise it raise it again so she can see
look at the
room
see I just want you to know where he was
I can't see him I'm to the uh left of
chairman votes so he's in the room he's
there okay thank you okay thank you okay
thank you
um so I will now close the exec session
on HB
uh blur excuse me the report author for
the majority report will be
representative Thomas is there a going
to be a Minority Report representative
officer yes uh cat represent McGee will
do that okay representative
McGee and when would you like to have
that Mr
chairman um
today's Friday so let's let's go for
next Wednesday by
noon okay thank
you okay
so with that we close the uh the exec
session on HB 351 we don't have time to
start another one so we'll wait for two
minutes and then we'll open the public
hearing on
HB 407 I got to call
somebody
four7 still
[Applause]
be
that
right
for
okay welcome back everybody it is now
11:01 so I am going
to call to order the public hearing on
House Bill
407 and I will turn the floor over to
the prime sponsor of the bill
representative McGee and representative
McGee since there's only two people who
have signed up to speak on this bill
I'll give you five minutes plus thank
you I I don't think I'll need it I have
written I wrote my testimony it's not
that long but I am going to try and
clarify what sort of is happening with
this so um I focus my testimony on
trying to clarify for the committee what
it is and what it isn't so thank you
chairman Vose and distinguished
colleagues I come to you uh to present
HB 407 relative to the purchase of
output bless you of limited I'm sorry
that's okay um uh relative to the
purchase of output of limited electrical
energy producers in interstate commerce
and including qualifying storage systems
HB 407 started its journey in the
legislature last session as hb1
1262 the bill was sponsored by
representative of costable and supported
by Governor sonunu as it moved through
the process critics uncovered some holes
that they thought needed to be filled
for the bill to meet its objectives hb1
1262 was sent to interim study and was
reviewed in August and the resulting
recommendations uh appear in the bill
you have before you today HB
407 uh HB 294 which was just introduced
by representative Lang uh earlier this
morning is identical in language to HB
uh 1262 from last session representative
Pearl and I had discussed uh merging our
bills since HB 407 includes his bill
language but it adds the changes that
had been discussed throughout the
process last
session uh representative Pearl and I
opted to allow both bills to come
forward so that the house uh Tech
science technology and energy committee
could sort it
out the first clarification comes in the
definition on line 3 section 3 of uh
limited production or limited electrical
energy producer the bolded language uh
beginning on line four of the PDF if you
have it there includes a qualifying
storage system because we know that
storage though held to the side as
distinct from generation is used to
reduce load and addresses demand and
therefore it needs to be accounted for
in the definition of energy
output uh so that was one of the things
that was missing that was identified
during the conversation so they added
that next I understand from former um
science technology and energy Vice
chairman Moffett and others who were
there for the conversations that Public
Utilities Commission rate making expert
George mclusky and representative
costable had had concerns that I believe
um I believe um Mr Belo had mentioned
when 294 was being being heard that per
Lea Lepa retailers might enjoy a type of
double dipping if they could sell their
energy and also participate in net
energy metering programs so the language
of HB 407 expressly prohibits that
potential another concern addressed in
HB 407 is that limited retail
interestate sellers would not be able to
drift between retail and wholesale
markets or be counted as assets by the
iso New England
so the language you see in lines 4
through1 the bolded areas uh bring those
agreed upon clarifications into the
definition of who and what a limited
electric energy producer is and how they
will participate in a retail as a Retail
Energy seller behind the
meter the rest of the statute language
is designed was originally designed uh
to define the particulars of how limited
electric energy producers are regulated
and accounted for because we need to
keep current with statute language that
includes relevant energy categories and
producers and that and that was the
original bipartisan purpose of the bill
the last bolded section um that you'll
notice relates to adding language under
the utility property tax exclusion for
this new limited
producer category that uh so that it is
consistent with the other categories
that are currently included in RSA
D so it would add that new section just
so that they are also included uh in
that in that language and and that's it
in a nutshell and that's that's about as
much as I know about what it was
intended to do and what the changes are
that you have before you in this
particular
bill so I'm happy to take
questions thank you representative McGee
for that excellent introduction of this
bill I have a question for
you I noticed that um Tom Fran from the
you see us here I may ask this question
of him later but I'll ask it of you
first and that is last year when we
heard this bill there was
considerable uh concern about whether or
not this bill provided sufficient
guidance to the Pu and the utilities to
be able to
implement this program this limited
electrical energy production program do
you recall that discussion and do you
think this the changes in this bill
satisfy those
concerns thank you for the question uh
chairman
Bose it you know I wasn't privy to those
conversations um I am not sure I I think
you're right that probably um
commissioner France would be able
to uh speak to that more directly in
terms of the conversations that happened
but I think that's sort of a cart before
the horse thing here because I I believe
that the Public Utilities Commission
would be the correct place for those
conversations or stakeholder processes
to happen in order to determine further
guidance I think the bill uh clarifies
and establishes that this is um
something that we want to happen and I I
I'm not sure that that we should be
providing all of those definitions so
maybe he can speak he's probably more
familiar with uh you know how this
process should go forward and whether
there's anything lacking in legislation
that would um that would undermine the
puc's ability to move forward in
regulating okay thank you I uh am not
going to put Mr Fran on the spot quite
yet because we have
another testifier who may be may be able
to answer the question himself
so the chair now recognizes
representative ssuch for a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
represent mgee for taking my question
actually I I want to clarify I think on
the first page on line five you talk
about qualified storage systems and
qualified Cod generators but then you
only mention as a a unit five megawatts
5 megawatts is a rating for Generation
but it's not a rating for battery
storage if it was five megawatt hours
that would be a battery storage capacity
so there needs to be either a a second
second unit or less than something else
or there needs to be a differentiation
between battery storage capacity and
Generation Well I think thank you for
your question um and I understand I take
your point I believe and the language I
was helped by by Clifton below the
language in terms of including the
definition of storage and then adding
the language about discharge capacity in
uh in a consistent manner with uh rated
generation so um my understanding is
that you would want to create that uh
ceiling um because of the firk
implications of going over the 5
megawatt but I think he can probably
explain it more detailed than I can um
I believe that that 5 megawatt ceiling
would also relate to uh the output
coming from your storage capacity uh Mr
chairman
followup followup uh I'd have to
disagree with that because whether you
release 5 megawatts of power in one hour
or in 10 hours makes a big difference
it's the difference between how long
your battery is going to last and at
what voltage you want to operate it at
so I think that five megawatts is is a a
generating capacity uh but it's not a
battery storage unit a measure so y i i
i i do point of order please
yeah yes what's your point of order uh
we're debating the issue here I thought
we were supposed to be just uh
soliciting information from the
sponsor uh good point uh good point
well I was asking a question here so
yeah so you did uh eventually get around
to a question and uh I wanted to know if
that's a unit of battery storage or not
and it isn't right corre so thank you we
appreciate that representative
Harrington you're recognized for a
question I'm sorry that was whoops that
was my only comment was that we didn't
want to get into a debate oh okay thank
you uh all right um
seeing no other questions for
representative representative Bernardi
you're recognized for a question thank
you Mr chairman uh and uh thank you for
uh taking my question uh in the
negotiations that perfected this bill
from its historical Roots uh did the
governor's team finally sign off on that
is this version something he has looked
at and agre read
to I am not aware whether he is aware of
the um the bill that took into
consideration the conversations that had
come up along the way um when I spoke
with representative Purl who was
sponsoring the original Bill he had been
asked to put the bill in because
representative costable hadn't returned
to the legislature and he wasn't really
familiar with the bill so he just knew
that they wanted to bring the bill back
so I I'm not really privy to whether or
not the governor is aware of the level
of detail of the conversations that went
on and the suggested changes but I think
if if Clifton Belo is going to be
testifying he was privy to all that so
he may be able to answer it for
you thank you thank you uh I uh spoke to
a representative from the governor's
office yesterday or the day before and
the governor uh is neutral on this bill
and on the other leap bill this year he
uh doesn't see either as a
priority all right so seeing no further
questions
for representative McGee I'd like to
next recognize Clifton Belo who is
representing the city of Lebanon and Mr
Bel you have uh five minutes plus thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
um I am here in strong support of this
bill on behalf of the city of Lebanon um
although I began working on this issue
25 years ago long before I thought I'd
be involved in advocating for municipal
aggregation I think it does it would be
very supportive of what we would like to
do in the city of Lebanon with Municipal
aggregation which is create options
outside of net metering that are
market-based that we could could use um
a distributed generation and storage uh
to help serve uh customer load right
within the city um and we potentially
have a couple project that that could do
that um and the the to to to go right to
representative some such as question the
phrase here is discharge capacity and
and any battery storage system any
storage system has a rate at which they
can U discharge or Supply whatever they
have stored um electricity or thermal
energy so a maximum rated discharge
capacity of less than 5 megawatt is is
the threshold that's equivalent to
generating capacity it's not the storage
capacity it's it's how the rate at which
power can be discharged and if it's more
than 5 megawatts is going to have to be
registered with ISO New England and so
shouldn't be eligible for this activity
that that's what that's based on that
that would be a very large battery
because it would probably it would have
more than an hour's worth of storage but
um it there are such things being
developed um I think as representative
McGee said this this bill tries to
address the concerns that were re raised
last year um it it and I don't you know
I can't speak for the Pu I haven't had a
chance to have discussions with them
this about it but they there were
concerns raised last year about
potential double dipping because the
language um in the former Bill wasn't as
clear uh this tries to clear that up
makes very explicit that you if you're
participating in these retail or within
State wholesale sales you cannot also be
an generator an asset in the New England
system or participating in net metering
so there's no double dipping um it uh
does clarify jurisdictional issues
essentially the the uh Supreme Court has
made clear as the federal power act has
always stated that uh states that FK
only has jurisdiction over Interstate
sales and uh inter and transmission that
occurs between states U the efforts to
define those boundaries um are are
fairly clear uh you know there is a gray
area where generators can choose one or
the other but they shouldn't be able to
choose both I don't believe um and so
this reflects those uh there um are um
there has been some con concern or
controversy even I would say um whether
about uh transmission charges what kind
of generation distributed generation or
storage reduces the allocation of
transmission charges and what doesn't um
uh and and
traditionally just to explain that a
little bit because it's important to
understand uh transmission which which
only has to do with the F jurisdictional
high voltage system that serves the
interstate Market um you know there is a
boundary there and there's nowadays
there's a almost everywhere there's a
wholesale meter Point uh that is at the
boundary between the high voltage
transmission system usually 115 KV or
higher and uh the distribution grid
which is usually lower than that
occasionally 115 but um and at that
wholesale meter point is where the load
of the distribution system which is all
retail load is behind that uh meter
Point um that is that measurement at the
hour of coincident Peak for each month
is how transmission costs are allocated
the transmission uh owners have a
revenue requirement and essentially that
Revenue requirement gets spread over um
the 12 months of the year and charge on
a monthly basis and it's based on a look
back on on the previous month's um hour
of coincident beak and what's measured
at each one of those wholesale meter
points traditionally um if you were a
network resource a bulk generator um
that was happened to be connected to the
distribution grid which there are some
of even even 20 or 30 megawatt size
power plants you're considered what's
called a network resource or generation
asset and you have to um register You
Are by DEA facto um big enough that you
considered participating in inter sale
wholesale markets um but traditionally
distributed Generation Um and storage
for that matter as it's developed in New
England that's less than 5 megawatts in
in its discharge or generating capacity
um have not been considered and if they
don't register with ISO New England as a
market participant they're not
considered um have not been considered
bulk system uh network resources and uh
the load that they serve on the
distribution goup
has functioned to reduce the allocation
of transmission charges because because
they're seen as load reducers um the
internal Market Market monitor at ISO
New England raised a question last year
uh as to whether that was an appropriate
practice uh without going into all the
legal issues I will say that most of the
transmission owners including eversource
National Grid um have come forward with
a proposal to the transmission Committee
of iso New England to clarify this in a
way that would say if you're not if
you're not registered with ISO New
England as as a generation asset Market
participant uh then you would function
as a load reducer uh which is the
current policy with regard to all the
energy markets but you would also
function as a load reducer relative to
the allegation uh allocation of
transmission charges so this bill would
give credit where credit is due uh but
only to the extent that there's actually
measured um uh output onto the
distribution Grid at that hour of
coincident Peak and only if it actually
reduces the allocation of transmission
charges so sort of regardless of how
this is resolved at ISO New England uh
this bill would work if if if it's
determined that some of these resources
um are subject to what's called load
reconstitution that is the load that
they serve at that hour quincon Peak
gets back gets added back into that
wholesale meter reading to determine
transmission allocation then they would
not actually produce reduced uh
transmission cost and they would not get
any credit for that um so those are the
main highlights I wanted to point out
this this is um um you know could be a
real market-based alternative that New
Hampshire could really set an example
for other states that here's a way to do
this that doesn't involve cross
subsidies uh there would be some benefit
for all distribution customers uh
because the credit on transmission would
just be based on the output um at at the
distribution grid level and there'd be
some savings from uh transmission uh uh
losses M mainly um mainly really uh the
Step Down Transformer from the high
voltage system to the low voltage where
there's significant losses so there'd be
some benefit perhaps on the order of 5%
to all distribution customers by
reducing this allocation of transmission
cost the bigger benefit ultimately in
terms of providing this kind of you know
marginal cost price signal is that he
gives incentives to use storage and and
distributed generation to help shave
those Peaks and typically move some of
that load off peak which which
ultimately saves everybody money because
we don't have to build more capacity uh
to serve the same number of kilowatt
hours so we end up spreading all these
capacity costs over um more kilowatt
hours rather than few and can help bring
down these costs over time for everyone
and it's the same basis on which the Pu
approved battery pilot for I for Liberty
Utilities um it's the same sort of
theoretical basis on which they are
getting credit for avoided transmission
and capacity costs by using uh these
residential batteries to dispatch them
at these expected hours of coincident
Peak you have to you actually have to
dispatch them for more than the single
hour because you don't know which one
that's going to be so you have to try to
Target what you think might be the peak
and help shave that Peak and get credit
for it now within Liberty Utilities
regulatory structure but this would open
this up to kind of a market-based credit
and really put most of the burden on the
load serving entity the supplier that is
um For Whom the uh limited producer is a
customer served they they they
essentially have to be behind a retail
meter and um they would be responsible
for accounting for that um you know we
would have to work under the Pu would
have to you know has the full Authority
Under This to set you know oversee this
and set up how this is going to work and
obviously there'd be some work uh with
the distribution utilities to make sure
it's not burdensome on them in fact
there's language in here uh that that
the commission take into account um that
it not to avoid any uh substantial risk
or uncompensated cost to the electric
utility in the franchise area where this
takes place so that that gives the
commission a lot of discretion uh to to
work with stakeholders to kind of get
this right so thank you for your
attention happy to respond to any
questions or continue to work with the
committee in the limited amount of time
to try to get this market-based approach
uh to to to help Drive Innovation and
harness the power uh competitive markets
to reduce costs to rate payers all all
around um and and sort of avoid coming
back to the subsidy debates around that
metering at Large Scale thank
you thank you Mr Bilo we appreciate your
testimony I recognize representative
samich for a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr Belo for taking my
question uh I still have to disagree
with you uh one megawatt in my view is
not a battery or discharge capacity now
maybe if you can explain to me whether
there's an implo
uh rating that everything is rated for
one hour then I can understand that then
it would be 5 megawatt of energy
released in one hour but without any
time uh Association it's that's not a
battery storage
unit um I believe that every battery
storage system if it's electrical
battery does in fact have have a rated
maximum output it can only discharge at
so many kilowatts per hour or so many
kilowatts um
instantaneously and so I I mean I happy
to work with you think you think there's
other words than discharge uh capacity
but but every battery storage the
manufacturer says you cannot discharge
this at a higher rate than one kilowatt
per hour or one you know discharge rate
of 1 kilowatt whether that's half a
kilowatt over half an hour or 1 kilowatt
over an hour
um that's what it is and and and ISO New
England has generally taken the same uh
view which is that if a battery can put
onto the grid more than five megawatts
instantaneously at any point in time uh
because that's an instantaneous
measurement the capacity to put out
power adding the per hour is is is the
quantity that occurs over that period of
time but if it can put out more than
five megawatts instantaneously then it
needs to be registered with them as a
bulk um asset as a as an asset uh on the
system uh so this is just trying to
align that line with with the iso New
England for jurisdictional boundary if
there's a better way to word it
certainly that could be
considered thank
you thank you below
recognizes P
question thank you uh Mr chairman thank
you Mr Belo for uh
being here to answer our questions so if
I had a 20 Mega hour uh storage facility
and I could only discharge 5
megawatts uh then I would be able to
discharge 5
megawatts
for four hours is that
correct that would be correct yes yep
thank
you
okay uh see no further questions for Mr
Belo I think it's time at this point in
time to put Mr France on hot seat and
ask him to respond to a question Mr
friends you recall from past years a
discussion about whether there was
sufficient language in this bill to
allow uh it to be implemented by the puc
and the utilities
I do recall that I've looked at this
bill the Pu takes no position on this
bill except to say that we are happy to
work with Mr Belo and certainly any
members of st& if uh you believe
additional language is needed I think Mr
Belo did a rather admirable job of
describing
uh this bill and what it does uh pretty
accurate accurately and how it fits into
the iso
markets so you have no concerns about
it's being
implementable I'll have to check with
our attorneys on that representative o
uh and I'm happy to get back to you
because the issues we had were probably
more legal than anything but I think
this bill addresses a number of the
concerns we had from last
year okay I thank you for being here and
for being willing to uh answer our
questions seeing no questions uh from
any of the other members of the
committee it is now
1127 or 28 so let us close the hearing
on HB 407 I'll announce that on the blue
sheet we had 130 people 137 people
signed up in support of the bill one
person signed up in opposition to the
bill
so we'll close the public hearing on HB
407 and that gives us time
to do a couple of more executive
sessions so I will now open an executive
session on HB is Harrington with
us is Harrington with us yes well
he's looks like he is so
H executive session on HB 289 thank you
representative
Harington and ask representative
Harrington for a
motion uh I move the
uh 289b ought to
pass thank you uh the chair recognizes
representative C
[Music]
Bros
9 thank you representative camb brose so
we have a motion
to render HB 289 as ought to pass that
motion has been made and seconded is
there any discussion representative
Harrington is recognized for yeah this
is a simply a bill that allows battery
or any type of storage for that matter
uh it's 30 megawatts or over it does two
things it makes it if if it allows the
site evaluation committee to get
involved if it's the maximum discharge
or instantaneous discharge is I think is
the the term that we're getting some
confusion over here I think uh Clifton
did it pretty well explaining that um if
it's 30 megawatts or or above that that
would give the SEC uh primary
jurisdiction on this the side evaluation
committee I'm sorry I should spell say
that out and if it's below that since
it's now become an energy facility it
gives the towns that the the potential
that they plan to build in the option of
petitioning the site evaluation
committee and saying we don't have the
technical or financial expertise to
evaluate this project and therefore we
would like the S evaluation committee to
do that and and that does a lot of
different things it brings in a uh an
attorney from the uh Attorney General's
office gets assigned to the case then to
represent the the people it also allows
the town to petition the site evaluation
committee to say uh we need this expert
that uh we just don't have the $20,000
to pay for uh and the site evaluation
committee can award those funds from the
um from the petitioner the person who
wants to build it so it opens up a lot
of resources for them and I mean as I
think there was a case in Littleton
where there was a proposal on this and
there was a lot of confusion on uh what
was going on in different uh trying to
do it so it's it's simply a a way of
allowing the the the time PS uh to have
more resources and also I've been
contacted by some people who represent
uh people that would potentially put in
uh large battery storage and they would
much rather deal with the uh site
evaluation committee uh on a process
that they understand and know than
dealing with a town where they really
just don't know what's going to happen
so it just it's we I think everybody
wants to get more battery storage or any
type of storage because we're going to
maximize the use of the uh interruptible
power from solar and wind uh it really
complement to have uh storage facilities
there thank you representative
Harrington representative son just
recognize for a
comment uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you represent Harrington for
bringing this bill I had conversations
with people from Littleton too when that
battery project was proposed and I think
you're absolutely right they need to
have some support from the SEC side of
value valuation committee on projects
like this uh so I I really uh commend
you for bringing this bill and um um I
also commend you for using a 30 megawatt
hours in your bill thank
you okay seeing no uh further comments
well we have one representative oxum you
recognized for a
com uh yes we had something of a
discussion on this at time of the public
hearing but the prime sponsor wasn't uh
available so just just to further
clarify this issue would you agree that
a 30 megawatt hour is approximately a
7.5
megawatt
facility to whom do you direct that
question I thought I made it clear the
prime sponsor wasn't available at the
time of the public hearing so it's to
the prime sponsor
I'm assuming that's me then yes sir okay
uh to tell you the truth I I don't know
off the top of my head because uh it I
suppose that would differ with different
batteries uh some batteries would be
made to have uh the instantaneous
discharge as rapidly as possible where
others may be designed to have an output
uh of a lower discharge over many more
hours okay could I have a followup
please
excuse me go ahead oh thank you very
much I'm I'm disappointed that that you
can't give me a little bit more we we
were trying to get a sense of how what
the physical presence of this entity
might be because this after all is what
the site evaluation committee is really
about is if if you think of these as
large containers about the size of
something that fits on the back of a uh
big semi-trailer
could you give us a sense of how many of
those might be stacked or placed
alongside each other on a on a
particular lot to be producing at this
um this not rate uh this amount of
energy I I I simply don't know the
answer to the question but I I can tell
you that if you're going to store 30
megawatt hours of electricity in
something uh you're not talking about
something you're going to put the back
of a pickup truck this is going to be
very very large much larger than that
how how big I don't know maybe someone
else uh here that might uh know a little
bit more about battery storage than me
but 30 megawatt hours is an incredible
amount of electricity so it's going to
be big yes I was talking about
containers on the back of a semitrailer
not the back of a pickup it probably
multiple ones at least definitely it's
going to be multiple we were just trying
to get a handle on how many is it 10 is
it 100
I wish I wish I could help you I just
don't know I I do think it's more in the
range of 10 but thank you
anyway representative Cali bitson is
recognized for a
comment don't forget to
unmute a clarifying question if I may is
30 megawatt hours the limit or can the
will the SBC get involved if we go
higher than 30 megawatt hour
if if I may Mr chairman thank
you yeah it's 30 megawatt hours of
grader so just so it's clear because
this is an important point they they
have primary jurisdiction if it's 30
megawatt hours of Greater if it's below
that the municipality has the option of
petitioning them and saying we don't
have the resources to handle this please
help us which has happened on a number
of the smaller wind projects there was a
24 megawatt Wind project in lemster and
they said we don't know what to do with
with this and it came the p and the SEC
took jurisdiction but if it's 60 or 100
they would definitely have primary
jurisdiction thank
you thank you okay see no more uh
questions or comments I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of
ought to pass for HB
289 representative Thomas Vice chair yes
representative Harrington
yes representative n yes representative
burer yes
representative yes representative yes
representative Bernard yes
representative K yes
representative yes representative white
yes
representative yes representative c p
represent yes
represent yes yes Representative
[Music]
Vincent Representative
Vincent representative M yes repres MC
Williams yes
represent yes representative
P yes representative Pas yes and the
chairman V chair votes yes
okay
well no it isn't we not one nonp that's
20 20 to nothing
but lady at the
bottom yeah I think of grean hairport
yeah because it took me Janine taught me
that
yes and represa c p probably going to
move
consent representative Cali Pitt is
recognized for a
motion where' she go where' she
go
okay move consent there we go you moved
consent correct yes sir without
objection this this bill will appear on
the consent calendar so with that I'll
close the uh executive session on HB
okay so our next on something my bill
went through unanimously next I would
like a
public exective
session the only time someone tried we
can hear you I hear you I muted him next
I would like to open a public hearing on
uh HB 396 and recognize representative
mner for motion exact session is it
which the number 373 I have yes exact
session did I miss think mistake
that3 373 we have
next uh We've deferred the the exact
session on 373 because representative
Thomas has asked for an amendment he
been told that it's on away but it's not
here yet okay so what what's the number
again so I would like to open an exec
session on HB
396 okay and request a and recognize
representative mner for motion I'll make
a motion for itl on House Bill 396
representative mner moves itl on HP 396
and representative n is recognized I
second the motion repr representative n
seconds the motion so it's been moved
and seconded at HB 396 be judged
itl uh is there any
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl for HB
you starting another
puzzle the last
one last one that means your toe better
get
better yes represent har
yes yes representa yes represent yes
representative
yes yes representative C yes
representative yes representative white
yes
represent no representative Kelly P
no no
no no and I protest the fact that this
has been rushed in this way with no
discussion
whatsoever
representative
M no representative MC
Williams no
representa
no Representative
pel no representative
POS
Representative
no repres the chair chair votes
yes excuse me Mr chair I didn't hear a
representative Vincent's name
called it was called twice with no
answer oh okay thank
you 11 to n we one not
voting okay on the mo for HB
motion itl carries 11
representative mner will
the majority report will there be a
minority I hope
so
representative who will write
the uh lee will you do that yes indeed
okay thank
you Lee
o please have that to us
Wednesday could you repeat that
sir representative oxan will write The
Minority
Report To Us by Wednesday at that was
Wednesday at no noon yeah thank you I
forgot to turn on my mic that's why you
couldn't hear me Wednesday at noon my
apologies no no problem thank you
okay all right so that uh concludes the
executive session for HB
396 Mr chair uh representative close uh
you had a blue sheet in four opposed
numbers last time which uh for the
396 oh there was a blue sheet but I have
no idea where it
is we were ex s we were in exec session
not public thank you uh I I think I can
answer that question Mr chairman I have
a record that says we had 82 yeses on
this and zero
NOS okay thank you representative s
representative Thomas what's the status
of your amendment to HB 373 there is
they are unable to
contact oh it's such a mess over
there okay so OS apparently is not
available and so we will defer an exec
session on HB 373 until another
time and since we have no
other bills on the list to exec looks
like we're going to get a bonus of 15
minutes on our lunch break Mr M I ask a
question of the chair represent
resentative Harrington you're recognized
for a question did we address uh HB
225 we haven't had a public hearing on
oh okay I thought we had okay thank you
no problem representative Ox you had a
question uh yes I was reviewing my notes
on HB 172 and I don't believe we had a
reading of the blue sheet on that could
I I understand you wouldn't have that at
hand but could we um ask our research
assistant to make make that information
available you certainly can uh Jen would
you try to resurrect the blue sheet for
HP 172 and give us I think I can do that
right now if you give me just a
second I attached them to all the
reports all the hearings I attached to
thank you Jen we appreciate you doing
that Mr
chair other building can I skip
out so for HB 172 I have in support 310
in opposition 33 neutral
2 thank you very much and um could could
you make that list available to us so we
could see what I can forward that to the
full committee thank
you okay thank you so with that we'll uh
call the morning
session
has ended and we'll get an extra 15
minutes on our lunch break I'll see
everybody back here at 1 o'clock to open
the public hearing on HP 225 thank you
very much have a good
lunch
open
for
e
that
is
gra
[Music]
gra can I
do
[Music]
CU I'm
feeling
Lee put yourself on
mute you might want to put yourself on
mute for
lunch
I'm always nous I suppose the room is
muted but we're not can anybody else
hear
me yes I can hear you okay thanks I'm
sorry about
that wonder if I'm sing a blank screen
while everybody else is talking no I
heard you
snoring
snoring just
kidding just wailing on my guitar here
oh yeah
that's uh yeah that's what we need to
do maybe we need to have a special St
Dem blues
song oh yeah
well I could suggest
several that's don't you have no mercy
in this
land um I'm into the blues heavily so
did you guys see the amendment 373 that
just got sent
out I did they're going to exect that
bill today so that's why they're giving
us a late breaking Amendment oh no no
wait I
didn't what number was that again
373 this is the uh Americans for
Prosperity bill that says nothing about
the transportation climate initiative
but when they did the testimony they
told us that's what they were trying to
prevent yep the Department of
Environmental Services is
from coordinating on yeah
[Music]
yeah
gy ain't the
word everybody have a good
lunch
yeah time off good thing disability uh
caucus
today yeah
and well there's also the uh hearing is
going on right now I tried to tune in
for a little of that was that was was
any of that
uh legible jumping in the middle like
that
yeah it
was it was understandable but I only
caught a short bit of it American
Disabilities have a problem with the
right
now okay everyone welcome back I hope
you had a good
lunch time to resume our activity
and I will now open the public
hearing on Bill HB
225 and I will ask the prime sponsor of
the bill who is representative Fred flet
to introduce the bill representative
flet the floor is yours thank you Mr
chair I'll cut this short by saying I
intend to ask for
an oh
okay do you want to say anything else
about it no we'll bring it back the some
next year we have more time okay
excellent any questions for
representative CL I couldn't hear a word
of
it oh you didn't unmute
used I didn't hear it
either the room appears to be
unmuted I think he's just a little bit
far from a microphone perhaps proposed
an itl you hear me
now we can hear you Fred yes we can hear
you okay I my my entire statement was
I'll cut this short I intend to it
request an itl for the bill it will come
back in some form next
year thank you okay any questions for
representative
CL seeing
none we will now turn to the next
speaker who has signed up to speak on
the bill that one's your
mic and uh I don't see the next speaker
listed that would have been mayor Jim
Donis from n nashwa but he does not
appear to be on the list well that's
fast
so we would go to the third person on
the list who is Clifton be
oh except he also does not appear to be
on the
list so we'll go to the fourth person on
the
list who
is Doria
Brown she doesn't appear to be here
either so we'll go to the next person
who is Joseph
Quik see Mr qu oh yes there he is okay
Mr
quis you
are Jennifer can you hear
me yes I can can you make me a co-host I
apparently
off there you
go okay so Mr Quik I can now allow you
to speak and the floor is yours
for well I'll give you two minutes how's
that uh thank you Mr chairman can you
hear
me yes thank you I I'll keep this short
also um although house spill 225
increases the eligible net metering
customer generator Peak generating
capacity of 2 megaw it dramatically and
inappropriately undervalues the rates
paid for this generation by the electric
distribution utility by setting the
rates at the equivalent of wholesale
rates setting of neet net metering rates
at the equivalent of wholesale rates
fails to recognize the value of this
generation in lowering the cost of
electricity for all New England excuse
me all New Hampshire electric bill
payers including lowering utility
electricity demand lowering transmission
costs lowering emissions of carbon and
other pollutants from fossil based
generation uh delaying or eliminating
costly distribution system upgrades and
keeping precious energy dollars within
New Hampshire I also want to just stress
that um renewable energy along with
Energy Efficiency are actually load
reduction uh assets for the distribution
and transmission Grid in New Hampshire
they're very valuable as we start to try
to reduce those assets over time it'll
make our grid even less resilient over
time so I'm definitely in opposed uh to
this legislation uh today or next year
thank you Mr chairman I would take
questions if people have
any thank you one minute 7 Seconds all
done a new record a new
record are there any questions from MRN
representative
recogn thank you uh Mr uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr kwasnik um
just because we have many new people on
our committee uh could you explain to us
exactly what that means or what the
differences are between the energy uh
that is being compensated or the price
that's being paid for net net metered
solar energy and if if we were to reduce
that the wholesale
price I'll try to do that um I think
that uh solar energy uh produced under
net metering is is more akin to the
default price of energy and I say that
because um there have been several
studies one done by the New Hampshire
Electric Co-op a number of years ago
trying to actually ascertain the value
of net metering electricity uh to the
customers or excuse me the the members
of the uh the co-op and they concluded
that uh when you take in all the aspects
of renewable energy under net metering
including reduction in transmission
costs um reductions in need to upgrade
uh distribution facilities whether they
be substations or or even just the wires
distribution wires um and also some of
the other existences of low carbon they
thought that um it actually was around
the price of default energy and actually
could have even a little more value than
that uh trying to Value uh uh net excuse
me net metering from solar at a
wholesale rate is um it really
denigrates the value of of wholes of um
net metering energy uh it tremendously
undervalues it and I think it puts the
Whole Net metering Concept in Jeopardy
if uh we be we end at a wholesale rate
for net metered
solar Mr chairman followup followup go
ahead uh yes Mr Quik uh do you happen to
know what approximately that price is
for default versus wholesale price uh it
varies depending on the utility uh the
location and but in general wholesale
prices are R in the order of 3 to four
cents a kilowatt hour whereas default
rates depending on the utility can be 8
to 10 cents per kilow
hour thank you thank
you thank you seeing no more questions
for Mr Quik we'll thank Mr kwasnik for
being here and I'll recognize the next
speaker who is Doria Brown a member of
the public representing the city of
NASA and do uh Miss Brown you have the
floor for two
minutes hi my name is Doria Brown I'm
here from the city of Nashville as the
energy manager in opposition to HB
225 I oppose this bill because the
changing on how we calculate payments
back for net metering would be
detrimental to nasua as we have two
hydroelectric facilities one that is in
that net metering range where we make
about $500,000 in Revenue being able to
net meter with facility if we change the
makeup of net metering we will see those
profits decrease significantly so would
be a very big hit for the community we
also have four solar arrays two that are
um still coming up online on our schools
that benefit from that metering as well
as solar arrays on our municiple
buildings with our um fire department
and our Transit garage which will take a
hit as well if this bill moves forward
and we recalculate how we get payment
back for net metering it's just will be
very bad for the city of
nasua okay thank you nice job a minute
and five seconds well done to um refresh
everyone's memory the prime sponsor of
the bill has requested that the bill be
ited but we will take continue to take
testimony from people who have signed up
next on the list would be Clifton Belo
Mr Belo you have two minutes thank you
Mr chairman um I had a little T trouble
getting back in so I'd missed the point
that the prime had suggested itl uh but
just briefly um you know I concur that
um really net meter generation should be
treated as load reducers um when you
look at the overall um uh default
service rate for Liberty at least it's
averaged around 8 cents a kilowatt hour
over the past decade or so um about
today about 90% of that um is what is
paid to the supplier the load serving
entity and the remaining 10% is a
combination RPS compliance cost and the
cost of the utility to administer
default service so if it's treated as a
load reducer which is physically what it
is it reduces the load at that wholesale
meter point at the interface of
transmission and distribution then about
90% % of the cost would you know goes
away because that is U energy that does
not need to be procured by the supplier
the load serving entity from the
Interstate Wholesale Market because it's
being produced on the distribution grid
um so it it you know I I concur with the
sponsor's recommendation of itl thank
you thank you Mr Belo any questions for
Mr
Belo seeing none I'll call on the next
speaker who is Heidi croll who is a
lobbyist representing the granite state
Hydro Power Association miss croll you
have the floor for two minutes thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
good afternoon everyone um we would
concur with the recommendation to itl
House Bill
225 um the two points that I'd like to
make are first that uh the Pu is nearing
the end of a very expansive process to
study the value of distributed energy
resources um this process began in the
summer of 2017 following um order
26029 in docket de1 16-5 76 um and we uh
would encourage the committee to follow
should follow um should allow that
process to come to a completion um that
docket was open pursuant to passage in
2016 of House Bill
1116 which was relative to net metering
and um importantly all the parties to
that pu docket including the utilities
cons consumer Advocates renewable um
Advocates uh Granite State Hydro
included um and the office of energy and
planning all agreed um to the adoption
of um the the net metering tariff um
that's currently in effect um during a
period of time uh during which data
would be collected pilot programs would
be implemented and studies would be
conducted so um we uh agree that that
that work should be allowed to continue
and the settlements that were reached in
that doc
um should be respected um and and
adhered to the other thing I would
mention um is simply that um we uh gsha
firmly believes that distributed
generation resources um provide benefits
well beyond the wholesale market price
of net metered power um including
avoided transmission costs avoided
capacity cost and avoided environmental
cost um and any uh net metering credit
set mely at the wholesale market price
would significantly undervalue the true
benefits of distributed generation and
um deny Fair compensation to the owners
of distributed resources so with that um
we would uh urg its committee to um vote
uh Down House Bill 225 thank you for
your time and be happy to answer any
questions thank you the chair recognizes
Jackie C pittz for a question don't
forget to
unmute Miss corl could you please give
the docket number again I I couldn't
catch it sure absolutely sorry I was
trying to speak rapidly um yes the
docket number is
de6
d576 thank you thank you that docket was
opened pursuant in 2016 201 pursuant to
passage of House Bill
1116 thank you you're welcome recognizes
representative oxum for a
question thank you very much Mr chair
and thank you uh M croll for taking my
question once again we seem to have
missed the health benefits aspect here
and uh with the emissions commission
that did its work last summer I think
for those of us who are following the
proceedings uh were dramatic evidence
came forward about the public health
costs of the uh the system that we're
currently operating under and the
potential benefits to the health of New
Hampshire residents from reducing carbon
reducing fossil fuel use etc etc do do
you happen to have any um figures
available to you such as those from the
recent synapse report on the the health
benefits uh which should be added in on
top of the environmental
benefits um thank you for that question
um representative I actually don't have
um readily available to me right at the
this moment um uh estimates um but I
believe that uh estimates to what you're
speaking about um were um brought
forward by at least some stakeholders in
the docket um that I just referenced um
so it's possible that there's
information there um also clean energy
New Hampshire may have more information
um certainly follow up with you um or or
to the committee um but I apologize
don't have that data at my fingertips
right now Mr chair can I have a followup
yes go ahead thank you very much um I
was an intervenor in that the docka to
which you've referred and I also was uh
present and not a not did not agree to
the settlement uh that that you
referenced however I I don't remember
hardly any mention at all of health
benefits at that time which was why I
thought it was so stunning when we had
actual experts on public health
available at the emissions commission if
if I could just take one more moment to
bring forward from the synapse report
which was just released um in December
of
2020 public health and avoided CO2
benefits of local solar exceed $600
million from 2014 to 2019 in New England
and10
million your mic's not on representative
oxam you were recog nice to ask a
question is there a question
please you I muted you you have to
unmute
please it it was an apology we moved
from an executive session the last time
we spoke and now we're back into a
public hearing and I was still in
comment mode rather than asking a
question I apologize oh okay thank you
for that apology uh representative McGee
you're recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman and I
will try and make sure it is a question
it is a question um for the benefit of
the folks who are new to the committee
Miss croll would it be possible for you
to just describe um what the process is
for because there are are several bills
that have come across including this one
um that are bouncing between where the
authority lies for an understanding of
how the rates get set how the rates get
approved how the rates get moved and I
think it would be helpful if maybe you
could describe to us what the
stakeholder process is like so that
people could understand um the extent to
which the Public Utilities
Commission uh Works to try and determine
what the appropriate rates setting
is um I can try I personally have not
been representing uh the granite state
hydrop Power Association at the public
utility commission's docket um
Miss Mano um who I think is probably
going to be speaking has been intimately
involved and she may have more
information but I can say that in
general um starting back with House Bill
116 um which did um direct the Public
Utilities Commission to open a docket to
look into um you know establishing
appropriate um uh compensation for net
metered power namely the Excess power
that's put on to the grid um by a a
small generator um that's not used by in
a in a net metering or group net
metering Arrangement and the the Pu
under took that um task and is is did
set up what's referred to as kind of a
2.0 a net metering tariff 2.0 um but
there was a recognition I think among
all the parties that there would be some
value um to having uh a a distributed
energy uh distributed resource value
study and that is what's underway um
currently to get even more information
um there's some some pilot programs
being run um data being collected and so
uh I know that you know they're meeting
Milestones um and I think the final
study is expected to be completed by
March of
2022 um and so you know that there's a
lot of energy uh no pun intended a lot
of time and effort that's been um put
into uh that work at the Pu by many many
stakeholders and the Pu staff as well so
um and it is a collaborative process um
and uh like I said I think uh you know
they'll they'll have that study
completed by March of
2022 thank
you okay thank you m Miss croll um
seeing no other questions from Miss
croll I will call on the final speaker
for this bill that is mine Mano lobbyist
who works for who represents
New Hampshire Mr have the floor for two
minutes thank you Mr chairman and uh we
agree with the sponsor's recommendation
to itl this bill um I will Echo some of
the things that the other folks have
said we agreed that the general court um
tasked the Public Utilities Commission
by passing House Bill 1116 in 2016 to
look at the net metering tariff and
credit rate in detail and they were
specifically tasked to Ure an avoidance
of unjust and unreasonable cost shifting
and to investigate the rate effects on
all customers and the current net
metering tariff and credit rate that we
have in effect now is a result of that
detailed investigation that made sure
that those things were taken into
account and so we don't think it is fair
compensation to upend that by
legislation and to switch the credit to
wholesale and so though we agree with
the sponsor's recommendation itl now we
disagree that this bill should be
brought back um
again as we showed um in our synapse
report just in energy and avoided
capacity costs that study found that a
distributed generation is worth at least
a value of 13 and a half cents per
kilowatt hour that's more than our
default service rate that the larger net
meter projects get it's um maybe closer
to what the small net metered projects
get and
um wholesale currently is in the two to
three cents per kilowatt hour so it is
very very low we agree with u miss croll
that distributed generation has value
far beyond what wholesale generation
offers and um we're also very concerned
that this would change the rate for all
existing projects um we feel very
strongly that when people and businesses
make investment based on existing law
they shouldn't have the rug pulled out
from under them and that new changes in
law should be only going forward and not
change um seconds yeah not change uh the
law under which businesses and people
decided to make their Investments thank
you thank you Miss
Mano
uh we have a late
arrival who has listed him or herself as
nashaa mayor
at nash.com or something like that so uh
on the off chance that this might be uh
mayor James donantes I would like to
recognize him to speak before we come to
the end of this public hearing so I
would ask the two of you who have your
hands raised if you could just hold on
for another minute Mike could you be on
for the next bill the next bill is a
Nashville B at
130 Mr chair I'm on for both bills if
that was a question bills okay thank you
so Mr uh you're recognized for two
minutes go ahead sir well thank you Mr
chair and actually you know meline who
just testified meline Mano used to work
for the city as the city's uh waterways
manager and she was really a great
employee we were very sorry to lose her
but she's obviously gone onto something
very valuable so my testimony here is
very brief I mean I'm I will defer to
meline on the the technical aspects of
this particular bill but I'm just here
to testify in general in support of net
metering because I think it promotes the
uh use of clean power and um then when
we get to the next bill I will testify
specifically about how that would affect
our hydroelectric um our hydroelectric
dams uh the the net metering bill you
will have next so um I I will keep my
testimony now now this
brief okay thank you uh Mr Mayor are
there any questions for mayor daas or M
Mano uh representative ssuch you
recognized for a
question yes uh thank you Mr chairman
and uh thank you mayor dones uh I
actually have a question for mine mono
but uh nice to nice to see you here Mr
dones meline the uh can you can you say
something about anything you know about
the uh mentioned before about health
benefits that we can we can expect from
the U more net
metering sure um so as I mentioned we
worked with other um similar
organizations to uh commission this
report from synapse energy economics
that came out in December and it was
mostly focused on the energy and
capacity value of distributed generation
but they did also look at the Val the
public health value of avoided criteria
pollutants as well as avoided carbon
dioxide emissions and so they found that
the avoided criteria pollutants which is
SO2 nox and particulate matter 2.5 had a
value of one cent per kilowatt hour of a
generated solar or small hydro and then
there's a variety of prices
that different authorities have put on
avoided carbon
dioxide emissions so a low value would
be $112
per uh metric ton and a high value is
$425 per metric ton and so that gives a
range of a value of six cents per
kilowatt hours to 22.6 cents per
kilowatt hours of avoiding carbon Dio
avoided carbon dioxide
emissions and that's in table three page
seven of the synap report that I emailed
to you all with our written testimony
for this Bill thank very very much uh
representative oxen is recognized for a
question thank you very much Mr
chair um I mostly my question was was
answered in with um the help of
Representative ssuch thank you very much
but I was hoping that um while we have
you here we could ask you to speak a
little more broadly about why it is that
we think it's worthwhile to support
distributed res energy resources and uh
solar in particular um there there seems
what used to be a widespread consensus
that didn't need to be discussed seems
to have come into some doubt in the the
current uh makeup of our committee and I
think it might be helpful if some of
those um home truths were were
reiterated for for for the benefit of
all of us sure so our organization is
very focused I don't think that question
is Germaine to the bill we're discussing
so I'm going to uh it's absolutely
Germain of the bill we're talking about
the value of what solar does for
Hampshire arguing with me I told you
that I didn't think that question was
Germain to the to the bill we're we're
discussing well for the third time today
I protest topic but it's we're here to
talk about this specific
Bill representative partial do you have
a question about this
bill I do in fact thank you so much
chair um
this uh we had now I'm coming in as a
newer legislator trying to educate
myself and I hope you can help me out
here uh in 2016 we had a change in how
we calculate net metering and since that
time that's a very broad question is
there would you see a general decrease
or increase in all in production of
alternative energy such as solar and
could you attribute to that to possibly
the adoption of the 2016 standards as
opposed to the earlier
standards sure so the change that was
made as part of that Docket in 2016 is
that the small net metering projects
which are up to 100 kilowatts in
capacity used to get what was called
full retail credit so pretty much any
charge on your bill when you are export
anything you pay for electricity when
you're exporting you are credited that
same value that you pay for your
electricity when it's imported um that
was changed to default service the
transmission charge and 25% of the
distribution charge so that did lower
the value the larger projects which are
100 kilowatts to one
megawatt always have got default service
credit before and are still getting
default service credit so the value of
the net in credit there has not changed
we've also there are confounding factors
so we've seen large variations in the
value of renewable energy certificates
at the same time and so it's a little
bit difficult to say I will say that um
there's still pretty strong adoption of
of smaller scale solar though um
certainly there are challenges so it's a
little bit I don't think there was a
significant drop off I would say
Associated directly with that there is
um a lot of restriction on because the
credit changes so significantly under
100 kilowatts and over 100 kilowatts
that a lot of projects will um make
their projects smaller than they really
should be to serve their needs to get
the credit for the smaller
projects thank you can I ask a followup
followup go ahead um what have you seen
in other states by uh I mean I don't
know how our current stand standards uh
for uh reimbursement compared to other
states in our net metering and have you
seen any evidence in other states
of a no slowdown compared to our what we
say we don't know what it's rebal to but
us but our slowdown and small energy
production our um our net metering
credit is very conservative compared to
neighboring states as our our value of
renewable energy certificates and um the
lack of other incentives like we very
limited Grant rebate programs so there
is much more robust markets for
distributed energy resources in Vermont
and Massachusetts for example and Maine
used to be similar to us and however
they changed a lot of regulations
including ramping up their renewable
portfolio standard increasing the value
of credits increasing the size of
projects that can participate in net
metering and they are currently
undergoing a renewable energy boom and
seeing a tremendous amount of investment
in their state while we are not thank
you so much for your time and your
education okay thank you uh
representative SS just recognized for a
question yes thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Miss moo uh um just a question
about um you were talking prior to uh
the differences with small solar versus
large solar
um is is there a bigger impact uh from
one or the other let's say what I'm
getting at is uh is there benefit to
having hundreds of small solar projects
versus many bigger ones uh is it kind of
a wash or or are there some systematic
differences um in our view renewable
generators of different scales serve
different purposes so what we call
distributed Generations are those
smaller generators that are we think of
as 5 megawatt and less that don't
participate in the wholesale maret
markets there's certainly a role to play
for utility scale renewable projects be
they utility scale solar or utility
scale Hydro or our biomass plants or
things like that they also serve a
purpose however distributed generation
does have some attributes and some
benefits that are different and that
complement utility scale Generation Um
such as avoiding line losses such as
providing resilience by having a wide
distributed network of generators rather
than having one central power plant that
if that goes down you know it's a very
significant amount of generation that
that goes
down thank
you thank you representative parshall
the next bill is about basically the
same subject if you'd like to wait and
ask your question then that would be
appreciated I think who mean
representative pabel my is contract only
lasts a couple more years I think
yeah sorry I didn't understand
[Music]
that okay so uh representative
Harrington uh can your question wait for
the next bill well it's rather jine to a
statement that was just made I just
wanted to follow up I'll make it very
quick go ahead U yeah you uh thanks for
taking my question you just stated that
the distributed uh energy or distribut
generation has a lot of advantages I'm
wondering how about the disadvantages
because of the fact that distributive
generation has no obligation to run at
any particular time does this not bring
additional risks to the grid especially
if you get large amounts of it it could
shut on or off whenever they feel like
it with no uh
repercussions um the only disadvantage
that I would say is that it doesn't
benefit from the economies of scale so
it is you know more effective to build a
large Plant I don't think that it not
being dispatchable is that much of a
concern our grid operator ISU New
England has gotten
extremely Adept at forecasting behind
the meter solar that's actually the data
that was used by synapse to do their
analysis for our report and so they've
gotten quite good based on the weather
forecast based on the factors that they
takeen to account to forecast day ahead
behind the meter generation for that
distrib for those disted resources and
so um they don't you know they are good
at taking that into account to be able
to manage our grid
effectively thank you okay
representative pel you might as well ask
your question now uh thank you very much
Mr chairman uh yes this is a question
that's gerain to this bill and uh M Mino
um this bill specifically looks like it
basically basically takes a number that
we want to the legislature to pass to
set the uh the the net metering rate and
from what I understand the Pu is in the
process of reassessing that rate could
you tell me what parameters the Pu will
be looking at or is looking at to set
this rate
uh generally that's a question what are
they looking at sure so um my written
testimony mentioned the bill that was
passed in 2016 that started the docket
de1
16576 and there were specific parameters
that the general court directed the
Public Utilities Commission to take into
consideration while reviewing and
setting the net metering tariff and
credit rate so um in my testimony I
mentioned that that included making sure
there was no unjust and unreasonable
cost shifting what the rate impact to
all rate payer are it also looks at what
the fair value and credit should be to
those uh to those distributed generators
there's a whole list of and so that's
what set the credit that went into
effect in
2017 as part of the order in 2017
however it was found that there was also
um missing information to be able to
continue to review the net metering
credit and so that's what Miss CR
mentioned that there was a series of
pilots and studies that were required by
the commission that included a
locational value of distributed energy
resources study that was um completed
this fall I believe and there's been a
request proposal out for the value of
distributed energy resources which will
look at a whole series of potential
value included including avoided
transmission cost avoided distribution
system Investments the value of the
energy itself the value of the avoided
capacity all of those things that are
are part of the study um however that
study hasn't started yet and so we're
still waiting for that study to get
going and get completed the results of
that study are uh intended to inform the
next iteration of net metering tariff
and credit rate so depending on what the
outcome of the study is they might say
the value is actually really close to
what we already have as a credit we can
leave it as is or it might start a new
proceeding to say we need to review our
net metering again taking into account
the results of this study that was just
completed followup
question follow up so uh the the the
rate that is being described in this
bill do you think that comes close to
being a fair price for net metered
electricity not at all the house bill
225 wants to reset the net meering
credit according to the monthly average
location ational marginal price which is
the average wholesale price in the iso
New England Market which as I mentioned
recently has been well recently it's
gone up a little bit because it's been
cold but towards the end of 2020 it was
in the two to three cents per kilowatt
hours which is not at all close to what
we think the fair value of exported
distributed generation
is thank you very
much okay thank much uh representative
McGee since the next hearing is on the
same subject as this one could you hold
your question till
then well if Miss Mano is there to
answer it then that because that's who
I'm it's related to what she just said
it was a question relative to what she
just
covered I'm not testifying on the next
bill if that is
helpful go ahead and ask your question
then thank you Mr chair for indulging me
and thank you Miss manow for your time
um my question was around you mentioned
there were pilots and studies and you
said that one of the things that was
being considered as a parameter was
locational value and it strikes me that
that's another thing that's been a
concern among our committee so I wonder
if you could say something about how
locational value is considered because
what I think of when I hear that
parameter is I think that we're looking
at places where distributed energy
coming onto the grid would be of higher
value than other locations because it
would it would be useful there and there
may be places where it's not as
appropriate so could you just see
something about that because I think
it's a new subject for a lot of us yeah
that's correct the idea of looking at
the locational value is that if we can
concentrate the deployment of
distributed energy resources in certain
area and use those aggregated
resources as an energy asset that can be
used in some ways as what generally is
called a non-wire alternative or a
non-wire solution it can avoid a
significant utility investment in their
distribution system that will be much
more affordable so we um we advocated in
the last net metering docket but we're
not successful that there should be
locational adders so we could have a
basic net metering credit but if the
utilities are willing to work with us to
show um where in their system
distributed energy resources that are
concentrated and aggregated and
dispatched for example have um more
value and would allow them to avoid
having to make a traditional investment
in poles and wires or upgraded
substations or things like that then
that is a much more costeffective
alternative for the rate payers and
will'll save them money and so it's
worth compensating those resources to
focus the deployment in that area to
provide that value to the rate payers
but we don't have a mechanism to do that
right now and so without having that
information available or that Financial
incentives the distributed generation
just goes wherever it happens to go
because that's where a resident or a
business wants to install it and so it
could be more beneficial and realize
that added value if there was that
mechanism in place and that information
sharing from the
utilities okay thank you very much u m
Malo M Mano being our final speaker on
this bill I'm going to close CL the
public hearing on HB 225 and report that
28 people signed in to support it and
167 people signed in to oppose it uh and
the I'll remind everybody that the prime
sponsor requested it so now we will open
the uh public hearing on House Bill
148 and I will call on the prime sponsor
of this bill representative uh Mich
O'Brien Senor an elected official from
nas to speak and introduce the bill
representative O'Brien you have five
minutes thank you Mr chairman and vice
chair and the underwhelm clerk of the
committee and to my fellow colleagues of
science technology and energy uh I'm
proud to introduce this bill I represent
nashille at District 36 uh that's
nashille w nine in the city and I'm also
Vice uh president on the board of
Alderman and was a firefighter for
nationville for 35 years however what
this bill does will increase the
electric generating capacity of
Municipal hydroelectric facilities who
may participate in net metering to five
megawatts now uh I want to basically say
as you know of Nash and N has two rivers
uh the mighty marac and we also have our
Nam sake River the nashille River on the
nashille river we do own two dams uh we
are good custodians of this these dams
we have spent a lot of Municipal money
on them uh such as we've replaced and
upgraded the turbine system so that
they're totally useful but this is not
like I'm not asking for a shovel ready
project these dams already exist Nash
being in his custodial duties also tries
to meet and we do work hard with the
feds and making sure that all standards
are up to grade by regulations of the
dams and from what I hear we have very
happy fish in the Nashville
River
uh we uh basically want this up to net
metering is because nashille has the
needs just to that you know that we do
have a lot of municipal buildings that
this could help us uh defray the cost to
our taxpayer is we have nine elementary
schools three junior high schools two
high schools one police station six fire
stations City Hall a library and a host
of other Municipal facilities now this
building was uh excuse me this bill was
heard last year and perhaps maybe a uh
uh the good gentleman representative
hington might remember it uh it did go
get passed by the committee
unfortunately uh through uh legislative
uh Magic it morph into something else
and I would like to make a request Mr
chairman that this bill basically stands
alone because I think it's a good enough
bill it uh it doesn't affect many in the
State uh because not many communities
have the blessing uh that we have in
Nash to have two already built dams in
the city that can that are capable
already and are now uh giving us
electrical power uh but this bill will
allow the city to become a partner with
eversource and supplying power to the
city and uh it would also help us in the
increase you know like I say having two
dams I mentioned the repair of the
turbines that is not cheap and uh this
would help us to uh def Fray the cost
and uh to keep uh our city in capability
well doing well uh as far as I'll be
open for questions I know it's Friday
afternoon so I know you good people want
to get home but uh I do have technical
experts hopefully with me uh from the
city we have Deb CH Chisum uh Doria
Brown and of course our esteem here uh
James dones uh but Mr chairman that
concludes my opening of Mox and I'm open
for
questions thank you representative
O'Brien we appreciate you bringing this
bill to us uh this year by the way you
did that in 3 minutes and 30 5 Seconds
that was excellent It's a gift sir it's
a
gift you have that gift okay
representative mner is recognized for
yes a year ago we obviously had a bunch
of metering bills that
um that the leadership at the time of
our committee decided to war them all
into uh 1218 and this was one of the
bills that I think we all had consensus
for the city of nashwa but um the
committee at the time felt that that all
should go into that one big bill so uh
what is your question my question is um
this was the bill was one of the bills
that was more felt that was question I
was asking I believe this was one of the
bills that was lumped into that
larger yeah okay yeah and Mr chairman if
I may say thank you for the question
this is why I make the request of this
committee uh please let this bill stand
alone and judge it a according to the
wishes of this committee I think it's
got good strong legs and can stand up on
its own thank
you uh thank you I have a question for
you myself could you refresh our memory
as to how much the total U combined
Capac capacity is for those two
hydroelectric facilities in nashille uh
we have uh I have with me uh Deb Chisum
that will be able to get into the more
technical expects but these are already
existing dams uh they are old and so
therefore they're Limited in their
capacity to re-engineer them to get into
if you're fearful of them ever becoming
a Powerhouse and becoming like
competitive to ever Source I doubt that
will ever happen because uh like I say
these are old existing structures when
we replaced the turbine it was a special
order turbine that had to meet the diam
and everything of the existing uh you
know uh Dam and everything so uh I think
they could supplied the numbers I think
it's 3 1% so a total of 4% but as you
know any type of dam we're at the will
of the weather such as if we have a good
spring or anything and it's not uh
anything in nature that would be too
competitive because as you know if you
don't get the rainstorms in the summer
uh drought situations uh you don't get
the
flow okay thank you we'll save those
types of questions for more technical
folks uh that are lined up to speak but
we do have additional questions for you
representative yes cat McGee is
recognized for a question thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
O'Brien for taking my question um my
question is whether you would consider
an amendment to remove language on line
seven that says up to and including five
megawatts because I think and
including uh is problematic where furk
Cuts you off at 5 megawatts so most of
our bills that include below five
megawatts they specify that and they
don't try to include five because then
you go over into FK
jurisdiction so when we were raising the
net metering cap to 5 megawatts we were
doing it up to 5 megawatts and not
including so I think that that um may be
something technically that needs to be
amended in the bill in order for it to
go through uh to achieve the the
objective that you have um uh thank you
for your question representative McGee
uh no I wouldn't necessarily be against
it uh what usually traditionally happens
as you know as our history uh when I
hand over a bill becomes the Committees
and the committee is to do the uh the
leg work on the bill and if you were to
change it to uh 10 I would be satisfied
with that but if there's any uh you know
if 10 was going to be the thing that was
got to hang up on this particular bill
then I recommend it's a good enough Bill
and uh we decided five but I'll take to
10 if you want to give it to me thank
you yeah I yeah that wasn't my point but
you're so adorable it's fine God bless
you thank you thank
you okay thank you
representative representative Jackie
Kelly pittz is recognized for a question
don't forget to unmute I'm unmuted I
will uh Echo Cat's last
statement but I I want to ask two things
one I didn't understand what you said
what do you mean by
partnership with eversource are they
going to pay for some of the
construction upkeep and maintenance of
these facilities no didn't understand
that yeah no not at all I mean uh coming
probably that was more speaking from my
fire department background as you know
traditional in the fire service we work
as a partner with osaurus when there are
power situations that are down and
everything and make sure that the public
is safe uh but basically this is not
really to become like a business partner
uh basically we are going to be uh
because of the limits of five megawatts
uh that's not enough to run completely
all our facilities so we'll still have
the demand from urce so we should not be
uh considered I probably use the wrong
phraseology but we're definitely not to
be a
competitor thank you and may I follow up
Mr the the other um question I had was
always in the back of my mind from when
I first got here was specific
legislation for
specific places or people or things do
we do you know of any other hydro plants
who are up to the five megawatts other
than the two rivers which
are in your town and any other plants or
any other facilities that go that high
is there anything on the marry MAAC or
well thank you representative for that
question and this is why it's basically
like a nashille bill and I hate to use
that term it's not that we in Nash have
broad shoulders we think of others in
the state as well uh but however uh not
many communities have it and I think uh
my technical expert uh Deb Chism could
probably verify that fact uh and this is
why this bill comes in with just nashal
REM mind uh because uh they're not many
people that have an operating Dam that
exists right now in this state Nasha is
very fortunate and very unique by having
to and by you allowing us to increase
this net metering uh on it uh will H
assist us and our tax Bay is to take
full advantage of a blessing that we
have from our provider thank you
thank you thank you uh chair recognizes
representative ssuch for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative O'Brien um as
someone who went to visit with a number
of members of this committee last year
the one of the hydroelectric facilities
in the state um I I want wanted to ask
you if you could say something about the
the contribution that the uh Dam
operators make to cleaning up our Rivers
which is something people don't know
much
about uh that is very true and I think
I'm gonna leave that to uh uh Deb Chisum
and to Doria Brown uh but mostly that
probably come under de uh Chism there's
a lot to running a dam and such as you
bring up I says in Nal we have Happy
Fish to my belief uh but when you have
Dam you gotta make sure that you're not
affecting any of the species uh you
don't want any type of debris getting in
that's going to destroy your turbine so
it's a uh nashille has a very good
stewardship and if I may say so the may
may want to jump on this as well we have
land cleared a lot of uh overgrowth and
everything that has been on our River if
you haven't been down in Nash lately
please come down uh we have cleaned that
out we are building uh walk ways around
the area we're going to show off our
namesake River nashar and we uh we
firmly believe and it's adopted by the
majority of citizens of Nash to be good
stewards to a a blessing of a natural
resource that we have in the Nash
River thank you okay thank you seeing no
other questions for representative
O'Brian well thank you representative
for introducing your bill and I thank
the committee sir thank you very welcome
thank you for being here I'll call on
our next speaker who is once again the
mayor of nsha The Honorable uh James
Dess Mr Mayor you have the floor for
three minutes oh well thank you again Mr
chair uh the as you've already heard and
I want to thank uh representative
O'Brien for sponsoring this bill as
you've heard we have two hydroelectric
dams in which we have generate we have
invested a lot of money millions of
dollars the in answer to one of the
questions the one one of them called the
Jackson Falls Dam is one megawatt
currently net metered the other is the
MF Falls Dam further up
River three megawatts so there would be
certainly no problem in the language
that uh representative McGee suggested
three megawatts yeah um so we we know
that there is a difference of opinion
regarding the desirability of broader
net me metering that currently
exists so and and the main concern of I
think eversource and other utilities is
that if there
were you know broad widespread uh 5
megawatt
commercial sites where where net metered
electricity were generated it could
negatively affect uh in their opinion
electric rates in New
Hampshire so we propose this specific
Bill to cover only municipally
owned facilities so that we
could uh not um cause any the type of
change you know Mass change that a
broader net metering bill would bring
about but would help the taxpayers of
nasro who've invested a lot of money in
this in in these hydroelectric
facilities uh the the um I do not
believe ever and I can't speak for them
but I've talked with them on a number of
subjects I do not think they have a
problem with this bill because it is
specific to Municipal municipally owned
hydro and uh again would would benefit
the the taxpayers of the city of
nashille who've invested so much money
in this uh in these facilities
so I hope that the committee oh and
there was one question I'm sorry about
um specific
legislation uh the idea that legislation
might affect only one Community I
believe it's uh fair to say that that is
legal and appropriate it but it's
usually expressed in terms of
municipally owned in other words it it
expresses it in a general way if some
other community were to get a dam uh it
would apply to them too similar to
legislation that might say cities of
over a 100,000 there might be a specific
rule applying only to Manchester but uh
still legal and proper uh so I don't I
don't think the the fact that this might
only affect municipally owned dams in
Nashville would is an impairment so I
would uh ask the committee to favorably
consider this help us out uh it doesn't
um have broad implications as some net
metering bills do I do support those as
well but I know there's much more
reservations about many more
reservations about those and I think if
you inquire of ever Source I don't think
they have a you know any serious problem
with this with this
bill and that's concludes my testimony
Mr chair thank you Mr Mayor we
appreciate you being here the chair
recognizes representative Thomas for a
question
thank you Mr chair for taking my
question thanks for my question mayor uh
I think you almost answered it but just
to be clear uh this are there any other
municipalities in the state that would
be affected by this bill at all so how
many I'm just curious I you know I do
not think so um I don't think there are
other there are other uh Municipal dams
of more than one megawatt or that would
be affective by this bill um that's my
uh impression but maybe Deb Chisum who
will be on could uh clarify that she's
our she she replaced Madam mateline Mano
as the waterways manager Deb Chisum did
uh but I think the answer is no but I
would want to qualify that by saying
let's make sure I'm right by asking
Deb thank you thank you um I I would
just note that
Doria Brown has is online and has signed
up to speak but I do not see the name
Deb Chism either being here or signed up
to speak so I just want to make that
well Doria may be able to answer the
question and she is the energy manager
that uh we have okay thank you she
testifying in a little while uh
representative Jackie C pittz is
recognized for a question I will wait I
believe for the I'll wait for the energy
manager I can't get my hand down all
right thank you okay seeing no more
questions for The Honorable mayor James
dest we thank you for being here Mr
Mayor now we'll turn thank you you're
very welcome we'll turn next to our
third speaker on this bill and that is
The Honorable Clifton Belo from the city
of Lebanon Mr Belo you have two minutes
the floor is
yours whoops wait a minute I think maybe
I have
to allow you to
talk okay now you
have thank you Mr chairman on behalf of
the city of Lebanon I do support U this
legislation
um I would um concur with the thought
that it the phrase up to an including 5
megawatt should proba should be
preferably changed to not uh um less
than 5 megawatts so would say for
municipal Hydro electric generation
facility less than 5 megaw it just
happens to be that exactly at five
megawatts it becomes a f jurisdictional
generator and um should not qualify for
net metering so it's that simple um and
I just referred to my uh testimony on
House Bill 106 uh from this morning
thank
you okay thank you any questions for The
Honorable Mr
Belo seeing none will call on our next
speaker who is Joseph kwasnik member of
the public representing himself Mr
kwasnik you have the floor for two
minutes thank you Mr chairman uh I am
submitting a oral testimony today in
support of House Bill 148 and I'll keep
it short um adding this provision to RSA
361 will permit a municipal owned
hydroelectric facil Nashville to fully
participate in the oil in the net
metering program within New Hampshire
and enable the citizen of Nashville to
fully participate in that metering via
their existing hydroelectric generating
plan uh this bill will go a long way
towards reducing energy cost for
Nashville citizens and should pass and
that ter that uh is the end of my
testimony thank you
sir okay thank you 30 seconds that's
probably the briefest testim testimony
we've had all year working at it okay
are there any questions from Mr
fasik see none we will turn to our next
speaker who is Heidi croll a lobbyist
representing the granite state
power uh
folks
and where are you here I know you're
here there you are okay Miss Crow the
floor is yours you're allowed to speak
for two minutes thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee um good
afternoon uh for the record Heidi coll I
work at Gallagher cahin and gartell and
I'm speaking today on behalf of the
Granite State hydr Power Association um
we appreciate the opportunity to testify
on House Bill 148 um GSA supports the
goal of House Bill 148 um however we
would respectfully suggest that if this
committee passes House Bill 106 which
you heard this morning relative to
establishing procedures for municipal
host customer generators um which gsha
supports as a step forward um then House
Bill 148 which would not be uh necessary
um so as you've heard a houseold 148
would allow municipally owned
hydroelectric facilities up to um and
right now written five including five
megawatts to be eligible to participate
in net metering um as you know currently
the size limit on renewable facilities
that are eligible to net meter is one
megawatt um to the best of Granite State
uh hydropower association's knowledge
there is only one municipally owned uh
hydroelectric facility um that kind of
fits in this category and as you've
heard this is um Mine Falls in nasua and
therefore um really only one facility
would meet the eligibility criteria in
House Bill 148 um MF Falls is a member
of the Granite State hydr Power
Association and we fully support
allowing this facility to net meter
however um gsha believes that all of the
state's small renewable facilities um uh
above one megawatt and Below 5 megawatt
should be allowed to provide um locally
produced power to Hampshire consumers
through net metering or group net
metering arrangements so it is for these
reasons that we um would respectfully
request that this committee uh pass
actually house bille 106 um so that all
political subdivisions including the
city of nasua will have the opportunity
to net meter with local renewable
facilities above one megawatt um and
thank you for your time and I'd be happy
to answer any
questions nicely done one minute and 50
seconds uh the chair recognized
representative partial for a
question yes I am just trying to get my
mind wrapped around this please help me
oh thank you chair um I'm also looking
at uh house bill
number uh hold on here
148 and also looking at Bill 407 uh
introduced at uh by representative mate
and I'm looking at Bill 407 is seeing
a a language has been written to that
bill makes it less problematic to get it
actually passed that's my understanding
of it can you please correct me if I am
wrong on this
one um I think that uh House Bill 407
kind of comes at
um comes at Power sales a little bit
differently and I think um both uh
opportunities under the Lepa act as well
as opportunities under net metering
um certainly do give um consumers uh you
know a lot of choices um and you know
both paths I think would be um uh
appropriate uh and would certainly
increase um competitive options um but
uh my reference was to um House Bill 106
uh which was representative Lang's Bill
earlier this morning um which really
talked about uh Municipal host customer
generators so which would be uh
representative langsville um would be
open to any interested um political
subdivision um versus houseo 148 uh as a
practical matter limited um simply to
the city of
nsha thank you so
much thank you uh the chair recognizes
representative ssuch for a
question unmute yeah yeah thank you Mr
chair
um I just wanted to know whether um if
um Miss crl if uh if a 106 were to pass
would that provide um other uh Hydro
potential Hydro generators from getting
into the business of generating more
electricity are there potential people
out there waiting for this opportunity
that you know of
thank you for the question um so
certainly there are um a number of
existing small scale Hydro facilities in
New Hampshire that are between the size
of one megawatt and up to five megawatts
that are very interested in serving um
local municipalities um schools uh
County complexes Etc um and it in fact a
lot of um those cons customers have
approached um their local uh
hydrogenerators uh asking if they could
um create a you know an arrangement to
purchase the power and um currently
there's really not that option so
certainly there's a lot of interest um
and in addition uh well I don't have
firsthand knowledge of it I I believe
that there's probably one or two
projects uh small Hydro projects out
there between one megawatt and 5
megawatts that um are sitting idle um
but potentially if there's you know kind
of of a new market made available to
them then you might see um an owner
invest to kind of um
repower a small Hydro facility so um I
hope that answers your question but I'm
happy to elaborate if it didn't thank
you very
much the chair recognizes representative
Cali pittz for a
question thank you Heidi um could you
please we I hear the change the term
terms interchangeably used here Supply
Power at net metering my understanding
of net metering is net metering is for
the purpose
of selling back to the grid but
basically for the purpose of
calculating the price or the the revenue
that's going back
to the
um the generator if for some reason net
metering didn't exist the generator
could still sell power to the
uh to the to electric company or whoever
is interested in buying is that
correct so right now for um thank you
for the question representative so right
now for the small Hydro facilities that
are above one megawatt or or really any
facility not just Hydro that's above one
megawatt the option really the only
option that's available for them is um
you know selling into the wholesale
market right um You I think there's you
know there's net metering and then
there's group net metering so net
metering is you know I kind of think
about it is the residential um consumer
have maybe has solar on their roof and
if they're producing Excess power then
they're um exporting that to the grid
and getting compensated for for that
excess that they're putting onto the
Grid in the case of group net metering
and you heard Miss vau um I think
testified to this uh in one of your
earlier bills in the context of group
net metering there's a generator um that
creates a group with willing customers
that that want to essentially use that
um that power and so it's kind of it's
virtual net metering if you will where
the pu's rules require that the power
being generated by the generator in this
case let's say a small Hydro facility
that the consumers in that group that
their demand for power has to meet or
exceed right the expected output of the
generator so in the case specifically
with smallscale Hydro uh I can give you
an example there's um a hydro a small
Hydro facility in the town of bosin um
the town of bosin is very interested in
entering a a group net metering
arrangement with that facility where the
town
uh facilities could um uh could use that
power that's being generated locally and
so that's the example where um an
example of where Hydro facilities could
be group net metering and and Mr Hayden
also testified earlier today um this is
already happening um for hydro
facilities that are one megawatt or less
um he's created a a product essentially
where he's um uh M doing you know
matchmaking essentially with with small
Hydro facilities under one megawatt and
matching them up with um schools and
municipalities who are interested in
group net metering with those
facilities may I follow up yes follow up
well my followup is basically do you
need net metering to sell power so I
have a generating facility could I
approach whether in high let's say a
hydro facility facility could I approach
the electric company myself and and go
with a power purchase agreement without
net
metering if you were
a uh individual it was in a if it were
in a wholesale Arrangement um yes that's
an option but if it's in a retail
Arrangement it is not an option and I
think um as we've talked about you know
I think there's there's Val differ the
there's value being lost by generating
power locally and then shipping it out
into the wholesale market and at the
same time purchasing power out in the
market and importing it um we're kind of
paying double on the transmission side
um as is one one place where we're we're
not taking advantage of the locally
produced power thank
you thank you I have a question for you
miss croll you mentioned a few minutes
ago a group net Beering situation in
which a host was generating power and
selling it to a group of folks that had
agreed to become part of the
group what would the host sell that
power to the group members
four so that would be negotiated between
the group
members um and the
generator um obviously they're going
to uh those group members are going to
look at this as a
competitive alternative um and so
they're going to look at what they could
buy power from a a third party supplier
they'll look at what the default service
rate is for their utility and then they
would look at this uh option as well um
and so I can tell you that basically how
it works currently with the the hydro
facilities under one Mega wat um
those uh utilities or or generators are
putting um their power into the grid um
they're getting uh a credit equal to the
default service rate from the local
utility at the same time kind of on the
other end of the wire if you will is a
group of customers taking that power off
the grid um and let's say you know if
the default service rate is8 cents and
the hydro generator has agreed to sell
the power for 6 and half cents um then
the hydr power generator is cutting a
check every month to the group members
for a penny and a half namely the
difference between the default service
price the credit they're getting and the
agreed upon sale
price so it is an important thing to
note um that in group net meeting
Arrangements um even though we talk
about the credit being the default
service price in fact
generators um
are in the end you know they don't get
they don't keep that they they give some
of that back to the group members so
that kind of the group members are
buying down their cost of default
service power
um that answer your question thank you
for that explanation so no further
questions for Miss croll I'll call on
the final speaker for this bill and that
is Doria Brown who is representing the
city of Nashua Miss Brown you have the
floor for two minutes hello I'm Doria
Brown and I'm here in support of HB 148
I did want to quickly lay out the how
much we make from our Hydro facilities
for our Jackson Mills and Mine Falls Dam
so that you get a better idea of that
difference so Jackson produces about
11,22 megawatt hours per year and from
generation we make a profit of $400,000
per year while mindes Falls we generate
2,681 megawatt hours per year and we're
making a profit from that generation of
$440,000 so we're making more than twice
as much electricity from our mind ball
Stam but not making nearly as much off
of that energy generation and now jhua
stands to really gain more value for the
energy that we are producing from MF
Falls if we're able to increase that net
metering cap for our hydroelectric
facilities and I also wanted to address
I know that question wasn't for me but
that net that group net metering
question if we were to group N meter
with a with our residents or our um or
our facilities we would have to make
sure that we
generate the right amount of energy
every single month and we would actually
end up if we don't generate enough
electricity in the business of
purchasing excess electricity for energy
that we have to make up and that is not
a business we really want to enter
into so it might become more costly to
group net meter if essentially the water
isn't flowing that month I I just wanted
to make a point of
that okay is that the extent of your
testimony yes I I'd like to take
questions now okay fine thank you so uh
representative ssuch is recognized for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you Mr Brown for for taking my
question fact I have two questions
really and I asked before uh previously
and um they told me you'd be the better
person to answer this but could you tell
me a little bit about the environmental
benefit that you you do your your
National operators at the dam provide as
far as the river uh quality of the river
and and environment is concerned and my
second question is have you considered
any type of energy storage on these
dams so I am here filling in for Deb
chis home because she had a meeting at
this time but she thankfully was able to
give me some of the down low on what's
going on with these dams when it comes
to cleaning water or cleaning the water
around it so yes the dams are
responsible for cleaning a lot of the
debris around them as water flows to the
river and they are a big benefit to the
Nashville River because they do that I
also do not think that we've explored
adding storage to these dams as it would
be extremely expensive maybe in the
future if we were able to net meter
these facilities we would have more
money to be able to invest more in
storage okay thank
you okay thank you um representative
Cali pittson is recognized for a
question I'm sorry to put you on the
spot Miss Brown um you you pointed out
that you make about $840,000 a year
between the two dams my thought is if
the if you Pro if this meing went up
you'd make about 1.2 million what is the
do you know what the operating cost of
those two dams
are I do not know off the top of my head
what the operating costs of the two dams
are but I can get that information back
to you when I meet with our waterways
manager you man follow yes not knowing
much about dams except the ones I've
visited and enjoyed looking at are
is there much maintenance involved in
upkeep of these dams I know there's you
know the the the turbines but other than
that is there quite a bit of maintenance
on these do you know so you do I can
wait for that you do have maintenance
with keeping these dams running I I do
want to point out that we recently had a
turbine issue with one of our dams that
is going to be very cost for us to fix
so when those those issues do come up
they kind of overshadow the the smaller
cost or the smaller annual cost of
having one of these
dams so they they are expensive to
upkeep okay thank you for that uh thank
you I have a question uh are fish
ladders a
concern uh in this
situation
I I don't see Fish ladders as a concern
in the net metering situation but we do
have a fish ladder on the Mine Falls Dam
if you want to come see it you're more
than welcome to I'm sure our waterways
manager can give you a
tour okay
good any further questions for Ms
Brown see none I will thank m brown for
being here today and uh we'll close the
public hearing on House Bill 148 by
indicating that 146 people signed in to
support this bill and one person signed
in to oppose
it and with that it being 224 we will
take a six minute break before we start
our next public hearing thank
[Music]
you
gakie I don't think you're muted no I'm
not why do I have to be am I gonna say
have but you might want to be I don't
know I I thought I was gonna run and
make a gourmet meal in six minutes
that's all so we're on another bio break
right I had a phone call so that's why I
was offline yes we we just we just
paused for six
minutes um I was I was listening I had
one ear in one place and one in The
Other Place listening to the court casee
and I thought that was it just
seeing real lawyers in
operation and the judge I admire her um
it was really an interesting process
just
listening I I can't I can't do that two
things at the same time I I I admire
that I was trained by the phone company
you had to be an octopus to work
there when he when he when he
not good hey Lee how you doing these
days feeling
better a little thank you that very
kind I'm glad to hear
it okay uh cat's not on right now
I I got my bills confused was it really
that obvious it must have
been just that's okay we all get
confused and if you noticed nobody said
anything so that means everybody else
was confused I'm feeling like such a
rookie sometimes here though you know
out out of class so no don't ever be
quiet let your thoughts flow and and you
know well I figure it's a way to learn I
guess so and that's the way that's why
you were
elected I ask case you can find anybody
else for the job personally
but
so what's it looking like for the uh I
mean are you getting any read from the
uh judge or anything I hav't I've not
been watching I no I it I think I
haven't gotten up I and I don't hear
anything so I think either they're in a
break or the arguments are concluded it
sounded like they were
concluding and they asked to file briefs
by midnight I mean guess I don't
know I I don't want to show up if I mean
it just seems like you know I mean
there's nobody's talking about a show of
solidarity with the people who are uh
with our handicapped people well let me
tell you I have a heart condition I have
severe o osteoarthritis you don't know
it except sometimes when I go to get up
in a session and I can't stand up that's
the benefit of being
home um and a lot of other things going
on so I think that add Plus I'm an old
lady and I'm
overweight so that makes me vulnerable
and the last time when we met
outside there were a few Representatives
walking up and down my shoulder who
didn't have masks on it made me very
nervous they weren't certainly weren't
six feet apart and if you look at our
committee which I would say that head
table isn't six feet apart without masks
so I
just I feel my duty to go I haven't
missed a session except in March when I
was in the hospital but I
do I'm taor
because you know I want to live to see
next
year why this got my second shot this
morning so and how was it are you okay
yeah but you know it's you don't have
any reaction so far not wood not a thing
so great I'm I'm supposed to get mine
Tuesday and I'm at 9:00 so I'm going to
be late to
session
um but I was afraid of a reaction So you
you're okay good I'm glad yeah I was
nervous what does it take Tuesday isn't
session Jackie huh no but I'm afraid of
I'm afraid of Wednesday oh gotcha I'm
sorry Jackie there's no uh vaccine out
there that's going to be tougher than
you are don't worry about it well no
self-respecting German with nii exactly
I wasn't putting it that way but I'm
just saying you're you're a tough lady
yeah but having a drive that
far
um it it does you know take me back a
little bit but I am afraid of it I am
and it's not just driving there but you
know it's the whole day and then you
have to drive back and maybe it's dark
and maybe it's just you know there's
just a lot of things well if it's dark I
can just get up and leave I mean you
know
I I left early from the last session and
I pulled up to the back gate at peas
because that was the only place I could
get to listen to the last little bit on
radio and you know they sent security
out up
after and just what do you think you're
doing here well exactly what are you
sitting at the back gate for the
Neighbors reported me I said I'm
listening to the radio and I when I you
know I roll the window down put my mask
on I said here what are you listening to
what kind of music is
that God bless security from the base
but yeah I mean uh because I didn't want
to drive home in the dark I'm getting
old I realize
that well look at the option there's
only one
so I I still I don't have that because I
don't have death there's living and
there's dying I don't have death
insurance so that's not an option I
think what he's saying is that I know
he's okay with the op so I have a teabag
here I just want to tell you what it
says let your energy be used to build
not
destroy all right that fortune cookie
personalized
teabags personalized
teabags that's how to get the message
out teabag
while we've got a second there was a lot
of discussion uh I don't know last month
or whatever on nuclear power and where
we're going with it um would anyone been
interested there's a there's a Ser
series of stuff that's come out with the
with the government the federal
government's been funding various
Advanced uh nuclear reactor Concepts if
the committee's interested in that I
could distribute it to them I'd love to
see it
Mike unless unless you happen to be
subscriber to nuclear news you probably
haven't seen it yet but I get nuclear
news okay there youle husband gets it I
assume right yeah but he show he Flags
everything for me yeah it's amazingly
interesting reading you know yeah in the
Texas context that even the nuclear
plant had failure because of the cold
yeah actually the the plant is uh back
going it's going back up right now it
had a u a sensing line to the feedwater
pumps froze and then the feed water pump
shut down and once they shut down the
Plant trips and the problem down there
is that there's so more designed for
dissipating heat so all of their it's
nothing like seab Brook I know a lot of
the committee has been to seab Brook
everything's indoors everything's
Outdoors down there because they want to
dissipate as much heat as they can and
this feed water sensing line for the
pump froze H because I I think the
temperature got down actually below zero
down there it's yes it did wrecked
wrecked cold I think they also
deregulated so they didn't have any
oversight saying what they should be
doing in terms of resiliency that's
that's part of the problem too well the
whole thing of Texas is it's remember as
you probably aware it's its own uh own
gr there's no firk regulation on it and
it doesn't have a capacity Market but
the nuclear plants are still regulated
by the uh nuclear Regulatory Commission
it was just one of these things that no
one expected it and they put out this
big warning uh about a week ago and they
it was even colder than they thought so
I mean everything started to freeze
natural gas froze wind froze obviously
if you got ice you're not getting solar
and then the nuclear plant tripped off
because of this uh sensing line freezing
so about everything bad that could
happen to about every source of energy
happened almost simultaneously there was
no particular one you can say this is
the fault of other than it was it hit
everything so as our chair tried to tell
us this morning there was an immediate
oh it's because of all that renewable
energy which it was
not get
de% fossil fuel we could have Mike was
the plant ever in danger could they shut
did they shut it down or oh it was a
safe shut down it was automatic when the
feed water pumps go there's suff
insufficient flow to the steam
generators the plant shuts down it was
it was no no safety issue whatsoever so
the core didn't get no no there was no
no problem whatsoever with that I just
I heard that and I thought no tsunami
your um nuclear uh for the entire
committee your readings you're
suggesting I'm sorry I I'm sorry I
didn't quite hear what the question
was I'll ask you later okay
thanks chair V we can't hear you yeah
Michael you're muted
uh how about can we get Fred he's in the
room the room is muted the gotta go turn
on the room
okay we sort of just heard you for a
second okay can you hear me
now all right fascinating discussion and
we'll take it up later we have some time
but we're late for starting
the the
public hearing on the last bill of the
day which is HB
167 I have a copy of right
here the prime sponsor of this bill is
representative MC Williams so I'm going
to turn the floor over to representative
MC Williams for five minutes to
introduce this
Bill thank you chair Vose um for the
record my name is Rebecca McWilliams I
am a representative from conquer's wests
side marac
27 um House Bill
167 is a necessary bill for the State of
New Hampshire and the State of the Union
right now uh climate change is real it's
happening right now New Hampshire has
experienced two extreme droughts
decimating our agricultural businesses
over the past 5 years California's Fire
season is lasting longer and
intensifying the number of Acres burned
every year 2016 was the hottest year
ever recorded on earth and now an Arctic
freeze has settled Over Texas this week
and killed 47 Americans so far due to
widespread power outages this is a
failure of the
system we the members of the science
technology and energy committee are the
smart folks who are working to do
whatever we can to fix some of these
issues it's our job to understand what's
going on what went wrong in the energy
sectors and to address them for the
ongoing climate disasters New Hampshire
is part of iso New England one big
bathtub of energy shared across all of
the New England states we are still
subject to disasters the potential for a
major grid problem could happen to us
from storms tornadoes hurricanes fires
floods and freezing
temperatures we the members of House St
have the power to switch the source and
mobilize our local businesses to
increase local homegrown power sources
and create local jobs ISO New England
has stated that infrastructure
constraints could pose a challenge to
the reliable operation of the regional
power grid which would create price
increases and volatility contribute to
increased air emissions all of which
would adversely impact New Hampshire's
citizens businesses and economy it's in
the best interest of all citizens of New
Hampshire that the size limit on
customer generators that may participate
in net energy metering and serve as
retail load reducers should be increased
from one megawatt up to but not
including 5 megawatts to increase
customer Supply Choice Foster a more
robust retail market for local renewable
energy and help mitigate the cost of
electric service in the state this will
reduce the price volatility of electric
service and reduce the potential for
disruptions in Electric Supply due to
inadequate wholesale generating capacity
in the New England
Marketplace so here we are the Pu
expects
uh that there are 25 existing projects
in New Hampshire with name plate
capacity values between 1 and 5
megawatts that could be eligible to net
meter under this bill once they no
longer have a capacity commitment with
ISO New England or are no longer a
registered
generator retiring from the wholesale
markets takes a couple of years um but
the expectation is that these generators
would stick around and participate as
well as creating the development of new
projects especially at Municipal sites
so our current utility scale solar
installations in New Hampshire our
Fidelity Fidelity Investments in meramac
which has approximately 3 megawatts and
the New Hampshire Electric Cooperative
solar farm in molten Boro at 2 megawatts
so most of these existing facilities
that the pu's references referencing for
25 facilities um are Hydro facilities in
New Hampshire where we value our freedom
home brewed electricity from our own
customer generators is the right
prescription for our Energy Future
I'm open to take
questions thank you representative MC
Williams three minutes and 33 seconds
nicely done I have a question for you on
page three of the bill lines two through
11 is this the exact same language we
heard this morning in house bille
106 um let me pull up lines 2 through
seven on page P three so I'm looking at
the same thing as
you it appears to be but I don't have
the bill from this morning open um it
does look similar from a cursory
glance okay my followup question uh is
this bill um identical or extremely
similar to uh House Bill 1218 from last
year this is similar
to
1218 do you know how it
differs um so we've changed some
dates uh for
implementation
and I don't know if there was a new
analysis or not performed at the end um
it's hard for me to tell um I'd have to
compare the analysis portion but the
dates have been changed in the
bill okay thank you very much
representative CL is recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman for the
existing
25 facilities to qualify what is the
benefit to uh rate payers of New
Hampshire it just raises their rates
doesn't it same same electricity already
being
produced so we're talking about creating
local H grown energy that will be
consistent and reliable even when
something in ISO New England impacts the
larger grid such as a great freeze for
example like what just happened in
Texas um what we're talking about is
perhaps an additional cost for that
reliability but on the average I would
say that it's worthwhile to have our own
local producers um able to contribute at
that level so what we're talking about
is incentivizing homegrown
energy
okay thank you um next up for questions
I don't see anybody else put their hand
up so thank you representative MC MCM
Williams we will now call on our next
speaker who is Clifton Belo The
Honorable Clifton Belo uh representing
the city of Lebanon Mr Belo you have the
floor for three
minutes whoops I guess I have to promote
you
go Mr Belo may have left the
building so we will move on and turn the
floor over to Mr Joseph quas Mr Quik you
have the floor for two
minutes uh thank you Mr chairman and I
promise this will be the last time
you'll hear from me
today um I'm testifying in support of
House Bill
one67 uh- FN and this bill um positively
improves the U amount of uh increases in
the the size of the generators that can
actually be net Meed eventually getting
back up to almost five megawatts on and
after January 1 2002 it also specifies
the um the um the amount of net miring
that can be provided by a particular
Source in that only at least 50% of the
actual uh generation must be consumed
behind the meter so I think that's an
improvement on previous bills I do think
that um this bill needs to pass as it is
expected to encourage the building of
more and larger New Hampshire renewable
energy projects such projects will
reduce electric load obligations for the
electricity suppliers in New Hampshire
reduce electric transmission costs keep
our energy dollars within New Hampshire
reduce red the carbon and pollution
signature of electricity consumed in New
Hampshire it make crystal clear that
debt metering compensation for larger
customer generators will be set at the
applicable default Energy Service rate
of its utility supplier in addition as
I've said before these valued assets to
the grid will continue to increase in
support a reliable and more resilient
electrical G grid into the future uh and
that uh is the end of my comments I will
take CEST
questions
thank you one minute 22 seconds any
questions uh representative sset you
recognized for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr pnik for taking my my question uh
just because previously we had a
question about uh how would this impact
rate payers in New Hampshire um could
you say something about the issue of
volatility in the fuel cost markets
because when we look in the future rapay
is going to be affective by the cost of
fuel and we know that in the winter time
especially in the past we've seen large
variations in the fuel prices how does
uh this kind of energy the renewable
energy sources you're talking about how
does that impact long-term our fuel cost
well as as everyone realizes um if we're
talking about renewable energy
specifically solar or wind uh those
resources are essentially free you don't
have to pay for uh BTUs of either coal
or gas or oil so the fuel cost is
essentially um zero so that's not volle
depending on the season uh and we do
know that as New England depends um uh
has lost I think all except one C
burning power plants depending more and
more on um natural gas supplies for uh
much of its energy coming and for New
Hampshire coming from out of the state
and we know looking at what's happening
in in uh in Texas is that uh gas prices
can can be very volatile in the winter
and also there are issues about gas
supply U especially when uh generators
such as in in Texas uh did not have firm
contracts for their gas and they found
that their gas actually went up to the
firm customers uh in the area of home
heatings and things of that sort and I
know that in New England some of the gas
generators uh some of their some of
their gas supply is certainly firm
contracts and a lot of it is also
non-firm contracts so there's some
volatility there and also supply issues
that need to be uh reflected uh in the
planning for capacity within New England
during those
Seasons thank
you thank you representative pintel as
recognize for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you uh Mr
quas there's a saying
don't put all your eggs in one basket
could you explain to me how this uh use
of net
metering uh how that increases the
number of baskets and how that will
actually improve our overall
infrastructure yeah I think we also have
to recognize that net metering currently
as it's understood in New Hampshire is
load reduction it's not considered uh
Supply but it does
uh as we've learned in the past it does
reduce the demand on the system um it
also uh reduces the amount of energy
needs to be imported from out of state
so that is all good for consumers in New
Hampshire but also um in general uh
having a diversified energy resource
base is good for uh for consumers in the
state whether it's a combination of
nuclear and we're lucky to have one in
the state a combination of um of gas
plants uh I think there's a few here and
and certainly out of state uh some of
the large wind turbines are providing
base load within New Hampshire and um as
we learned today there are two utility
scale uh uh solar plants one uh and the
one I'm familiar was the 2 megawatt unit
that's owned and operated by New
Hampshire um uh Electric Co-op those are
actually feeding into the system they're
not n metered they're actually um
sending it basically supplying into the
system for instance in that case for the
the electric co-ops uh uh load
obligations to its
members you need a followup
representative okay thank you uh I have
a question for you Mr frik you just
we're talking about um load
reduction
if if a load reduction source is
intermittent how can it be counted on uh
to be genuine load reduction
who who figures out what part of the
load has been reduced and
when well I think I'd like to go back to
the comment that um Miss Mano uh talked
about today is that ISO New England has
very sophisticated forecasting of uh
formulas and they have a very great
understanding of how the weather uh in
solar insulation demand and other
factors can be actually calculated and
and uh predicted in terms of what uh
these load reduction sources will
actually provide in the day ahead market
so uh although it seems like they're uh
they're here or or not here they
actually in aggregate uh provide uh some
necessary resources that are counted on
by ISO New
England so are ISO New England's
forecasting facilities better than the
TV weatherman who only gets it right
maybe 50 or 60% of the time um I'm I'm
not an econometrist uh in in in
predicting that but I understand that
they have a pretty darn good track
record okay representative Stitch is
recognized for a question uh thank you
Mr uh chairman if I may just add a
comment as information to uh the issue
of the load reduction and
predictability um it's interesting to
note that in Europe Spain for example
that generates a lot of solar energy has
a very sophisticated predictive program
where it allows it to export its energy
into markets in France because they're
interconnected and there of course
France doesn't have as much sun as Spain
does but this is a a really important
aspect because right now we can see what
happens with Texas their grid is not not
connected to anyone else so they can't
be getting help from other other
networks when they need it
so no I'm sorry just a comment thank you
oh okay thank
you uh thank you Mr Quik for your
testimony thank you see no other
questions from Mr plaznik I will turn to
our next
speaker who
is Mark Brown who represents Consumer
Energy
Alliance uh Mr Brown the floor is yours
for three
minutes thank you can you hear me we can
thank you all right dear chairman Vose
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Mark Brown I'm the
executive director of New England for
Consumer Energy Alliance or cea CA is a
nationwide Association made up of both
energy consumers and producers working
to advance in all of the above energy
environmental policies that will lower
energy costs for every American CA
supports actions that thoughtfully
Advance our nation towards a cleaner
more environmentally responsible Energy
Future we believe that responsible
policies always consider the needs of
consumers while leveraging and
supporting the development of
state-of-the-art Technologies to improve
our environmental stewardship aiding in
the continued reductions of all
Emissions on behalf of CA I want to
thank you for the opportunity to provide
this testimony today on
hb67 DEA supports New Hampshire amilies
and businesses making investments in
generation that will allow them to
produce their own power and even sell
that excess generation back to the grid
there's no legislative or regulatory
hurdle prohibiting this from happening
now the issue is at what price should
they be paid for the exported
electricity the retail default energy
rate which represents the fully bundled
energy rate including firm energy
capacity risk premiums and is currently
roughly 6.5 cents per kilowatt hour but
that varies depending on the solicit
ation period or the avoided cost rate
authorized under the public utilities
regulatory Policy Act and set by the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
which was approximately three cents in
2020 is often argued that New Hampshire
should support expanded retail net
metering programs in order to reduce the
state share of the regional network
service AKA transmission charges what we
have not seen is empirical evidence
showing that the increased cost of
adopting retail net metering programs
like paying twice the market rate for
generation increased risk premiums to
default service customers outweigh any
purported benefits of decreased
transmission cost there is however ample
evidence of the regressive nature of
retail net metering policies in other
states such as those proposed in
hb67 Massachusetts dpu has repeatedly
recognized the regressive impact that
net metering and other on-site
generation policies have had on
low-income customers stating low-income
customers have experienced an increase
in its bills as a result of the growth
of on site generation and has
implemented a 32% discount rate to
account for Saka the envelope math
concludes that the low-income discount
rate of Massachusetts is around h100
million per year former MIT energy
initiative researcher Scott Berger's
study of Economics of rooftop solar
looked at a data set of consumption and
cost from comed's service territory in
Chicago modeling out solar adoption and
take into account the different income
trends of
adoption and he concluded that among
other things PV adopters reduce their
contributions to residential so excuse
me residential cost recovery placing a
higher share of the burden of
residential cost recovery on
non-adopters given the lineon share of
PV adopters are wealthy the net effect
is that average expenditures for
affluent customers decrease at the
expense of low-income customers 30
seconds okay U Stanford economics
professor Frank wolak found that the
vast majority of Almost 100% increase in
average residential distribution Network
prices between 2003 and 27 for
California's investor own utilities can
be explained by increases in the
installation of distributed PB capacity
uh anybody that knows what's going on in
Maine is seeing a lot of problems in
Maine with interconnecting the solar
there from the advancement of their
programs um has called for an
investigation at the Pu so there's uh
inmation I think the best thing to do is
to uh you know let the Pu conclude its
study before we start expanding that
meter and cost
thank
you thank you for your testimony the
chair recognizes representative
Harrington for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I I I just want
to make sure what I heard I think the
most important part of what you just
stated is that there's a vast difference
between what makes up default service
and what makes up the avoided cost for
the utility is that correct yeah the
default Services it's air firm product
okay you know so when you what you pay
for your default Energy Service rate is
fully bundled it's firm energy capacity
ancillary Services you know the
administrative cost RPS you know all of
that bundled in the avoided cost is for
energy which is what is provided by
distributed generation it's it's
intermittent it's not dispatchable right
nobody knows when it's you know coming
from a home so
thank
you you need a followup representative
Harrington no I'm all set thank you okay
great uh any additional questions for um
represent
for Mr
Brown seeing
none uh that will
conclude Our Testimony un l unless Mr
Belo has
[Music]
returned and I see no evidence that he
has no one uh has their hand up so it
appears that we have concluded testimony
on
hb67 FN so we'll close the public
hearing and uh I thank you all for being
here there were 100 41 people who signed
up support to support this bill and two
people who signed up to oppose it and
two people who signed in as being
neutral so with that uh closure of that
public hearing we can
now resume some exact session
activity I would like to open the exec
session on HB
373 and uh recognize representative n
for a
motion I oh are you sure you want me to
do a motion order point of order Mr
chairman point of order Mr
chairman yes representative McGee what's
your question thank you chairman um you
had mentioned earlier that there was an
amendment and it was distributed I
believe but we haven't even discussed
the amendment so are you
moving to a vote without even discussing
what's been added to the
bill yes my understanding of the prop
proper procedure is that you uh make a
motion to ought to pass then you ask if
there are any
further um motions to consider and if
someone has an amendment then they will
move to uh pass the amendment then on
once that's done then you move to ought
to pass as amended that's my
recollection of how the process works
does anybody have a different
M
no okay so representative uh call fist
did you have a comment about that you've
been around longer than uh most of
us and I mean that in a good way and
don't
I I just I want just wanted to ask a
favor of the shair when you read when
you you say that a bill is going to be
exact did you just read the title
or of the bill yes I apologize for
that's all thank
you although it might take me a minute
to find it Jackie could you answer the
question that the chair gave
you sorry what was the question about
the
amendment the amendment
yes once we once we
establish that we uh that the exec
session is open this is relative to
State participation in low carbon fuel
standards
programs the name of the the bill once
we establish that
we are in executive mode on this then
I'll ask if there are any additional
motions so representative ner do you
have a motion yes I'm Mo ought to pass
okay with Amendment representative
bernardy and will second that motion
okay so we have a motion to ought to
pass on HB 373 are there any additional
motions that are appropriate
representative Thomas yes thank you uh
chair um and we discussed this
previously U briefly we have car and I
have here um a
Amendment
[Music]
representative on a Case by case basis I
believe this would give the governor or
the representative which in this case
could be the department Department of
energy uh the latitude that if they hear
of a particular subject coming up on
this item that they want to have eyes
and ears there to at least listen that
they can on a meeting by meeting basis
approve uh someone from Dees to go down
there and to listen I think this gives
latitude to the governor to to provide
this type of service that's all this
this amendment is meant to do and they
would have to be specifically requested
by this person to go down for for that
particular meeting um to go down there
and listen any other meetings would come
up the same direct that have asked again
so do you move the adoption of this
amendment and I move that we adopt this
amendment I have a question
representative
Harrington to recognize to second the
motion I second the motion okay thank
you uh for discussion representative ner
thank you does it say who the designated
representative will be or how it will be
decided no it
doesn't would be my assumption that if
not directly from the governor that it
might come from his new uh office of
energy but since we don't know who that
is or how it's going to be formed yet
this Le kind of General be his the
governor's
design representative representative
Cali pitz you have a question for
discussion yes I do I I first first I
had a point of order a representative n
introduced the bills is she was she
permitted to ask
questions the amendment on an amendment
yes I think she but she the motion on
the floor was to pass the bill so I I'm
gonna just question that I don't usually
question the chair I'm going to question
that she might be right I'm sorry I
right representative Kelly I might be
the other question I had was to uh
representative Thomas do you think that
this particular amendment is
micromanaging the
dees and and not allowing them to follow
the expertise that we have invested them
or think they
have well I believe that in this
particular case um in trying to
improve the orinal bill in itself and
also the fact that we now are getting a
new Department of energy um there there
there may be situations
where we would want the department of
energy or Governor to um decide if we're
going to spend State money I'm going to
witness listen in our programs that
worker stated that we're not going to
actually do but we may want someone
there and I think I think a decision
like that should be left
up of stuff coming at me may I follow
up yes follow up
okay you just you just mentioned the
department of energy Board of
Governors I I guess I've never heard of
a department that had to go to a Board
of Governors to do anything and maybe
that's just my fault because my ears
haven't been open and who is the Board
of Governors I I I believe that's a
result of me not enunciating completely
and clearly I what I was saying was that
it could be up to the uh Department of
energy who whoever that might be or the
governor's Representatives okay we just
don't know who that is and and I believe
that uh in a situation like this I think
it's up to the governor or his designate
his designate to decide when to spend
State money on programs that we know
we're not supporting but we may want to
send someone down there to hallucinate
on a Case by case
basis I know I'm limited to go
ahead thank you representative what is
the amendment number please the
amendment number is 2021
d455 thank you yes representative oxims
recognized for a question or a
statement thank you very much for
allowing me to go beyond a question I
finding great difficulty with this bill
and the amendment does not help at all
the concept that we would not want our
staff members whether it's Dees or the
new Department of energy to have the
fullest possible communication with the
people who share the grid with us who
share the the interests of our residents
of our citizens of our
businesses it it it just defies any
imagine can can you give me any reason
why you would want to impose a gag order
isolate our staff from the staff of
other states other individuals
businesses Cooperative organizations
that could help us to do things in the
best possible most coste effective
way representative
Thomas question well that was a question
it may have been rhetorical it seems to
me that the
amendment uh takes away a gag order
doesn't impose
one representative pel you recognized
for a question excuse me am I not going
to get an answer that the amendment only
says you can do it in when we on a
caseby casee basis it doesn't stop the
the general
rule I will glad to restate my reason
again which is on a program such as uh
such as this where the state where the
governor has said we will not
participate in it I believe that it is
up to the governor or the designated or
he does me to decide when to send people
to a program that we are have already
said that we are not going to support
but we might want someone here to listen
in on what's going on and that should be
on a Case by case basis I personally
believe that on programs that we are
participating in then it's to the
department heads to decide they want to
go to help out the states in those in in
that program
so I just so this bill is about the
transportation climate
initiative uh point of order Mr
chairman representative ssuch what's
your point of order well I would like to
have some clarification about exactly
what we're doing here uh so I uh
representative Thomas introduces an
amendment uh are we treating him like a
witness so we ask questions or do do we
discuss the content of this bill as such
and merits of it pro and con uh you've
had different rules for different
procedures so I'd like to know what what
procedure are we in right
now we're discussing the adoption of
amendment 202-
0558 so so we are we not limited to
questions we can make comments and our
and and and uh voice our opinions about
the amendment is that correct is correct
okay thank you very
much okay representative pintel is
recognized to
speak uh so it it's very difficult for
me to understand what the rationale
for not
allowing uh people in
Dees to be able to listen to be able to
learn I'm not talking part participating
they don't not have to be participating
but to listen and
learn why are we gagging that ability to
listen and learn to report it just makes
no sense to me at all and if you don't
call it a i you can't call it anything
other than a gag order it's just that
plain and
simple
okay next
recognizes representative crean for a
comment unmute button uh thank you
chairman um I really want to Echo the
thoughts of uh my my colleague saying I
I feel like this is a very specific bill
um really micromanaging the the de um
I'm a little bit concerned that we are
giving this level of specificity to the
governor um
to yeah to control um where the dees uh
May participate in discussions or not it
just seems um like this is something
that really should just be best left to
to Dees um not something that the
governor needs to get
into thank you representative the chair
recognizes representative man for a
comment yes thank you Mr chairman
um the air Resources Division of
um of U Dees has long been interested in
air quality and I I cannot see this bill
having any
purpose uh and I perfectly happy to be
corrected any purpose other than uh to
prevent uh opposing opinions from
getting in the way of
U policies that are interested
in that might be uh you know let's put
it this way I don't understand why we
would not allow and not even require the
Public Utilities
Commission excuse me the uh Dees air
Resources Division to sit on sit in on
any discussion they want to or they feel
is appropriate for that relates to air
quality because that is the mission of
the air Resources
Division and it
um certainly makes me scratch my head as
to why this is going on thank
you thank you the chair recognizes
representative McGee for a
comment thank you chairman um I I I'd
like to take us back to testimony when
we were listening to 373 since we're
discussing it now in exec and um we
heard testimony from Greg Moore of
Americans for Prosperity that the
transportation climate initiative was
the
precipitating uh Regional issue that was
ongoing that had spurred this bill and
yet the governor had already given
instructions to the Department of
energy uh and their you know air air
quality division as to the level of
partic ipation that was required so the
executive is already in charge of this
department and if there is an energy
Department there will be an additional
layer of authority over environmental
services that is basically under the
executive so I really think that this
bill doesn't do anything because as as I
said the governor had made the decision
that we're not part of TCI and he also
instructed Dees on the level of
participation that they were allowed to
do so this bill is unnecessary and so I
think the ought to pass motion that's on
the
table uh I don't understand what you
what it expect what it expects to
accomplish which I think other people
have asked already but I would offer the
further position that I think it should
just be ited it doesn't really do
anything the governor is already
involved in these decisions and he
already has oversight and he already has
input
so it's kind nonstarter
representative I I'm allowed to speak
because uh I just talked I asked Paul
and I can participate it's only in
public hearings where I can't oh okay
okay so clarification okay sorry to
interrup representative mner is
recognized yes um going back to
testimony that day that Mike fitgerald
um did go to the last hearing on this
last year it was de's decision to the
governor recommendation in an meu that
we not participate TCI so uh the the
dees is the one that made the decision
for us not to participate in this right
now that that was their recommendation
to the governor and but the proposal to
put a cap on carbon emissions from
gasoline vehicles which would force gas
Distributors to pay allowances to sell
gas above the that cap revenues from
those allowances will then be sent back
to participating States in which the gas
was
purchased but this bill isn't on TCI
this is just on whether or not Dees can
talk to people it doesn't to do with
whether we participate in
PCI and then his and and and to the
amendment they can still go listen so
that's you know we can still listen and
they can they can stand it and you back
to the governor say maybe they want it
that's the whole real the purpose of the
bill I think my my point is that it
doesn't really do anything it doesn't
affect
anything that's the it doesn't have any
effect that's why I don't think we need
it say don't waste
tax an earlier version of this bill
actually struck the language in the RSA
that allowed the appropriation of funds
this version of the bill doesn't seem to
do that so uh representative Bernardi is
recognized for a comment thank you uh Mr
chairman and uh thank you for letting me
comment on this speak loudly I I believe
this bill does
exactly uh addresses TCI it it is it is
part of a legislative initiative to say
we are not going to participate we are
essentially validating the governor's
and the de's opinion that is
inappropriate for us to participate in
TCI now or when a governor changes that
wants to wants to participate in some
such craziness as uh creating a
regressive gas tax system so this bill
then Pro prohibits us from doing that
unless on a caseby casee basis it's
authorized for some
discussion okay uh representative mck
Williams you still have no raise hand
capability I'm wondering maybe if Jen 4
can look into this because I still don't
have the ability to do raise hand on
Zoom but thank you for calling on me
chair Vose um I I want to bring up a
rather important piece to this
um when we look at separation of powers
right we've got the legislative the
judicial and the executive Dees is part
of the executive branch so it it's
really up to the governor as the
executive to decide who he wants to
staff and how he wants to manage his
executive branch and therefore Dees when
you bring in another branch in this case
the legislative to write a bill that
says the governor can micromanage his
Dees staffers of the air quality
division we are in effect act acting as
an accomplice to write a really bad Bill
you know this is a sort of legislation
that you look back at and say why on
Earth would we have the legislator
saying the governor can micromanage Dees
the governor and Dees need to go get
together in a room and decide who's
doing what who's in charge and if that
means firing people do it this is just
silly for the legislature to get
involved okay thank you for that comment
representative MC Williams uh
representative Harrington is recognized
for a
comment yeah I just want to say I
discussed this with uh Chris Elms the uh
Governor's legislative uh guy this
morning and he said they had no problem
with the the bill uh especially as
amended the dees has already decided on
their own valtion to get out of the
transportation initiative and that they
wouldn't be attending it further but I
think the amendment gives a little more
flexibility uh so that we uh different
departments could get back involved in
it and it's just you know it's a simple
matter of not spending money on
something we're not going to
endorse thank you representative n um I
have thank you um Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the
question representative Harrington um
did you discuss with Chris Elms the
bill without the amendment are they okay
with it without the amendment
uh basically he said they could live
with it either way but they probably
preferred it with the
amendment all right thank
you uh next up is representative
oxenham just a comment I I just hope
it's a very slow news day because I just
think New Hampshire is going to be
ridiculed from one end of the country to
the other for such an absurd piece of
legislation
thank you
representative representative pel has
recognized for a
comment don't forget to
unmute thank you Mr chairman there's
been some good points and I and you know
the whole idea that that uh we're uh
we're gaining flexibility by this bill
this is this bill removes flexibility it
is it is once again it's a gag order it
uh it hobbles the uh what our Dees can
do and in a way it hobbles the governor
to be able to because he has to act on
every specific request not you know why
not just give him the authority to give
a blanket okay or
not that's the governor's
prerogative this is not a good
bill we are not going to be happy with
it you're not going to be happy with it
when you find out what happens thank
you okay thank you I'm hearing the same
comments over and over and over so U I
think I'm GNA in discussion on this
amendment now and ask the clerk to call
the role on the amend Mr chairman I I
don't think you can do that I think
people have something to say you have no
idea whether they're going to repeat
themselves I know I'm not going to so
I'd like to speak please
I was distracted um representative stit
you were saying that you're certain that
someone has a new comment to make well
Mr chairman I I can understand you
asking people only to make new comments
and that is understandable but to assume
that everyone's going to just repeat
what has been said is a wild assum asson
on your part I think so I know from my
point of view I'm I'm not going to say
the same things so I'd like to say
something different so that's why I
raised my hand okay well I thank you for
that comment I would caution you that I
did not say that I assume everyone's
going to say the same thing what I said
was I'm hearing the same things over and
over and that gave me pause to wonder if
we need to continue this discussion if I
keep hearing the same ISS issues
discussed over and over the same points
being brought up I don't see any
legitimate reason to go on now if
somebody does have a new point to make
I'm willing to listen
so if you do have a new point to make I
will call on you if you do not please
put your hand
down all right I recognize
representative partial for a brand new
point
thank you uh chairman folks this not so
much of uh comment is a uh maybe a
speculative question but I am looking
the language uh representative Thomas
maybe you can clarify this says unless
specifically directed by the governor or
designated representative on a case-by
Case basis now I think you've made the
case that the department of energy can
come is a designate their representative
to come and listen in but I'm wondering
what's going to prevent the department
of of uh environmental services from
doing the same thing and perhaps I'm new
and ignorant here but I'm just wondering
if you could enlighten me on this
area thank you so that's a question for
representative Thomas uh I think that
you're I I assume representative tras
you feel qualified best qualified answer
it as you drafted the uh Amendment so
yes I'll allow that representative
Thomas if I understand the question
correctly
this
amendment I'm not sure I can sit any way
differently this amendment would
allow the department head perhaps to say
U we believe that uh we have good cause
to go and listen to a meeting on a
program that you said that we would not
be participating in in a program that we
said we didn't think we should be
participating in but we think that it
would be a good idea to to listen
uh may we attend and spend State money
to do so and this would allow the
governor to say to listen to their point
and say either no I don't think we'll
spend money through that meeting or he
could say or the designated could say
yes we think this is a good one to go
and listen to I don't think I can make
it any plainer as to what the intent of
this bill
does I I really don't have any more
answers to answer same question question
stated in different terms so apologize
for that that's that's what that's a
very simple Amendment that's what it
gives that gratitude nothing else no
apology necessary and I'm not weighing
on the bill itself I feel like I'm
really not qualified to understand its
full history but I'm this looking at the
language here and I'm this wondering if
it could be re worded to make it a
little stronger about who the designated
Representatives would be that's all and
I want to thank you for the time you sp
on
it thank you uh representative mner is
Rec recognized for a question oh I was a
fake hand wave it was okay uh
representative crean is recognized for a
new point that we haven't heard before
yeah um just a question really following
up on that last
one representative paral brought up the
point what is preventing Dees from
interpreting themselves as a design of
the
governor is that what you were asking
representative partiel I don't
okay because I'm also confused on this
point would you like representative
Thomas to
respond please if he
could representative
Thomas could you restate that
restated sure sorry um so what prevents
Dees from deciding that they are
designes of the governor and making
their own decisions and thus
making this entire Amendment
move well my opinion and time spent in
government
service both in the military and in
actual d d SL service you one normally
does not assume that they are the design
for or their higher level boss unless
they get either something in writing or
it's understood in their Charter that
they are the design need for that
particular item so I don't believe there
could be any misinterpretation unless
somebody wanted
to um
either on purpose or mistakenly
supersede that particular director so I
I believe that that unless they were
given
specific direction that they word does
that they would not be assuming that
point in this particular
here thank you representative man do you
have a new point to make I think it's
new but maybe it isn't I think if the
governor wants to exclude Dees from
understanding or or giving opinions
about um air pollution and so on that he
should do it on his own and um take
responsibility for it I don't think we
as a
legislature should be providing him
cover by forcing the issue with a with a
bit of legislation I don't see any
reason for this legislation that makes
any sense thank you okay thank you
representative samit you have a new
point
tonight uh yes I do Mr chairman so a
couple of new points in fact so number
one this bill is not about any kind of
Transportation initiative
it could be in the future but it's not
about that that's not what we're
discussing here we're discussing
something very different number two I
think this bill Fosters a a strong
partisanship that we should not be
encouraging if the if the next Governor
is a Democratic governor and then he's
allowed to designate what the dees does
and doesn't do I don't think some people
on this committee would be too happy
about that and and because that Dees is
not just a resource for the governor he
they're also a resource for us when we
go to them with a question and ask how
can you help us with a certain issue we
get pretty good and pretty an unbiased
information which is very valuable to us
as legislators and finally uh I would
not be surprised if we go down this path
that the next thing will happen is we're
going to tell Dees that they're not
allowed to participate in anything
it La science okay thank you very
much thank you representative
representative Thomas has recognized for
the
comment Mr chair I
just point of order com did he look at
the but I uh I I I have not heard
anything different the last 10 minutes
really I would like suggest that we call
the vote I don't think
so I have something to say
representative C pittz you're the last
speaker on this and and I wish
representative Thomas would speak into
the microphone I um I never got the
amendment because the amendment was sent
to the legislative address which I don't
have all legisl is the legislative
address STNA so I never got the
amendment I have a
personal uh email and that's where
things are sent so I don't know who sent
it out but I didn't get it so I want to
ask representative Thomas if he in that
Amendment does he remove the word
discuss sorry represent could you speak
into the mic please so I can hear you
better do you do you remove the word
discuss participate and discuss again
again because I never saw the amendment
I I I will read again and I don't have a
mic right here so I will speak
louder thank you the entire the entire
sentence of part Roman two would State
under the amendment it would State the
Department of Environmental Services
shall not participate in discussions or
planning of such programs unless
specifically directed by the governor or
design representative on a Case by case
basis thank you and my my I I don't get
passionate about much I don't have much
passion left in me but anybody who says
do not
discuss that means internally or with
somebody else that to me is a slippery
slope and something this legislature
should not get
into there is a freedom of speech
whether you bought likes it or not I can
turn around and discuss whatever I
want as long as it doesn't impinge with
the business as long as I'm not charging
him or on the clock so that means in the
cafeteria or at lunch or whatever they
can't discuss any program how do we know
representative Thomas whether something
is going on if we don't discuss it now
you want to put a cap on money spent you
want to say if you're going to spend
over you know $0000 you have to get
permission to do it I would be okay with
that if it's valid you could get it but
right now most things are this way it
doesn't cost me a quarter to sit here so
I'm just
wondering why anybody would come up with
the idea to muzzle
speech and and I I did say dag order
because I think that is a very slippery
thing what if I decide that Finance
can't discuss school vouchers what if I
decide you know this is opening a can of
worms and I think that can should be
shut thank
you thank you uh
representative well there's a face we
haven't seen all day Representative
Vincent is recognized for a comment good
thank you very much Mr chairman just
something short um I think we should put
this uh put this in the garbage where it
belongs I really do thank
you
yes I'm sorry Representative Vincent I
was distracted uh could you repeat your
comment I would love to first of all I
want to thank you very much but I really
think that this this belongs right in
the garage can it's not going to do any
justice for anybody but thank you and
it's good talking to you
good to hear good to hear from you
too thanks okay looks like we've
exhausted ourselves here so I'm going to
call the question and ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
adoption of the amendment 202
1-55 Mr clerk yes uh Vice chair
Thomas
yes oh representative Harrington
yes representative ner yes
representative mner yes representative
PL says yes representative beresi yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative kimrose yes
representative PL yes representative
white yes representative sage no
representative Cali pittz no
representative
man representative man
no Representative oxenham no
Representative
Vincent let me think about this no
representer
McGee no representer
McWilliams absolutely not represented
crean I'm sorry I mispronounced your
name several times earlier I'll
eventually get it
right it's okay it varies from day to
day this is on the amendment not the
okay
vote ma'am just clarifying this is on
the amendment not the correct bill right
um
yes Representative
pimel
no representative
parel
yes the chair yes chairman votes chair
votes
yes
yes eight no no
extensions okay so the amendment is
adopted representative n did you have a
question no I wanted to make a motion
not to pass as
amended yes okay I'll give you that
opportunity in just a minute
yes the clerk has read the vote and it
is 13 in favor eight
opposed so the amendment is adopted and
now I recognize representative ner for a
motion I move a to pass as
amended representative
uh Berard I will is recognized will
second that motion okay it's been moved
and seconded that
we pass HB 373 as amended
otpa any further
discussion representative
pintel uh thank you uh chairman Vos I I
feel very strongly that uh this is
something that we really need to to uh
itl um this is not a good bill uh it
really hamstrings the governor it really
hamstrings our
departments uh this uh is going to come
back and bite
somebody um and I think the just thing
to do is to do as uh representative V
Vincent said is to can
it thank you very
much thank you uh representative
[Music]
oxam thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my comment um I I really do think
that we should not be proceeding with
this the the fact that it singles out
the Department of Environmental Services
in this way does a real disservice to
some fine public servants who have done
extraordinary work on behalf of the
residents and citizens of New Hampshire
and I I really I I just yes I agree can
it thank you representative Cali
pittz I've been brought to tears
twice January over government January 6
and today and just the statement from
Francis Bon I may not agree with what
you have to say but I will fight to the
death for your right to say it
and nobody should interfere with that
right of the people voice I do not
believe that if our Dees is doing a
crummy job get rid of them but we have a
right to know what's going on New
Hampshire is not in a
bubble okay I would just say that I
would just remind everybody that this
bill doesn't muzzle the department of
environment services from talking about
things in general it's it applies
specifically to low carbon fuel
standards programs there can't be many
of those and it doesn't really muzzle
them even regard to
that so I think maybe some of these
arguments that I've heard are a little
overflowing uh seeing no more hands up
for further discussion I'm going to call
the question and ask the clerk ask the
clerk to
call the rooll on the question of
otpa on HP 373 Mr clerk if you'll give
me just one second I'm coming up from
somebody unplugging my computer and uh
getting getting that roll call
back okay who unplugged your computer uh
I don't know for
sure okay well I'm sorry to hear that
happen sounds a little scary Fred we got
ghost uh
[Music]
let's just say I don't want to blame the
party who might have done it
okay and now we know who did
it representative paral did you have a
question yeah so while we're waiting for
the come up could I uh trouble you to
get the uh um blue sheet count on this I
know it's pre- Amendment but J 4 can you
get the uh blue sheet for HB
I can give me just a moment and I'm
ready thank
you we'll wait just a second to see if
Jen can find that blue
sheet then we'll call
[Music]
the I will alert you all to be prepared
for an exec session on HB
225 at the conclusion of this exec
session right representative v um I have
28 in support 101 in opposition and one
neutral okay thank you very much all
right so now I will ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of ought
to pass as amended on HB
373 may I ask again who moved 73 I did
representative n moved the question and
representative bernardy second
okay we have a clerk uh now who uses no
paper it's all electronic yeah but
that's great till somebody unplugs a
computer called battery storage not if
you have battery
storage it ran out okay it was ought to
pass the
amendment HB 373
otpa got
it okay uh and pass bill as amended
correct as
amended representative Thomas yes
representative Harrington yes yes
representative ner yes representative
nner yes representative plz votes yes
representative bery yes representative
Bernardi yes representative Kim brills
yes representative clo yes
representative white yes Representative
samich
no representative Kelly pittz no
representative
man Representative no representative Ox
no Representative Vincent no
representative McGee no representative M
Williams no representative kchen
defently not Representative
pel no thank you Representative pasel
no okay the vote is andair and chairman
chair votes yes okay the vote is 11
to1 Mr chairman okay with a vote of 11
to 10 now the motion ought to pass as
amended carries uh representative
Harrington you have a question yeah I
just want to let people know I had an
amendment to HB 213 and it was just sent
to everyone's email address as lo as put
in the state thing so I'm not sure if
that's where people get their mail but
it was sent to all science and energy
and Tech uh people so it's on 2113 and
you should have it in your inbox now
representative Harrington can you give
us a little overview what does it do uh
it what it did was it grandfathered in
all thermal projects uh that were up to
any anything that has received any
wrecks up until uh the beginning of next
year so existing uh projects that were
getting thermal wrecks would still
continue to get them it wouldn't allow
for the bill wouldn't allow for new
thermal new thermal projects to get
useful thermal energy to get green
wrecks but anyone that's presently
getting them would continue to be able
to get
them okay thank you representative
Harrington we're still in the exec
session for HB
373 and would like to ask representative
n for a majority report by next
Wednesday at noon and representative
ssuch will there be a Minority Report uh
yes there will uh uh representative
pimel are you willing to write a
Minority
Report sure yes thank you I thought I
was gonna write it Oh I thought we were
a
team well well uh all right forget it no
you write it I'll write it in the paper
well okay so it's representative pimel
yes I think so
yes okay please have that to me
by noon on Wednesday okay and who was
the blur auor of the majority sorry
representative n okay thank you
representative C pittz I have a question
for you if you don't use legislative
email how do you get uh information
about activity that goes on within the
committee I really
don't she call I get anybody that sends
me anything sends it to my personal
email and that's the way it's been for
about eight
years office Could you um maybe consult
with the IT department and find out if
they could forward your email to your
legislative address to your home address
I I will because because that's the way
I get most of my email all of it I just
don't have a legislative
address I think they can do that
for I will I will check with Paul on
Monday
Paul yes Paul Smith can do that for you
I was just informed by represent I'll
check it up on Monday if I can uh I
don't know if I can be audible but um I
just emailed forwarded that amendment to
Jackie thank you thank you John
apprciate you doing that but like to
find a more permanent solution that yeah
this is just for this I'll have them fix
it I'll have fix it representative
Harington you recognized oh wait a
minute let me close the public hearing I
mean the exec session on HB
373 now I'll recognize representative
Harrington for a
question
representative Harrington did you have a
question he's muted no I I had left my
hand up by mistake I'm sorry I was
stepped out of the room so no questions
no problem representative McGee did you
have a question yes thank you Mr
chairman
um oh good I
just oh I know what it was I had put
together a list actually of contact
information for folks on the committee
for both sides of both caucuses is so uh
would it be okay if I just sent that out
to people I'm not going to send people's
personal contact information if they
don't want it like phone numbers and
whatever if they don't want their
personal phone numbers but you can just
email me and by five o'clock today I'll
send uh the sheet that I have so that
people can get in touch with each other
if they want to Mr chairman can I say
something yes thank you for making that
offer representative n thank you um
representative your name is Skate mgee
uh could you take my Comcast email
address off that list I I like to get
keep it separate and I've been getting
emails in both boxes and I'd rather just
have them all in one place absolutely
that's why I'm asking because I think it
makes sense that we have a contact list
that is what everybody wants to be
contacted at thank you why don't we
haven't opt
out thank you for offering to do that
representative Al pitz what was your
question why don't we have an opt
out opt out opt out rather than opt in
well you just said you wanted your
personal email so I thought you wouldn't
care if people had it no but never
mind don't get it that's Cali Pit's
humor I get
it let's open now the uh exec session on
hb25 and uh representative PL has
recognized for a motion yes Mr chair I
move to itl
225 uh representative Platt has moved to
itl HB 225
representative white is recognized for
uh a motion thank you I'd like to second
that so it has been moved and seconded
that we itl HB 225 is there any
discussion
it appears that there is no discussion
so I will ask the clerk if he is
ready to call the role I shall be in a
second as soon as the clerk is ready he
will call the rooll on the question of
itl on HB
225 have made the motion
himself
having that motion being seconded by
representative
white okay are we ready
uh a second
shall second was representative white
got that I'm just going to the right
form okay and for uh the record for
Jackie C pittz the title of this bill is
relative to the calculation of net
energy metering payments or credits
thank
you okay representative
Thomas yes representative Harrington yes
representative nter yes representative
mner yes representative pletz have votes
yes representative bery yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative camell yes representative
PL yes representative white yes
representative sage no oh sorry I vote
Yes representative C yes representative
man yes representative
henham yes okay Representative Vincent
Yes
McGee yes representative MC Williams yes
representative crin yes representative
pel yes representative Pas yes uh
chairman
V yes vote is 21 to
nothing without objection this will be
sent to the consent
calendar by a vote of 21 to zero motion
of itl on h225 is
adopted and representative flet will
write a brief what majority
report is it concept yeah but it still
has to have to report okay it could be
two lines I mean okay nothing doesn't
have to be anything sign but we don't
like
it
so it is now seven minutes before four
o'clock and we have the room for another
hour and seven minutes and being
opportunistic I think we should continue
to uh conduct exact sessions on a few
more bills I know that um could we have
a break
first we could take a break minut would
you take aak biak but at four o'clock I
would ask everybody to come back and we
will exec HB 308 HB 309 and HB 168 time
fored so thank you and take a break
until four
o'clock thank you Mr chair could we also
could we also ask Jen to get us the
sheets for the other three hearings
today 225 148 and 167 I don't think we
we had call outs on the numbers for four
and against if we could just get them
that' be
great you're asking about today's bills
is that correct correct or the exec
bills no not the exec bills we okay most
of
those yeah
iug I'm just trying to keep up
as
thanks so my computer
died
so I did send out that information on
Advanced reactors and the funding to
every everybody's mailbox so you should
have it as
well
great thank you and Jackie to follow up
on your concern it was a normal reactor
trip down in Texas what happened is the
sensing line to the feedwater pump froze
so the feedwater pump didn't know it was
going on so it shuts itself down which
means less water is going into the steam
generator so the reactor says uh-uh
can't deal with that and they shuts down
the reactor so so it was due to the
freeze and U you know it's just a
different world down there how they do
things up here that wor of while that
pipe would have probably been indoors
and it would have had U electric
resistance heating taped all around it
so it couldn't freeze no matter how cold
it got so but in defense down there it
was 10 below zero in parts of Texas
which would be like it would be like in
Portsmith going to 35
below so and you most places probably in
Portsmouth you'd probably have freezing
pipes and freezing things there um when
the temperature got that low it just it
was just so abnormal that it was
difficult to deal with for
everybody I feel sorry for those people
but we went through what did we go three
weeks without power in some places when
we had the ice
storm
I don't know if you caught me there I
was saying with the the ice storm we we
had that Jackie was speaking of people
lost of 11 days we lost it for seven
here some people lost it for more and um
I think the uh power companies have
responded quite a bit with a lot of kick
in the butts let admit but they've
really gotten much better at responding
to these outages so I would have thought
uh if it was 10 years ago the outage we
had last weekend which was it lasted two
hours probably would have been two days
so yeah the problem at that time was
they didn't have enough stay
aparts well there was all sorts of
problems when I was that was one of the
big ones no inventory when I was at the
commission they were sending people out
in vehicles to write down written
reports at uh outages and then they
would drive around and collect these and
then eventually four or five hours hour
later they'd go back to the uh office
and hand them over to the engineers to
start working on Solutions and I was
shocked because I said me you don't know
what an Apple phone is take a picture
and send it
instantaneously so it's come they've
come a long ways from where they were
years ago a long ways we all learned
from our mistakes
yep
and the snow is supposed to go away here
but it's snowing harder now this is
probably the hottest it's snowed all day
so yeah it's snowing hard here too but
it's not sticking I'm looking at the
driveway clear I don't know probably a
little warmer down there than we're here
about 25 here so
it's pre-treated here I think you know
because they put so much salt on it and
sand from before but this is supposed to
go on all night right well they said two
to four inches in most of the state back
in your yard you're lucky uh Jackie
you're supposed to get up to six because
right by the coast is supposed to get
the most uh snow but don't tell me
because I have to shovel the car out
of bet you just and yell at the snow it
would go away
well yes I do breathe
fire drag it that's what I
assumed no we out my front door right
now it's been snowing all
day a lot of snow yeah that's it that's
the
picture a lot of snow yeah it's been
snowing all day here but we probably
only gotten two or three inches so yeah
we Chie Brown snow it's his big fluffy
things floating down you know it feels
like I should go for a
walk
outside better to listen to the rest of
the meeting from the
outside not
funny a little distance couldn't hide no
it
couldn't
but I've been on both sides of the table
so well we need to look at 308 and 309
and that's the other one okay uh we will
exec HB 308 HB 309 HB 68 time
permitting so I'm going to open the
executive session now on HB
308 and I'm going to recognize
representative murder for a motion oh I
just time one
308 yes I make a motion that we retain
HB
308 and uh I'll recognize representative
bery second it's been moved and seconded
that we retain HB
38 is there any
discussion for Jackie C pittz this is
relative to broadband access to pole
attachments thank you that's really for
everybody really
is it is for everyone representative
Harrington you're recognized for
comment don't forget to unmute
representative
Harrington there you go go sorry about
that that's very rarely that people tell
me to unmute usually it's the other way
around
but they uh this is a really important
issue it's not only the the issue that
presents itself in this case but it goes
beyond that I think anybody who lives in
a rural area represents rural districts
knows that Broadband
uh is is the is the issue I mean that's
what everyone's worried about and there
there are like I there are federal
fundings out there I've talking to to uh
people at the governor's office there's
there's millions of dollars of federal
funds but they haven't quite figured out
what the rules and regulations are going
to how to spend it we want to use this
stuff wisely I mean it's it's become
essential for people in rural areas now
to have Broadband so if we can get the
federal money we want to figure out how
to spend it so we we need to do justice
to this and I certainly hope we retain
the bill and bring in everybody together
on this and get together and come up
with a good
plan thank you representative Harrington
another reason to retain this bill is a
petition was just filed with the
puc by
Consolidated Communications and
eversource they currently own 338,000
polls in the eversource service area
jointly they own those polls
5050 and the petition that was just
filed with the PO seeks to transfer
ownership of those polls from the 50%
ownership of Consolidated Communications
to eversource so that eversource would
be the sole
owner 338,000 polls so that might have
some significant impact on this bill I
think that's another argument for
retaining the bill recognizes
representative pel for a
comment thank you Mr chairman and this
is another bill where uh I am full
agreement with representative Harrington
I think that uh something has to be done
here and right now the bill as written
is basically taking the issue of who's
paying the
bills away from the uh broadband and
giving it to the utilities and that's
just as bad and we need to get the uh
these people in the same room together
and work out something that's a little
fair to
everyone so I will be voting to
retain thank you representative oxam is
recognize for a
comment can you hear
me yes D thank you very much and thank
you for taking my question um yeah I we
we have several bills that deal with
Broadband um 153 is the the broader bill
that SS to set up a
commission but I I just wanted to
highlight the point that we we
continually talk about rural access but
there are underserved communities also
in urban areas in New Hampshire that
also need to uh and their needs need to
be addressed thank
you okay thank you uh is there any
further discussion on the motion to
retain
hp38 seeing that I will ask the clerk to
call the role on the motion to retain
hp38 representative
Thomas yes representative
Harrington representative
Harrington I'm mute representative
Harrington unmute yourself
going on he's getting some
coffee I'll come back to him
representative nter yes representative
mner yes representative plet yes
representative bery yes representative
Bernardi yes representative cell yes
representative po yes representative
white yes representative Sage yes
representative Kelly pittz yes
representative B yes representative
oxenham yes Representative Vincent Yes
representative McGee yes representative
MC Williams yes represent
crean yes represent
pel yes representative Pasha yes the
chairman chairman votes yes and one One
Last Call on representative uh
Harrington yeah excuse me I had a phone
call that I had to take so I I vote Yes
okay it's so face 21 to nothing that's
what they all
say 21 to
nothing the motion to retain HB
308 passes 21 to nothing there will be
no majority or Minority Report required
since we have retained the bill so I
will close the exec session on HB
308 and before we start another exec
session I would like to have a general
discussion about retained bills we have
retained now I'd say at least a half a
dozen maybe eight bills maybe even
uh what it is the committee's preference
going to be with regard to how to deal
with these retained bills we have a
couple of choices one is we can start
working on retain bills in the spring
once we finish our normal legislative
activity up until the around the 1 of
July and the second choice would be to
come back after the 1 of September and
start working on retain bills in the
fall I personally think we should get as
many of them out of the way in the
springtime as possible uh to reduce our
workload in the fall but I'd like to
hear what other people have to
say anybody I would agree with that me
too spring would be good I would agree
with that if we're going to be we're
gonna have be tied up anyways because
it's going to be house sessions so it's
not like uh Jackie's running off to
Venezuela or whever she always goes for
a couple of months on vacation she's
gonna go down with Bruce Cancun so but I
mean yeah let's let's do it while we can
because we're still going to be have to
be around for the budget hearing and
everything else for in in May and June
so the budget vote so I will plan to
start scheduling uh I would like to have
school vacation off in
April if you look at that ditto here
because I've already got plans for that
vacation in April we may not be done
with Senate
bills in in April
so I'm I'm I'm looking at maybe may
miday we could May POS possibly start
some of these retain Bill work sessions
so maybe miday through the end of June
we'll see how that goes yeah Mr chairman
I would think that during that time
frame our normal load would go down but
we're still going to have normal H
regular house sessions that we have to
hang around for that's probably a good
time to plug it in and get as many of
these out of the way as we
can of course the wild card here is
going to be the AV availability of space
to hold well maybe
over maybe will be
over I don't think C is going to be like
a light bulb you know that gets shut on
and off I think it's gonna linger it's
gonna linger but we'll
see all right thank you for that input
now we'll open the exec session on House
Bill
309 Mr chairman I think uh uh
representative parsel had a question
I'm sorry I didn't see that
representative I'll make my comment um
as far as availability of rooms go I
know that there are people I would
prefer to meeting in person I truly
would be but I'm finding this Zoom to be
you know when you make it's it's a I can
see a lot of good coming out of this as
well it would have been my first choice
to being in a zoom conference but I mean
if it it gets our bills out of the way
and I would be more than happy to go
through some of these retained bills
through Zoom conferencing as well that's
all okay I appreciate that comment I
will say in reaction to that comment
that in-person meetings work better I
think for work sessions than Zoom
meetings because people tend to kind of
stomp on each other in a zoom meeting
whereas in a in a in-person meeting I
think that happens less often so I would
I would gravitate toward an in-person
meeting if we can do them but if we took
my boots
off thank you representative
Kelly I have a question then the the
clarification sure so these are going to
be work sessions not more not hearings
we're going to actually uh look at these
bills individually
and on that is correct uh the way you
handle contained bill is you hold work
sessions to decide what to do with it
okay okay great thank you typically a
retained bill would get modified some in
some fashion before you made a decision
one way or the other
excellent okay so now let's open the uh
the exec session on HB
309 which is relative to the computation
of renewable energy credits and I will
call on representative Harrington for a
motion I would uh make a motion ought to
pass on this bill
representative Harrington moves ought to
pass on HP
309 representative
PL uh Mr chair I'll second HB 309
representative PL seconds the motion on
o to pass motion on HB 309 is there
discussion representative
ssuch yes thank you Mr Mr chairman uh I
want to thank uh representative
Harrington for bringing this bill up uh
I think he was very correct in assuming
that the 20% capacity Factor was not a
realistic number uh as one who has
Sellar collectors on my roof I've
measured this a couple years now I'm
only at
13.7% so much less than 20% so I support
this
Bill thank you representative Harrington
you're recognized for com oh Peter thank
you for the for the kind words uh but
it's exactly what you said I mean this
was a kind of a false uh figure it came
up with 20% I think there was some kind
of a legislative compromise back some
time ago but we know that uh it's
depending on exactly where you live I
think you must be pretty much on the
average at 13.7 it's 13.5 to somewhere
New Hampshire close to the 14 but let's
use the iso numbers and let's use actual
MERS that's what we should be dealing
with not not not legislative compromise
numbers okay thank you representative
Harrington any further
discussion seeing none seeing none I
will uh ask the clerk to call the role
on the motion ofp on HB 309 Mr clerk
representative Thomas
yes representative
Harrington represent yeah yes I'm trying
to get my video there it is I'm back up
yes representative n yes representative
erer yes representative PL votes yes
bery representative Bary yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative cambros yes
representative PL yes representative
white yes representative Sage yes
representative Kelly pittz yes
representative
man representative
man yes okay representative
oxenham oxenham thank you yes
Representative
Vincent Yes okay representative McGee
yes representative uh
mcams yes representative critchen
yes representative pel
pel yes representative parel yes chair
chair votes yes 21 to
nothing so
the motion of ought to pass on HB
309 carries with a 21 to nothing vote
representative Harrington will Author
the committee
report and without objection the bill
will go on the consent
calendar is that acceptable to everyone
yeah apparently so
okay so I will close the exec session
now on HB 309 and open an exec session
on HB
168 and I will I will read the uh the
name of the vill it's requiring the
adoption of innovative vehicle emission
standards pursuant to section 177 of the
federal human Air Act and I recognize
representative n for a motion this is HB
what HB
168 Das FN Mr chairman I move
itl representative n moves itl
representative
FL uh second representative FL seconds
the motion of itl on HB
168 do we have any
discussion representative
ssuch U thank you Mr chairman uh well I
think it's very unfortunate that we're
not able to see the big benefits of
becoming part of a nationwide network of
of of uh states that are trying to
encourage low emission vehicles and at
the same time give uh New Hampshire
customers access to these vehicles uh in
in the pursuit of trying to reduce our
our pollution and our fuel consumption
so uh I I won't be voting for itl
because I think this is a good
Bill thank you uh representative
cran thank you Mr chair um I agree I
think that we heard in the testimony for
this bill a number of consumers um
talking about how difficult it was for
them to um be able to test drive of this
new technology and how important that
that was for them um we heard testimony
from uh car or car dealers saying that
uh they want to be able to sell the cars
that that people want um but that is
difficult to do when they they don't
have them in stock um so we're putting
New Hampshire at a disadvantage relative
to our neighboring states and um I would
like to be able to vote for for this to
pass or at least be
retained okay thank you
representative I'm going to uh read
something here that I
uh discovered the other day that I found
absolutely
fascinating a Tesla lithium EV battery
weighs more than 1,000
pounds and it typically contains
contains about 25 pounds of lithium 30
pound of
Cobalt 60 pounds of nickel 110 pounds of
graphite and 90 pounds of
copper in order to
obtain those components of a typical EV
battery you have to M something like
25,000 pounds of brine in order to get
25 pounds of pure
lithium you have to mine about 30,000
pounds of
ore Cobalt Ore in order to get 30 pounds
of
cobalt you have to mine about 6,000
pounds of nickel ore to get 60 pounds of
nickel you have to mine about a th000
pounds per battery of graphite ore to
get 100 lbs of graphite and you have to
mine 25,000 lbs of oil or copper ore in
order to get 90 pounds of
copper so just to produce these five
elements to produce a 1,000 pound EV
battery requires mining about 90,000
pounds of
ore and it takes a lot of fossil fuel to
mine all that or to put together one of
these
batteries according to Cambridge
University of Meritus professor of
Technology Michael Kelly replacing all
of the United Kingdom's 32 million light
duty vehicles with Next Generation EVS
would require huge quantities of
materials more than 50% of the world's
annual production of
copper 200% of its annual Cobalt
production 75% of yearly lithium
carbonate output and nearly 100% of its
entire annual production of Neo dim di
Diamond
Neo
dii three times in a r so the point I'm
trying to make here is that it may be
premature I think
to assume that electric vehicles are
going to um be ubiquitous in the in the
near future
because China just a few days ago
debated whether or not to stop sending
Rare Earth minerals to the United States
80% of the world's Rare Earth Minal
minerals are in
China they want to cut off the United
States because a lot of those minerals
are used in the manufacturer of F35
fighter jets
and guess they're
not
[Music]
bombing yeah so anyway the point I'm
trying to make is uh this may not be the
best way to go and I don't think we
should
be subjecting our state to a dependence
on electric vehicles or even
Courage the adoption of electric
vehicles if uh if they're going to be so
resource
intensive that we may not even be able
to to go down this
road much longer so that's why I would
not be in favor of this particular bill
so next up I would
recognize uh representative MC
Williams thank you chair Bose um I just
wanted to say that um it is an honor to
serve on science technology and energy
with everyone here in this
discussion and that one of the wonderful
things about being elected officials is
that we are able to set policy and we
can decide how to incentivize and
disincentivize the way that things work
on a large scale and isn't that exciting
so in response to your concern regarding
U batteries and the rare earth minerals
and components that make up batteries um
the good news is that uh there's a whole
group of NOS that are currently working
on um requiring transparency in what
goes into each of these manufacturers
batteries and also setting Global policy
on recycling for these manufacturers as
well so here we are in New Hampshire
elected officials able to set policy and
certainly I would say that battery
recycling is something that we have
within our purview if we wanted to set
that as a agenda item for the future uh
but for right now we still haven't even
incentivized EVS in New Hampshire
although the rest of New England has and
so we are certainly Suffering The
Economic Consequences of people from New
Hampshire going to other states to
purchase EVS because we just don't have
them on the lots and there's not a lot
of reason for um a manufacturer right
now to send them uh but there are some
Lots who are owned by dealers who choose
to be a little bit more um open to new
technology and certainly to Greener less
air emissions technology so that being
said um I'm not going to rehash
everything I said in my introduction to
this bill uh but just the future's
watching New Hampshire's watching and
what we do today matters for setting
policy so thank you all for being my
colleagues on setting policy and um I
look forward to continuing to push for
the
future thank you representative MC
Williams next step is representative
parshall yes thank you chair vas uh
that's interesting about transparency uh
interesting comment because I'm thinking
that that's kind of transparency we need
in technology that's not what we're
really getting from such things as the
fracking industry as we well know when
they when they PL it's on a broad scale
we don't know what they're putting in
the pipes so this is kind of exactly the
kind of green energy that I can see not
only being more transparent but also
being a boom industry for uh all these
mining concerns and uh I'd like to see
more industry uh if it helps us all the
better both Ford and GM are moving to
EVS rapidly and I assume that they're
doing that knowing what their resources
are I personally drive a leaf and here's
a personal story behind that um when I
want to pick up my leaf I was uh I asked
the salesperson there well how many do
you have in your lot how many can I
choose from he says well if you want one
we got one for you and that was the
extent of it I either had to take what
they had on the lot or uh continue
driving my gas powered vehicle now I
love my uh Nissan Leaf uh and I it's
it's a wonderful purchase but I would
have liken more choice and I would have
had that kind of choice if we were um in
competition with the rest New England to
bring these uh bring these cars into New
Hampshire thank you for your
time thank you next is representative
pem
Andel just muted myself uh thank you Mr
chairman yeah on basically I'm probably
iterating a little bit here but um these
batteries are extremely recyclable it's
almost uh maybe not 100% recyclable but
pretty close to it so yes we are going
to have to do a lot of mining uh the
other thing is we really need to work at
giving New Hampshire choices to move
towards a low carbon source of uh of
Transportation uh it's not just EVS it's
probably hydrogen powered vehicles as
well that uh we would like to see in the
lots that there's not as many of those
out there but the technology is uh is
starting to come around and uh we
certainly would like to expand choices
without choices it's hard to uh to raise
demand and I think we need to allow the
choices so that we can raise the demand
and get away from high carbon vehicles
thank
you thank you uh representative Cali
pittz I I just wanted to say that I
respect my colleague Rebecca but I have
problems with some of
the some of the premise in the bill I do
believe that New Hampshire has a choice
I couple of years ago I drove an
electric vehicle and I was quite
impressed with it and I know that if I
go into a dealership and say no I don't
want the blue one I want the black one
he says I don't have a black one he'll
go get it because dealerships work
together they want to move
vehicles um I think that we should be
moving toward vehicles but I agree with
chairman Vose that it's premature I
think infrastructure in New Hampshire is
part of our problem in a couple of years
I think we'll be there well I hope we'll
be there but I think that's the problem
now is infrastructure in New Hampshire
so I think that we should and that we
understand from the dees that they've
got money and things are happening with
the Volkswagen money so I think that uh
right now this bill is a little
premature sorry
Becca thank you representative uh
representative
ssuch
thank you Mr chairman um well I was
interested to hear your comments um
however as a physicist I read these
articles constantly and there's always
new technologies coming out and there's
many people who have different opinions
but the bottom line is uh the world's
car makers have already decided what the
business Market is going to look like
and the rest of the world is also moving
ahead in this direction so that's
undisputable uh also we have other
Technologies like was mentioned before
hydrogen fuel cell vehicles are already
available in California and that is is
something much more easier to handle
than even the lithium ion batteries so
uh and and in addition Battery
Technology is getting better all the
time uh they're going away from rare
earth materials uh now the newest thing
is zinc oxide Nano bubbles as being a
replacement and these materials are
available to us readily everywhere so
that's going to change dramatically uh
so um and if we look at the fact that
our offshore wind generation might
produce not just uh electricity but also
hydrogen uh there's all kinds of
opportunities so I think there's no
reason to be pessimistic about this
thank
you thank you representative
Thomas uh thank you Mr chair um I'm glad
represent s has brought up the hydrogen
I recently attended via Zoom a uh
seminar on the
northeast um I guess opening if you will
uh of
um I forget the the association but it
was about hydrogen producers and and how
they were uh citing that they were
opening up the Northeast to hydrogen
development for the purpose
in many ways uh for vehicles but more
importantly for industrial equipment and
uh I can say now that at least 25 years
ago I always said I'm going to wait for
the hydrogen car to come along because I
thought that was a good deal and so I'm
I'm optimistic about hydrogen and uh and
the use
in vehicles so again I do believe this
is premature which is why voting for
ideal but I think hydrogen is
good possibility for feature far above
what uh representative McGee is next
thank you Mr chairman um so I I just
wanted to say the bill is actually for
Lev ANZ so low emission Vehicles as well
as zero emission vehicles um in talking
with just my colleagues on the
Democratic caucus of STNA I I don't know
how many folks FKS have either a low
emission vehicle or a zero emission
vehicle but can you raise your hands
because there's quite a few of us I
think everybody right look even Nick so
so my point is you may have the
perception that it's premature I have an
electric vehicle there are supercharging
stations on the way to conquered on both
sides and hooks it uh and there's a you
know bunch of places where you can plug
in I went to the coast not too long ago
a little bit of a break be you know
after the elections and the place that I
stayed had a charging station for my
vehicle I have a charging station in
it's really not a problem the car
doesn't run out it's not like it's a
Tonka toy you know I mean they're very
welld designed they've come a long way
so the idea that we as a science
committee are talking about the
technology and saying well wait a minute
we need to be cautious we are the dut
hole in the region and that was covered
in the testimony and car manufacturers
are all coming out every day there's a
new major car manufacturer saying the
date by which all their cars will no
longer be combustible engines so it
isn't future it's it's now it's
something that from a policy standpoint
we're supposed to be preparing for at
this moment so I I disagree that it's
it's premature to to just say that New
Hampshire wants to open up its dealers
to having Les and zevs available so more
people can access them because as is
Testament we didn't all consult each
other when we bought our latest Vehicles
it just happened because we want to be
contributing to lowered emissions and
we're not the only ones so that would be
my argument against iing a bill that is
clearly uh
relevant thank you uh representative
oxen is
recognized okay thank you very much um
and in as each person speak something
that I wanted to say get said and so I
have to drop that out now I have to to
revamp where I am as to the donnut hole
not only is this an issue about selling
Vehicles we have a thriving tourism
business that is an essential part of
New Hampshire's economy there are t
there great infrastructure for zevs in
Vermont in Maine in Quebec in New York
in Massachusetts we are the dnut hole
people planning their vacation say oh
avoid New Hampshire let's not go to New
Hampshire this this is this is not being
forward-looking this is not being um the
Science and Technology Energy committee
policymaking instrument that I think we
should be I certainly support this bill
hope you will
too thank you representative Harrington
is recognized for a
comment just sort of a general comment
on a lot of the things we've been
talking about we've heard now we've been
hearing for for many many hearings about
how New Hampshire's the dut hole New
Hampshire's behind all these other
states are so much more Progressive and
better than we are you I look around and
you know this summer I was up in North
Conway and they were telling me it was
the busiest summer they ever had and all
these people from Massachusetts were
just pouring up there from New York and
Connecticut and New Jersey and they were
all coming to New Hampshire and you know
we have the lowest unemployment rate and
the best economy of all the New England
states so I'm just kind of getting sick
and tired of hearing that we're behind
everybody else no we're the Envy of the
rest of New
England we had low covid rates was the
reason they
were okay representative recogniz
representative par is recognized for
comment
call it but representative um Sherman
vks but uh representative Herington I
don't think anybody was disparaging New
Hampshire generally I think we're
focusing on a specific uh individual
Point here and I think this is a point
that we'll make New Hampshire an even
more attractive place to live I know it
would be for me and I would also like to
answer another comment that was made
earlier about the availability of these
cars yes I could have waited four to six
months to get the kind of car that I
want
but why you know I live in a in an age
of instant gratification was there in
the lot or waight and I want to start
driving it right away I would just like
to have the same options that people
have in all the other states around us
and maybe that's the donut hole is we're
not availing ourself of being on The
Cutting Edge of Technology if we choose
to be not everybody's going to choose to
go there but this is about choice and I
think it's about making a good choice
thank you again
thank you representative uh
Bernardi yes thank you Mr chairman
uh I want to just uh uh payback off off
of Representative Harrington's comments
I do not think we're the donnut hole and
you folks in the Democratic caucus
validated that you all put your hands up
and said I've got my electric vehicle
flavor it
was uh
representative CIP pit said if you want
to get one you go to the dealership and
say I want this the dealership will go
to main Mass if they don't have it bring
it up you'll have it I know that's how
dealerships work I don't believe we need
to set punitive standards here against
dealerships in order to make this happen
the market will make it happen if people
want it if they don't want it they won't
be
there representative BR is recognized
for her comment uh thank you Mr chairman
my comment is very short this uh this
bill grows government and I don't think
we need to go grow government in order
to sell EVS in neire thank
you representative representative
C just want to correct something not
every Democrat raised their hand because
I'm a poor Democrat and I couldn't
afford I could not afford a car and I
wonder about people in my class elderly
people people living on on fixed incomes
these cars are very expensive
and there's not many of them around so I
right now if you want one you can get it
and the proof is that there were plenty
of people who raised their hand so I I
just make my
point okay thank you representative C
pitz representative Harrington you're
recognized for a
comment yeah I'm just you know these
cars they're out there they're available
and I've got uh thou I mean like all of
us we get hundreds bab it's working on
thousands of emails a week now on all
sorts of different things I've never had
a single email from not only my own
constituents from anyone in New
Hampshire from anyone any place that
said we are having a hard time buying an
electric car so I just don't I just
don't buy that argument don't get there
people right off that I was reading a a
fascinating study just a couple of days
ago came out of California I think it
was Northern California they studied uh
the number of kilowatt hours at homes
that bought electric vehicles versus
their usage before they bought the
electric vehicle and they also studied
uh driving patterns and they discovered
that most Electric vehicles are
considered by most families at least in
California as a second car uh it's not
their primary vehicle they use their
electric vehicle
for I don't know maybe pleasure driving
or short around town driving um so even
in California apparently they don't rely
on their cars they're their electric car
is their primary vehicle uh
representative MC Williams no sorry
representative cam brils yes I just like
to point out that this bill assumes that
availability is going to increase demand
when in actuality it's demand that will
increase
availability the market
work okay representative MC
Williams I just want to address a couple
of points that have been brought up um
first there was the concern about this
bill being punitive um yes there is
language in this bill that threatens uh
a fine if the requirements are not met
however historically looking at all the
states around us in New England and this
potentially punitive requirement no
other state has issued a fine in the
time that they have been adopting have
have had these regs and that's over 10
years no one has been fined for that so
while it's on the books it hasn't
actually come to the point where uh
there is a fine issued for for failing
to meet that requirement so that's Point
number one um Point number two we're
talking about a chicken and egg problem
here so saying that there isn't enough
infrastructure in the state of New
Hampshire in order to push for Zev and
LS and that includes both hydrogen and
electric um that that kind of begs the
question of well do we need to get more
cars in New Hampshire before we focus on
more infrastructure do we need to get
more infrastructure before we focus on
more cars the answer is we need both
it's not just one or the other um and
then finally I I just I have a a
fundamental concern saying that this
increases the size of government
um we're talking about one more staffer
at Dees to manage the program this is
forward thinking this is something that
we're going to have either way we're
going to have someone who's in charge of
tracking what happens with Zev and LS
because let's be honest it is the wave
of the future it's what manufacturers
are creating and at some point this
legislative body will pass some kind of
a bill to address the road usage fees
probably not within this committee but
who knows uh so we will need to have
someone Staffing to address new modern
vehicles either way so it is a potential
for double dipping and the staff time is
going to happen it's inevitable so thank
you okay thank you representative MC
Williams representative Harrington
you're recognized for a
comment sorry I've done it again I
didn't lower my
hand okay thank you well seeing no more
comments uh oh representative clet
you're recognized for a comment I just
want to know what kind of donut I might
like
it donut guy
representative you have been missed
representative PL it's just it's just
the hole it's not the
donut well we now know that FL Fred is
back and healthy because he's making his
old same old dumb jokes thanks FR GL to
see C of game glad you're back Fred it's
good to hear so I'm going to call uh the
vote on this bill now and ask our clerk
to call the role on HB 168 the motion is
itl so Mr clerk yes representative
Thomas yes representative
Harrington trying to get my video I'm
trying to get the video up and it's not
coming but yeah there it is uh yes
representative ner yes
representative mner yes representative
PL says yes representative Beres yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative cambrell yes
representative PL yes representative
white yes Representative suuch no
representative Kelly pittz
yes representative
man no representative Ox no
Representative
Vincent
representative McGee no representative M
Williams no representative cran no
Representative
pel no Representative parel no chairman
votes chair votes
yes uh I think believe the votes
129 okay uh with a vote of 12 to9 the
motion of itl on issue
168 passes representative n will write
the majority report representative ssuch
will there be a Minority Report and who
will write it yes I think uh represent
MC Williams will you be writing that
I'll write it what's my deadline
Wednesday uh Wednesday by noon thank you
thank you representative MC Williams
will will write the uh Minority
Report and and that allows us to
complete the action on the exec session
for HB 168 so we'll close that exact
session and I'll recognize uh
representative Thomas who has some
information about something that
happened earlier today yes earlier this
morning it was pointed out I hadn't seen
the calendar yet but it was uh now I
have it was pointed out that the vote
totals for 614 and 624 were incorrect in
the calendar I asked our research person
to check into that and for um for
624 uh the clerk that is Paul Smith came
back and said yes it was AAL error the
vot toal should be 11 to9 instead of
191 so they're aware of that 614 I'm I'm
not entirely they're still checking that
I not show theol should be 11 to 10 but
I I don't
have I can't go back and verify that
so represent VIN on a couple of those V
it's possible yes we were they were take
it on the same day I missed him on a
coup anyone take not
that yeah Mr chairman if you remember
that was the bill that had a tend to tie
tie
initially and we came back in the next
hearing and there was a reconsideration
of the bill in which case it was 11 to
okay that's what's in the calendar is
119 11
no two
votes and and we had an
amendment that was passed 12 to8 and
after that was otpa 11
to9 but that's what it says in the
calendar 11 119 is correct was a
question about both v no
no
yes that's what the calendar says I know
best way to do it is read off who voted
what well I'm sure we have it okay well
it appears now there was one uh typo in
the calendar and one bill that is listed
correctly yeah so that's that's what
representative Thomas wanted to inform
you all about would have been solved if
we didn't reconsider when you told us
you weren't going to reconsider
it thank you for that uh representative
McGee so I would just remind everyone
that we will reconvene here on uh Monday
morning at 10 a. we'll be hearing three
more bills HB 549 I believe it is and
then a continuation of
hb13 and HB
315 and after that we will do some more
executive sessions and I will send
representative ssuch a list of the bills
that we hope to EXA that day we're
making great progress we EXA eight bills
today
so um we're getting there and I want to
thank all of you guys for your hard work
uh you've been you've been
uh doing yman Duty on these bills and
and I appreciate it the discussions as
always are enjoyable and
fascinating hope you all have a great
weekend and Mr chairman if I may just
remind people on 2113 they should have a
amendment in their inbox M correct and I
will point out to people that you will
all be receiving an amendment HB 315 I
just got it from OS about an hour ago
and I will send it out this evening to
everyone so you'll have the entire
weekend to peruse it so all right thank
you so much I was G to have nothing to
do over this weekend now I know I could
something was gonna be so bored yes it's
gonna be so boring otherwise yes no we
can get the wife to um shovel the snow
to sit
around John if you can do that you ought
to write a book because I've never been
able to figure out how to get my wife
shovel any snow so oh my wife is smarter
than that yes she's okay we're done
we're we're out of here very much be
safe on the way home everybody be yeah
drive safe I would take offence but I
never shovel